[Music]
n
yes sir mik check mike check what's
going on geek the
sneak what it do PE what's going on oh
Christopher har what's going on good to
see you brother especially
condolences show love show love
condolences to you and your family no
doubt JM the OG Von I see you what's
going on I'm a love with Sig ghost fixer
what's up what's going on live Supremacy
what's going on Lieutenant Hulk the
lieutenant no doubt what's going on Zach
rally robot n what's going on Lord
Metroid what's going on no doubt dark
streamers I see you E I see you salute
salute young Dred the artist I see you
no doubt we going to get this thing
rolling in a bit oh it's your 38th
Michael oh happy b day happy BN day no
doubt salute we will get up in the ram
see y'all in a minute be
back here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y to messed up and turn me to an
animal and heades be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's arson up in the
apartment and call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting and range you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm antisocial love
my city but I'm still by coal I got's
Swit what did you doing Don't Stop N
that was dope keep that keep that keep
that going keep that going n Go look I
guess you could say that I'm very spoil
feel to be your dog they very loyal but
I ain't going to hold you I ain't heard
the boy you ain't got to say it I'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making Vault try with
a gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell a uber cuz it's pretty hard
to sleep on Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am
um what's important is that you are
pulling up to the iron Lord's podcast
right now as we speak and uh I guess I'm
here to keep you entertained until it's
time to get this show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and head be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they they it's saring up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the RS you just a Target when
I'm in the range I was the hardest start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm antisocial love my city
but I'm still by coal I got let's switch
that up what did you do don't stop no
that was dope keep keep that keep that
going keep that going go ahead look I
guess you can say that I'm very spoing
to be your dog thing very loyal but I
ain't going to hold you I ain't heard
the boy you ain't got to say it I'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making Vault Tron
with a gang of cougars and I'm going
places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep I'm Freddy KW good
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do in um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y to messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's arsing up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting and range you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless back when
you was messaging people on AIM check my
vocals all on Twitter but I'm antisocial
love my city but I'm still by Coastal I
got now let's switch that
what did you do don't stop that was dope
keep that keep that keep that going keep
that going n Go ahead look I guess you
could say that I'm very spoil to be your
dog they very loyal but I ain't going to
hold you I ain't heard the boy you ain't
got to say it I'm embarrassed for you
always been a nerd never been a loser
making vultron with a gang of cougar and
I'm going places better tell a uber cuz
it's pretty hard to sleep on Freddy
kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and head be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because can Bank on me being
accountable I know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable I kill a beat and
they want to compare me to Freddy and
Jason I rather be Hannibal they be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all too Dramatical I know it's random
but I addicted to flipping the sample
and making it flammable this is that
this is that Yoga Fire Flame they think
it's sarson up in the apartment they
call it department and I get the blame
still I'll be running collecting the
range you just a Target when I'm in the
range I was the hardest of start
regardless back when was messaging
people on a check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm anti my but I'm I
[Music]
got keep that going go ahead look I
guess you could say that I'm very spoil
to be your dog thing very loyal but I
ain't going to hold you I ain't heard
the boy you ain't got to say it I'm
embarrass for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making Vault Tron
with a gang of cougars and I'm going
places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am U
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y'all missed up and turn me to
an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being aable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Aron up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
and range you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on
check myter but I'm anal love my city
but I'm still Co I
got don't stop that was dope keep that
keep that going keep that going n Go
ahead look I guess you can say that I'm
very spoiled feeling to be your dog
thing very loyal but I ain't going to
hold you I ain't heard the bo you you
ain't got to say it I'm embarrassed for
you always been a nerd never been a
loser making Vault Tron with a gang of
cougers and I'm going places better tell
a uber because it's pretty hard to sleep
on Fred kruer
that's let's do that again
here you here you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started I am well it's not
important who I am um what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a accountable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they they can Saron up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the rign you just a Target when I'm in
the r range I was the hardest to start
regardless back we was messaging people
on AIM check my vocals I on Twitter but
I'm antisocial love my city but I'm
still by I
got's what did you do don't stop that
was dope keep keep that keep that going
keep that going n look I guess you could
say that I'm very spoal feeling to be
your dog thing very loyal but I ain't
going to hold you I ain't heard the boy
you you ain't got to say it I'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making Vault Tron
with a gang of cougars and I'm going
places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger
that's
let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertain until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y got to messed up and turn me
to an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Aron up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the range you just a Target when I'm in
the range I
[Music]
was
call loud and clear aam
ofation not on
me I C theis
ofial near the river St lawence with the
[Music]
I'mma just chill and watch them and
snacks in the attic I wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young
Whooper then they will mistake me for
adct if I can imagine it's cool to give
you some advice then invite your girl to
your squadron cuz if you don't give her
that option you going to be single
player like Sovereign you going to get
tossed in the bushes by King David
royalty and not a pretender detrimental
to a Elemental what a avatar to a knee
Bender I got to be NE I know it's my
destiny work to Caro who cares if you
fly if you stealing mosquito swear you
ain't something but really be steo you
like to collect stuff and that's cool
but I got bad news even if you really
was that dude can't never still be the
king of the statu since a juvenile I've
been cursed with a curse to be Musical
and if you hate it we'll meet in The
Crucible other than that it's cool and
it's beautiful we let you know that your
dreams are pursuable whatever you want
to do then it's doable if you got work
on a Sunday is suitable cuz you can
listen to this in your cubicle on the
Lord's
day if you got work on a Sunday a suable
cuz you can listen to this in your
cubicle on the Lord's
[Music]
day all right Mike checking
mikeam kills you with D do
[Laughter]
that addict mike check her mike check
her excuse me you're
PA k m check M
check no doubt all right you hear ye and
we are live and welcome to the iron
Lord's podcast LLC and also live on
Lords of gaming.net episode number
339 it's another glorious Sunday we're
back at the round table on the Lord's
day and today we've got rumors of a new
Xbox third party
strategy
understatement Xbox Gaming revenue new
PlayStation and Xbox handhelds and
Playstation state of play to discuss so
we going to get right into it so let's
introduce the while we're missing
one always always missing one the the
Lord the the Messiah himself we we do
not see him today no no he should be
hopefully joining in progress shout out
to our brother sof send some love while
he's away now he back you hate to send
the love you hate to send the love yeah
what you g to have to say that love for
when they need it though oh right on Q
hold on right on
Q live okay okay from The Dungeons of
where he at can I get can I get a bunch
yeah you want to run me poorly poor no
you sound good you sound good yeah I'm
on the run you know I I I I went out and
leaked all that Xbox information
yesterday look where I'm at again you
doing your Messiah things your sofam
things it's crazy what do you mean about
a portable Xbox or oh this guy this guy
okay what's going on I'm gonna be
hopping in and out because I thought
this was this situation was was set and
it's really not oh it's
notum back and forth so I'll be here
when I can so you get you get intro and
then and then after that you can dip and
then come back for when come if you got
time if you got time back back back and
forth back and forth all right no doubt
no doubt and so let's introduce to Four
Horseman for United you already know my
co the co Mo my brother from another
mother the difficult game conqueror lord
of the spin clap and the how of the
young wolf my man Lord adct back to back
the atct show how we doing doing pretty
good man you
know come on here and I was going to
talk about
you but I ain't got off power worlds in
like a
week so
addic I am I I I see what's funny is my
girl getting mad because I'm because I
used to only play when she was playing
but uh now I'm just like
look play you don't oh wait you gave it
an
ultimato yeah it's either you you you
you with this life or you you you you
got Dr custody of this life wow that's
that's different Power causing problems
in the in the
relationship they said adct you sound a
little low they said adct is Sol a l Sol
is
remote yeah I can't see the live feed
and I don't know it's it's my work uh my
work wi-fi blocking the uh the live feed
yeah join is block my it's fine I yeah
they they trying to make you productive
at work no YouTube for you
that yeah yeah you crispy crispy you
crispy so continue continue I have no I
have no YouTube Right nah n you good you
good now YouTube's up though but you
good good adct you
saying the wrong mic is picking no you
good now you good you good you sound
great if for some reason it always feels
like on their end it doesn't I don't
know but yeah U you know pretty addicted
to power worlds I've been enjoying my
time with the game you know I shared cuz
I was fighting a legendary yesterday and
I shared a clip from me fighting it like
you're not really supposed to fight
legendaries like that it's generally
supposed to be like you your pal versus
the legendary but I found out that if
you build a base near the legendary on
the map and you lure it to your base
every pal at the base will clap that
thing for real that's crazy and what's
funny is like you guys didn't even see
half of it that that
legendary was destroying my team where I
had to switch it out three or four times
he killed he didn't kill he he he
knocked out probably 30 PALS like back
to
back he's fighting
incredible you got you got you got that
Anubis Andis putting in work no see see
now I'm on this okay now I'm on this uh
quality over quantity thing it's okay
I'm not going to send 30 PS at them I'm
going send six that's strong that knows
what's up strong f
you saying the beefy pis right now R and
tble P but but see Anubis is you know
AKA lario 2 that's the Pokemon name
larus so pretty much what what Anubis
does is
ludicrous i i in order for me to like
make him the strongest he has to be I
have to breed him like 100 times I can't
with this I can't with this that was wow
that was crazy that was
wow the the thing is though is the the
goal because they have passive traits
you want you want your pal to have the
best passive traits and they keep
passing it uh from from whoever is
currently like if if like the the mom
and the dad have certain traits that you
want they can they can get mut uh M uh
mutations or have different traits but
what you want to do is try to get
everyone to have like the best traits
you want a pure
blood the
best J yeah you got
to you got to sir I already know what it
is at least at least not coming from
adding yeah definitely that's that's
that part's not a go so it's been it's
been pretty much power world and
everything else has been on
hold yeah I ain't played nothing but
power world I feel you if I'm not
grinding like uh legendary uh spheres I
I'm trying to to fight the the the
legendaries in the game and they're not
they're they're no joke they I came
across like there's there's a pair of
legendaries in the game where you have
to fight them both I'm sitting here
trying to Dark Souls them like trying to
pick one here here over here like trying
to separate them so I don't have to
fight them together hilarious no doubt
and of course we have our most technical
gaming Lord the solo gamer who lives for
the single player selfish experience and
also the s adamis the Lord of crowns and
Messiah of IOP see I said it in a nice
tone Lord
it you looking like a prophet today the
Lord PR of the iron bank PC Master races
oh Lord s how we doing sir I'm good I'm
on the run yet again you tell you know
voice is a little muffled I'm in the in
the dungeons you know thanks to my
homeboy El Chapo for hooking me
up tunels doubt but yeah I'm at work
today so um yeah I thought it was going
to just be kind of relaxed but I got
some stuff that I do have to do so I
like man so I'll be end and out
hopefully for for for the topics but
yeah what have I been playing so what
you been playing continue to grind uh
the uh Prince of Persia lost Crown
playing a little bit more of that I mean
again the good thing about that game
Metro brains in general right go
checkpoint to checkpoint and kind of it
it and this one in particular doesn't
really job of of you being able to place
um sort of markers in places where you
know you have to come back once you get
a certain power whatever so you're not
lost right so that I'm so doing that a
that Tekken oh oh let me hear Let me
hear this king is a
problem King is a problem I mean our
King is a problem but you talking about
the tech
character this yes that that ouring is
problem oh my God bro they gave this man
the links that he has now crazy right
and like any like any King moves like
you can get out of them right there's so
many there's so many change ups there's
so many change UPS now that really he
has so many weapons to stay in damn near
rain zero in your face that it's kind of
crazy like it really is crazy he's not
as fast as other characters he makes up
for it in power he makes up with in
variety um and he just like they they
they did my man right so I'm happy I'm
learning all these strings uh hopefully
be a problem at some point when I get to
play with y'all yeah you got to get we
got to get the the player match going
with the crew it's like the rotation
back in the day pass the controller and
it got spectator mode for everybody
who's not participating in the immediate
match player match is fire bro oh my God
and then Brian Fury I want you know a
little bit with Brian Fury
that he just I've never seen a character
enjoy beating people down so much is his
disposition you're getting like really
really bad feedback off your mic I'm
getting I wonder what it
is know like it's bad like interesting
okay that's why I had you mute because I
muted to see if it me and when I told
you to mute it just went away the moment
you muted I would turn your Bass Down is
it like on 10 or something like that's
what it sounds like it sounds like that
my my um my P track yeah it's down it
could be me just folding the whole thing
no no it's not true they saying it's me
it's called
interesting I would turn that down and
then turn your your Zoom settings up
because that's the only way you're
window setting or uh what you call it
setting or zo settings well you just
turn your turn your mixer thing from
seven to like a like a six yeah it's a
six now it's a six now oh then turn it
into a five I don't know what's going on
but it it's not listenable unless you
just keep muting yourself oh wow okay
keep going I mess around yeah so um that
and then yeah I remember I told you guys
there was a game time decision that I
had to make on a certain game and I went
ahead and did that so um I I got uh
Suicide Squad it's not it's not me it's
Cog I literally like troubleshooted
during the show they they say in the
chat they say like Cog is fine it's
everyone else but maybe but see the
thing is is the moment you mute the
sound went away the feedback went away
like it's yeah it's the buzzing that's
what I'm saying Lucic it's like it's not
me I I muted all right we'll figure it
out we try to figure it out once I
disconnect fix hold on MAR changing oh
maybe maybe now it's fixed it because I
think it's Zoom I think it's I see Zoom
saying um Zoom didn't have my default
mic what about now check now P sound cuz
Zoom just gave me an update like it
didn't see my mic and now it sees it so
we'll see no continue I'm sorry off I'll
mess it up you take talk yeah no so uh
whatam call call it uh Suicide Squad I
played a little bit of it um just enough
to see kind of the movement the differ G
it's gone yes I fixed it
yay some of the differences that the um
the characters have um but I haven't
really done much else I haven't you know
really seen like a much a story scenario
because every time I try to connect I'm
always in some place that shuts my
internet down so of course it's a
service game so if you don't have a
consistent internet connection it's not
allowing me to play offline so even if I
am just playing single player so um but
so far I mean I I like the movement of
the characters you know I have I have
it's this is another situation where I
have to analyze the game on its merits
and not project onto it what I want it
to be you know so So eventually you know
I I have more to say about it but I'm
you know there's a lot of really low
numbers there and I really have to see
what you know if that lives up to that
because from what I've seen so far the
game moves well plays well it's a matter
of how fun it is you know in the long
term but again I can't I haven't played
enough to make that assessment but yeah
so polarizing right do you like though
yeah I mean I haven't played enough to
really say that I like it or don't or
not i' I've just been able to mess
around with each of the characters a
little bit to see their move sets a
little bit and that part has been cool
but uh again I need to I haven't like I
yeah I saw that I installed it live on
the show you re you uninstalled it live
but you know what it is thinking about
it now
second is a hard game for to come into
he don't want do special style he will
act like he veteran super nice okay I
mean I can appreciate that but if you go
that route it is more difficult because
again even though we find it simplistic
in like you know the the here's my thing
here's my thing the reason I refuse to
use special style I'd be damned if if I
start learning the game through a
gimmick that you guys make fun of and
then when we playing all you guys doing
is making fun of me playing n here's the
thing first of all when you're doing
story mode you're play with a character
that you don't even like teken is about
your identity with a character supposed
to look at the roster and be like okay
that look like a dude I'm WR that look
like a style and I'm a flow with the
story is forcing you to play Jin right I
even don't really use Jin like that so
he doesn't like Tekken is a thing when
you start messing with a character and
things start flowing natural then you
form your identity with the character so
right that's your problem right you're
in a situ it's not your problem but in
the story mode because you're with JY
the whole way
and this is a character that doesn't
feel good to you it's going to be weird
right so that's why I said with you go
to I mean do the story story it's fire
you got to get it done but after you do
that I would say go to Arcade Quest
because then you can pick who you want
and then learn the game while it's
teaching you with your little you know
your little Me avatar or
whatever eventually yeah no doubt that's
not like but it's a 3D it's a 3D fighter
like you know obviously like a something
like 2D like a street fighter is a
little little bit easier to get into
it's a little more simple it's just one
plane to worry about now you're worrying
about multiple planes side to side
movement I get it um but but KAG is
completely right like it if you basing
it on the story mode yeah because it's
just like Mortal Kombat where they force
you to play with all these different
characters you're mostly playing with
Jen but there's a part I don't know if
you even got to it where there's an
actual tournament in the story yeah yeah
that's where I race
right no doubt so you can play as other
character I got to the right part of the
brackets and I was like yeah the I'm I'm
good I'm good on this I'm all the way
good and I went to the the the the the
superior game power world that's what
this what he wanted to play power world
we know what it is all this interrupting
his power world time was getting on his
nerves he's like I don't like fighting a
I know how he do I know him but I it it
bothers me because I know you could be
good at them and what bothers me is he
is such an anime guy and if he the story
is like 4 hours like if he beats this St
35 minutes you want me to play other
three and a half hour yes and beat the
story just beat the story then you I
just want to talk to you about the story
cuz you the anime dude like they cater
into you you how about how about I just
you know just look the watch no we not
doing that YouTube video no we not doing
that messy continue s so that's it
that's it I'm done um yeah I will have
more to say about suicide squad next
week all right no doubt hold on you get
back into the to the caves where you
at want to he King's intro oh no
question question no doubt you already
know and of course we have the
incredible hus aka the EXs gamer oo the
prophet of Xbox Swami King of the
statues who demands nothing less than
that premium experience and is the
leader of the Xbox front line movement
beloved Lord King how we doing um I'm
doing good like okay okay okay these
dudes out here is crazy I don't know
when I became the um barometer of uh uh
gamer score or something like that you
the gamer score because it's it's kind
of crazy like I I've noticed like every
so often he be like yo look at his gamer
score he he doesn't play games like
where where was my gamer score when I
was playing on neoo like where was my
gamer score when I was playing on my
Genesis and all this other stff scores
are Untouchable yeah like and I'm like
you you've tied yourself to your digital
identity now these kids right and they
like look at me I got like 34
platinums um
okay but then you look at you see the
mentality is he's old playing video
games but his gamer scor is
low that means that when gamer score
started being calculated right I already
accumulated a gamer score on a
non-digital analog era that's a fact I
got it's called Memories right so y'all
can't talk about a Game Cube you can
talk about what you saw what you heard
about with a Game Cube and you look over
to us my gamer score doesn't equate me
and your platinums don't equate you so
when you start talking about oh I got a
thousand platinums and you got five that
means that you don't touch grass that's
all we was all in that pocket though in
of this generation we was all when we
were coming up that was the pocket we
were in like we were blazing doing all
this craziness whatever whatever but we
have no record because that stuff didn't
exists in our era it sucks so it's like
now if you got life and things going on
or whatever whatever you don't have that
you know a thousand on everything kids
is like yo look
at it is the competition is not there
you know we just don't get you know we
got to do work and all this other stuff
but listen questions oh oh what's up
what's up questions what's the question
what's up nobody's outraged with this
IGN
thing yes yes I mean it wasn't a topic
today but um yeah I'm just saying like
that one part because I got tagged in it
and I just had to mute myself out of it
got you which specific the Kevin conro
stuff yes that stuff oh okay okay okay I
saw something about Kevin Conway join I
saw something about an ending being or
something that's that's the extent I
know of it s you you know what's going
on I mean the initial thing was that
they you know kind of even the day
before the official release of the game
they had a video up sort of spoiling the
ending and it's like I you know when do
when do you ever see a spoiler cast up
of a game before it's officially re
released like it's like with it's just
it's weird Behavior weird behavior that
that can be interpreted as Petty and and
um yeah and then then the next thing
after that was kind of an opinion piece
talking about how hey um they did they
did Kevin Conroy dirty for his last
performance ever in this game because
and and the gist of it is obviously it's
it's killed the Justice League we all
know the premise that Brainiac has taken
over uh pretty much the entire world and
he's turned the Justice League so for I
guess for a decent portion of the game
I'm not sure about this but it seems
like a decent portion of the game Batman
is evil and but he's Kevin Conroy so you
know you know this this person I forgot
who it was who wrote the article
basically and saying that like this is
not the way you know that he should have
been you know since he passed away this
is not the last representation that
people want to see of him and then
somebody from the dev team said Hey
Kevin is my friend we worked for years
on these games um he loved every bit of
it he loved you know being able to sort
of stretch you know stretch his legs and
be evil Batman like you know every
moment that we spent you know recording
this stuff was joyous like I don't know
what why would you assume that as
somebody who doesn't know him and
doesn't know us and a lot of people
concur it's like okay that you know you
can you can come up and say hey I don't
like this for this particular reason but
I think the the tone of the article was
like nobody likes this nobody should
like this and it and it was stoking the
flame of more sort of in some instances
unreasonable hate for the game
so that that's kind of the gist of the
whole thing and it's like man like it's
like yeah I keep putting the foot in the
mouth when it comes to this situation
yeah I don't get that and what the
problem what's going to happen is that
the perception whether it's reality or
not is going to is going to come off as
if they're hating on this game and and
and when you have a series of events
that kind of contribute to that
perception it's going to be hard for
them to shake that that's just a reality
so yeah that's unfortunate and not being
not being straightforward about how you
really feel about it because again I'm
multiple sort of podcasts where it comes
up in within the IGN family um you know
there the mention is we didn't get
that's we didn't get Cod that's neither
that's neither here nor there but we
didn't get codes it's like and then you
know I get it because when other outlets
have gotten codes and other outlets were
able to sort of have a review out for
embargo and it's like okay this was
something that you know the publisher
decided in the best interest of selling
their game they business which is a
business if if someone want your opinion
out there no no but they didn't want
your opinion out there with the with the
general yeah you know day one and yeah
look this is a business I I'm sorry like
we we got to deal with the reality right
which is yeah Publishers and developers
want to give it to outlets that they
think let's be honest you know give them
a best shot right or the most Expos
right and you know reviewers or Outlets
thatour you know that cover games
whether it be IGN or games whoever they
benefit because if you have the hottest
game before everyone else in a one week
or two we window you're dominating SEO
you're dominating clicks you're
dominating because you're the sole
controller of that access and they have
to come to your site for the hottest
game so this is a business and what I'm
seeing that's just what me ad have
talked about it I see a push back for
Publishers I'm seeing Publishers saying
look either we don't like the way we've
been treated we don't like you know the
verbiage behind stuff or we feel and
they are starting to react so it is
interesting yeah get I already know you
love this topic and this particular in
this particular instance it's not that
they you know you can't be overt and be
like I know y you know you're gonna run
our game into the dirt and we don't you
know but in this particular instance I
think their feeling is they're not being
fair with that's that's what I'm hearing
from multiple Publishers internally a
lot of and this is including not just
out journalistic outlets and websit I'm
hearing content creators are being
evaluated and some people like hey well
they're picking and choosing but other
people are saying hey yo you're not
denied or entitled to any code you're
not it's the it's the it's at the
discretion of of the publisher gete yeah
the part that like irritates me it's
like you know what would have been a
better point of view IGN you know what
you should have done IGN when it come to
you're upset that you didn't get a code
you should just let IGN be aah desert
when it come to Suicide Squad info all
you really done is give them the the
traffic they actually wanted by by
[__] on it at any corner you
possibly that what you so it's just like
the the the part that's just crazy to me
it's just I don't want to ever hear
anyone from IGN call anyone else
entitled it ever again I don't want to
hear the that word even be vocabulary
for them because this I've
never seen a YouTuber or an influencer a
streamer not get a code and just start
sharing the ending of the game yeah
that's wild that's wild before the game
even came out yeah that's wow that's
different so this is my this is my uh
this is my statement straight to IGN
don't ever let me catch you saying that
that stuff again because every time I
see you saying that
I'm I'm I'mma share my own tweet and
it's GNA be any variety of tweet that
you've done this week because there's
multiple I can pick from there's
literally people might as well make a
part-time job right now talking down on
suicide squad even though I don't I
don't particularly like what I what I
play to the game you don't see me on
Twitter doing a straight
on like campaign against it oh they said
here's my thing if you get if you don't
I might be disappointed that I don't get
a code but you can ask Cog I've never
let the fact that I didn't get a code
affect my review of the game that's fair
that's fair it's always been like you
know I didn't get a Cod bomb and still
do what I can with it right and look you
know I I think these Publishers are
getting upset because there's too many
in genuine entitled babies in the media
that the moment they don't get something
that they feel entitled to they say you
know what we gonna do we gonna bomb your
gang
what then what they do is they act like
they're not going to they they was in a
room together they like we going to bomb
it we no they sat there in the in the
room together see here's the thing I
know for a fact that a lot of the media
look down on influencers and stuff and
the moment that they feel like
influencers streamers podcasters maybe
not necessarily as much podcasters they
feel like we shouldn't be here like we
we shouldn't be doing what they're doing
and some of us yeah and some of us are
making twice triple the money getting
that cold and messing around with Neil
Dr what the hell's going on over here
like look you know that's irritates me
because when I get disappointed and I'm
saying you know I'm disappointed I
didn't get like this code or that code
these same people on Twitter telling me
that I shouldn't feel entitled but the
moment they don't get one Cod they are
making campaigns against the game yeah
it's interesting and it's not everybody
at IGN and there's some cool people I
got people IG so yeah please but at the
same time
anyone who participated in this I'm
sorry they they they they should have
the entire social media Stripped Away
from more review codes you choosing
violence today you you no but the thing
is is when you when you are when you are
trying to use your platform obviously
we'll never know if that's generally how
they feel but if if it is if they're
generally using IGN as a platform to to
punch down on a game because they didn't
get a review code early they should
never get a code again that's generally
what's going on now it could be this is
their their actual feelings but I think
it's more like they're playing oh this
this is cool this is cool but they
didn't give me that review code so it's
it's bad it's bad it's a five oh man
look look you know well I will say this
if that is the case hopefully it's not
it publish Publishers are watching
Publishers are watching so you know it's
all about engagement and someone else
will take up that that access so we'll
see what happens so it's full circle I
agree but um yeah anything else kiding
that was going on yeah I'm yo I'm I'm
glad that you remember cuz I was like
this was your segment but it's just a
small little thing it just got got crazy
um um I'm playing what you were doing
King yeah in Alex defense you did th lob
the grenade yeah you lob yeah okay you
do so what's up with IG he knew he KN
suicide he about no one outraged by this
there was no world on Earth there was no
Earth that if you talking about this
particular situation I was going to go
on a rank he what he was doing you know
that dude that be like yo you a here yo
it's crazy nether you ain't he what
happened D I
know he knew what he was doing continue
I heard I had
heard I'm playing bro oh oh yo so you
know I get addicted to those vampire
Survivor type games those Robotron games
it is Robotron and so much fun it's like
I said okay I don't I wanted to know why
why am I addicted to these games and I
was like oh yeah Robotron and Smash TV
stuff like that down yeah so I was like
yeah so this bro I'm so addicted to it
so I was between that and fortnite
trying to finish this battle pass and
playing um
bro excuse me that's all I'm doing oh no
doubt no doubt and of course you already
know you got the gaming ninja himself
the shobi Lord Cognito spread that Rin
in the r IOP that's telling you what you
want to hear but what you need to hear
shout out to fin dke Mr Manny plays have
my man Brad Ellis former um easy allies
that debuted on Duke with us talking
about the layoffs talking about the
future plans of Xbox um had shout out to
I ebontis on taiy Travis we actually had
this thing where Travis bought two
players that people who never played
Destiny before and then had them play
for the first time and get a honest
assessment and they like we don't know
what the hell's going on in this game
fired up four cutcenes nobody no story
Exposition and then like why they
dropped off you know kind of thing so it
was really funny as Dy man Bungie got to
they on B is horrible and people were
like well we'll see how the final shape
go but we we out for that wow yeah they
was out they was out so for me um yeah
it's been infinite wealth now that teing
slowly out my system I got the the gamer
score thing you know what I'm saying
which I normally don't do but during the
course of play the game you'll get it it
it's not that it's not that difficult um
yeah play Infinite wealth man it's
really heating up now I would say
chapter three oh my it's really cooking
I'm up to the part my man Danny Cho is
up in the joint that's crazy um yeah as
far as I would just I still would advise
if you've never played like a dragon do
not play Infinite wealth the first two
chapters start off very slow building up
right after so you're not going to have
a context you know what I'm saying and
you're not it's not like super action
heavy in the beginning it's more recap
heavy and funny stuff and Goofy stuff
you know what I'm saying kind of thing
but once they get to Hawaii oh it's on
and popping the SC I didn't know haai
Hawaii be scamming they got the scammers
out there boy it's crazy so yeah salute
salute on that um yeah gotta talk about
our good friends at uh NZXT man um look
I've been honest with you I know this is
soft PC Master ratio your Bild segment
I'mma Be real since I got the D I've
been using this for Content creation
right this is the AMD what we got the
player three joint you know what I'm
saying AMD Edition AMD Edition you know
what I'm saying what's what's our car
looking like it's crazy 90 something oh
I I forgot the exact but it is
essentially a 4080 40 basically we 4080
outside right so I'm going be honest I
gotta honest thing with the Lords like I
I didn't want to play no games
because there's a part of me that I I
remember what happened when ebontis made
me get my first PC in like 2017 for
creation and back then Destiny was 30
frames on
Console so I knew what happened when I
saw it I said oh no I'm not going back
it was one of those so I'm like all
right so now shout out to n6t you got
the new you know what I'm saying what
you call it monitor the new Jump what is
it what is it hold tell you the canvas
the 27f 60 on 165 um Hertz gaming
monister full HD with the HDR I never
had hdr on my monitors too so I got the
HD bro I threw on that cyber Punk first
with the Benchmark saw full full Ray
tracing reflection
Shadows all the bells well settings on
Ultra everything did you did you turn on
path Tracer now here's the thing when I
turn on path Trac it seem like R Trac
turn off no path tracing is different oh
so I try I didn't try that so I should
throw in the path Tracer what what
should I do yeah do that oh it's
different different oh that's different
bro I threw on the um the the joint and
I let the Benchmark run with the
Reflections in the P yo you know when I
knew the game was real the game I'm
seeing smoke coming out of smoke stacks
I'm going inside the the bars and people
you see I'm like oh like you know the
old school New York King with the bars
and saw with the bars smoking was
allowed in the bar and remember that
feel that Haze I was like hey yo I'm
seeing things I didn't even know existed
in the game I'm like oh man this is
crazy then I had the nerve to throw on
that Starfield with the
update oh no oh man I'm doing over 100
plus something
frames the character movement is so
responsive it's so silky I'm like oh
this is how it's supposed to be played
and this is a AMD chipset to and this
ain't even the FSR 3 yet this the FSR
I'm like oh I see why God Howard said
what he
said so we have the RX
7900x and in terms of the processor we
have a ryzen 77800 x3d which top of the
Topo I'm just going to tell you right
now listen py so K GRE and PC back look
I'mma give it up where I got to give it
up it's it's crazy that and plus the new
Starfield update like I don't I'm scared
to throw Tek I don't even want I don't
even want I don't that yeah so I'm
nervous for myself you know I need
strength right now in these difficult
times you know what I'm saying
especially Xbox getting on everybody
n especially if you put it on that new
monitor you put on that new monitor it's
a 108 I monitor I threw it on I right
now I'm using a new monitor like I said
with the HDR 165 Herz 240 what is it
fresh rate all that bro I when I just
looked at my desktop screen I was like
oh God oh God I was like
I your mouse is running back and forth
yeah I'm like why is this bad responsive
ex yeah it's crazy it's crazy yeah NZXT
god tier go get that in the description
if y'all looking at I'm telling you
everything they do is fire everything we
got more stuff to talk about we can't
talk about just yet we got more stuff to
talk about that's going to be crazy but
I had to shout out NZXT on that um again
the um it's it's all down I put the link
in the joint the canvas 27f on 165 put
the monitor in the oh you put it in the
description for me oh good luck yeah
that my it's and what's crazy is like
it's it's lowkey like like when you were
explaining like how good it looked and
the features I exp I was expecting a
couple more hundos on there like yeah
yeah ni right I'm just going to be real
console guys if you got a rig that can
run this stuff it's going to be
difficult for you to cuz now you looking
at Chico like
yep and Fabrication with the sad face
like oh this this what you doing AK
gaming lives look at slowmo pop up I got
my PC oh you got your case for SXT yeah
SXT man rock with them I got this is
this wasn't even ad promo I just had had
to give it up that joint is crazy but
anyway that's what I got but they did
send it to us I want to be transparent
with that they yes but but the thing is
is like they didn't even they're like
look you know shout it out for you that
will it's
like NZXT has been mad good to us guys
if you're looking to get a PC or
something man use the link we do
recommend like like this podcast it's
not a live one at the bottom left bottom
right no bottom left it says powered by
nzx this entire podcast is powered by
zxt it's all beef and all
power zxt g g g g no he only get the
best beef
yeah super beefy PC super beef if you
want the beefiest of P hey
yo show show King your
build show King he wants to see King
wants to see y'all show keep your builds
keep your builds keep your you don't
want people to show you to pull up show
no no no no what that keep your
bill your bill hi your bill okay fair up
fair up fair up no doubt so add you want
help with the super chats or actually I
have it on my phone I do this do s do a
remote work yeah yeah
so they couldn't stop my
phone all right we got a de the sneak
member for three months Lord bronze what
up Pete what up what's going on salute
salute y then we got Echelon 7 the $10
Super Chat peace to the Lords peace to
you
brother then we got Robert kellet $2
Super Chat joysticks and strange love
being wild with s's pal I
even whoa I'll be right backing you out
of pocket for that one if if it's that
greasy Latino pal want nothing to do you
hate that
one not a good look that's not a good
look for the culture the Latino
delegation did not
approve then we got SV $5 Super Chat do
you guys think that 2024 will be better
than 2023 for
gaming um better I mean last year was
crazy last year was crazy last year was
Bonkers this year I mean there's gonna
be some great games coming out year but
I think last year there's not many years
you can have the type of quality and not
necessarily just quality but output in
general oh last year everyone was firing
on all cylinders like everyone year
getting new hardware this year right
Nintendo but um beyond that yeah it's
going to be a good year I think though
last year everybody was like rocket yeah
was crazy then we got G $2 Super Chat
Brian Brian furer is for degenerate
right the ruler me you know that
remember remember that the Nazi joint
that they run every time a game come out
that blow out another
game the protate it out what the hell
m m Kombat was supposed to sell more
than I love that one I killing me
hilarious he he does have fascist
qualities yeah very very fascist yes yes
so we have Michael Mooney five pound
Super Chat exp's third party strategy
let's let's give them games that they
can't make once they have peaked
engagement okay oh that's what we doing
okay I see I see what we doing early
okay then we got zip da that's five
Super Chat zip with the drip with the
drip here zip here with another segment
of out of context Cog oh Lord summon
sign number five Cog says at the TW
minute 12 second Mark so you start to
feel it and then they start to you
out wow this guy right with the time
stamp damn with the pause time stamp you
gotta do it you got that's crazy that's
crazy you held on to that one all
right then we got Robert Kell $2 Super
Chat IGN Petty they got
blacklisted wow then we got J Mack
member of 39 months Lord Silva thank you
brother and we got G $2 Super Chat
titles can be
misleading titles can be misleading let
me hold on I got jump here uh Destin was
too
gungho okay I don't know be misleading
yeah yeah I guess you know the titles
where it was like the preview the
preview
cover right right I played the preview
yeah didn't like it yeah
yeah we got JM again5 in chat the more
the gaming media exposes themselves the
more focused the community should be on
controlling our narrative clearly core
rotten game media yeah I mean this true
this is amazing site Lords gaming.net
though I mean saying rocking out there
that's rocking if you if you really want
to support you know but I'm just saying
you know grass for
you know what I'm saying funny streets
you know what I'm
saying we got the legendary y you right
absolutely right legendary Yi $5 CH he
ain't The Golden Child addict anymore
he's evolved into Mad Dog
addict talk that sh messy move this over
then we have Lord pdtv $2 some I've been
around dirt too much no dirt hasn't been
around me yet yeah yeah Dirt has his
level of Beast yes we got Lord pdtv $2
Super Chat I was petty pettier than me
100% with
ading Messy then we got Doctor Strange
love5 chat not yet anyway nah kill the
justic lead deserves uh less than a five
that live service looter shooter slop
deserves all the criticism
The Rock City we knew and led is
gone I think they just made the divisive
game don't make what here's the thing
though here's the thing you can you can
criticize the game but posting the
ending to it like pretty much only uh
only tweeting about it for days that is
not just criticizing the game that's
trying to assassinate the game
especially in a story orientated game
like suicide squad where you can argue
to me that is I think the best thing
about that game is the story to post the
ending to the game which a lot of people
probably want to buy because of to me
that's beyond just criticizing when
you're an outlet like that should not be
trying to control the narrative around
the game that's not what you do as a as
a news Outlet it feeds into the
perception that's what that's the part
that's really unfortunate yep then we
got gamer by choice10 we have project
Aries put the crust in the chat for Lord
project salute
salute then we got gamer by choice $10
Super Chat much love to the Lords and
the realm salute one of the most
informative and entertaining podcasts it
is like watching Family discuss
something passionate keep doing what you
do salute Lord I love that one that's
love salute salute love man love we got
Hollywood rules $5 Super Chat happyy
Sunday to my NYC and West Virginia
cousins thank you for helping me through
my NFL football withdrawal shout out to
King and addict for a great show on
Friday oh thank you thank you and
portter rock 77 salute salute oh P Rock
came through
oh it was a great show yeah people were
talking about that on my live stream
afterwards they're saying you know
there's not enough of that that goes on
that's why like I do want to like kind
of address something a lot of people are
very upset with how we handled like the
state of play thing it's like look I
can't help that you guys decided to
watch a reaction of another Community
reacting to something that you wanted to
watch uh part of me feels like and this
is just me MH you should have watched
the actual program like I I don't like
to me that maybe the chat can disagree
and you probably will uh but I feel like
if you watch a re like your favorite
Community reacting to something you want
to see their reaction to the actual
content you don't necessarily care about
what the content is now you care about
it you are going to see it but you just
want the general idea of what's being
announced you don't necessarily care
about what's being said that's fair
that's fair and and I think normally and
the only there not even a push back
because I agree 100% with what you're
saying I guess the only thing I will
give them throw them aone is that the
the jdub king match up we did go I will
say will say jdub and King were
definitely little too so it's just like
in back in the in the house back in the
days the dudes is arguing and the fight
is like fight is on right so you
whenever your man get off yeah what's up
now that's what that is you know what
I'm saying it was a little more extra
that episode so I think maybe that's
what the push back is the the thing is
though I would have to see how these
same people would handle Jay du being at
a bad Xbox show and see if they would be
okay then like like to me is it just
because you know is it just because it
was a PlayStation are you applying that
during the Xbox was B Xbox
amoud King 247 I'm curious that they
would have the same issues that maybe
they would I don't know because the
thing about reactions the reason I do
them is because it it is one of the few
things that gets us in front of a new
crowd every time cuz people are always
looking for reaction so if you go off
the context and you don't know the show
and you're just coming in and you're
watching King and and Jay interact with
each other it might seem crazy CU you
don't know the context of the show you
never watched it so I can understand
that that's fair that's fair what else
we got Sol so adct was saying that they
upset cuz I was roasting a king okay I
got it I got it I got it that's what it
is
okay dragging the mustard Hots draging
them what you guys J Boy On The
Run I'm sorry Xbox gam is making
themselves crazy Xbox is doing what we
already know small what we already know
small exclusives multi big games know
always knew they wanted to do that we
will discuss open they open the door we
will
discuss we got Lucius Augustus $5 CH
lucious Xbox giving games to other
platforms where Game Pass doesn't exist
it's some Adam 22 energy and I
ate oh not the Adam 22 come on yeah come
on man put us in that man come on man I
got to get a soundboard of the the
Pokemon Stadium announcers saying that's
super effective
continue we got let me see that was
funny uh face 23 be can why $2 Jack Cog
moved to PC before Xbox went third party
yeah I had to dip out I heard I heard
xxt got me though I can play Everything
well Xbox said I can play everything
then we got then we got project Aries $5
Super Chat put five on SOL books he
sounds like he calling from jail salute
to the Lord
yo no they didn't say put five on your
book
thank you thank you for the commissary I
appreciate it we having some mac and
cheese tonight this call is from the
correctional
facility do you accept do you accept
this call from the correctional
facility it's about damn time5 Super
Chat my fiance just got me a Xbox [__]
I'd be worried fellas love to show it
well stay healthy wait why not there yet
I'm not there
yet no they out of pocket
continue then we got s to Sage $5 super
CH Xbox with Activision Revenue included
has just had a q1 and Q2 stronger than
any PlayStation q1 or Q2 in history Xbox
is nobody's charity case SSU is outside
all right you outside say I didn't hear
nothing about not going to the party oh
you on my boy come on let him
C they just real good is skirting the
you are your Messiah stuff continue read
the to damn super chats we don't want to
hear you right there love
your they all get
assassinated J Boy On The Run $2 Super
Chat I'm embarrassed by people crying on
Xbox at the moment oh
man I heard you guys got a couple of D
oh man that's crazy that's crazy then we
got Hollywood
rules5 can the XBox guys stop running
through the streets like Chicken Little
screaming the sky falling I do think
Phil and Cole we need to address it
though apparently it will be addressed
at some point they can address it all
they want these dudes are still mustard
Hearts we G to talk about it y they can
tell you in your face what it is and you
be like but but they going to do it I
know it I just know
it I just I feel it in my it's a feeling
it's a feeling it's a feeling I can't
you know what's funny cuz I I posted on
Twitter uh that I said you call me
mustard all you want and your people
came at me like I
expected D must HS go what you got here
we got dror strange oh here we go you
know when I change the tone of my voice
it's that kind there we go me and sa are
playing a similar game to power world
but it only involves ditto knockoffs and
a lot of scor fighting oh man he said
knockoffs he said y playing power world
to oh man that's
wow thank you for your patche
[Laughter]
violated that man damn we got J back
once again5 Super Chat it's not the
publisher or the developers fault that
you inject your sensitivity in video
games grow up and judge on merits alone
not your field that is correct all of us
want something to be what we want it to
be but it just is what it is
yep let it exist we s immediately come
back oh s is back on your head stop I
will drop a ,000 Super Chat every week
on for five weeks if Xbox go party not
happening wait wait hold on screenshot
that hold on Read that adct read that
again run that
back Sage be careful brother I Love You
Sage be careful I'm I'mma not accept
that because we love you too much we
can't let you go we can't the money you
pay your bills with Y yo yo yo yo yo
your word is your
bon he got to stand 10 to down you going
to stand on that one right there my guy
Sage we love you brother please we going
to give you a pass on that one we going
give you hey I want my cut so that's two
that's 250 that bch said he going to
drop a th000 Super Chat every week for
five weeks if XBox goes three and he
said not happening with his chest out
yeah yeah I want my cut yo so so they
don't want their so I don't know what
you g to do this but send my 250 my way
bro we we going to talk man we going to
talk I want you go out like this n we
can't do that my we we we we we try we
ain't trying to have you that's a lot of
money my dude that's a lot of bread
that's why I ain't giving it up give
my he he got to stand on he he standing
on business you got you got to stand on
business you got to stand on
business yo you stupid G you a fool he's
like nah that's what he said he said
what he
said's like you can just drop the full
thousand over our front line that's
right
yo thank you thank you for your
patronage about next Super Chat we got
to move on we got to move on list real
Qui like since I may not be around the
look I think they could again we we are
assuming that we want them to conform to
what we already know as right I think
Xbox could be the first ones to be like
you know what we're gonna keep making
hardware for whoever wants it and we
could and every damn single one of their
games could be third party it doesn't
matter because they're going to have
Game Pass for the people that are in the
Xbox EOS system if they want it if not
they could buy all car and they could
sell every single game in their in their
Library all aart to everyone else I
think as a company that is the ideal
situation this is what they want they
want to make as much money as possible
on every single game so this idea of a
third party can't also be a console
manufacturer we're talking about
Microsoft here they could do and that's
they could do whatever they want they
could decide not to do that that's true
and then you're going to owe us $5,000
but
some but I I just think we we're we're
too rigid with our thinking right now
they could they could do both it might
be because it's never been done you know
but at the same time there's a lot of
people that think a lot of stuff and it
don't work out for them sometime
sometimes you too early to to the new
wave and and that has been that has been
kind of their Achilles heill where
they're too early and everybody thinks
is the worst thing in the world and it
turns out to be the norm in a couple of
years true true that that has happened
before we we go damn so we ain't gonna
get you for the Drake because you gota
go I'm try I'm try you g try let's get
the super yeah get the super chats and
then hopefully like I said we get you
back for let me see we got
doctor sa is in
jail he needs to watch out when he drops
the soap unless he wants a visit from
do he had the demon made horns oh no
that's that's not about so soap on ropes
sir
he said he got to be quicker than
that uh oh no look it say jetsu sage is
about outside of the street screenshot
$5 Super Chat Sage screenshot it no pass
wow he's standing on business King good
that's crazy my my my cash app is is in
my
BIOS one more S one more one more to
jump there we got face 23 can why by $20
CH rumored games going into Sony and
Nintendo C of Thieves high five Rush
grounded Halo Master Chief Collection
flight him fight simulator right
got so we we'll see right those
absolutely those make sense um that
Master Chief Collection you might as
well just throw yourself off the nearest
bridge whoever sold you that one you got
throw up in the bushes you smoking bro
okay all that other stuff yeah but that
dude nope but that one remember that one
was live service that and no and that
one was discussed at the start of the
PS4 Xbox One generation it just yeah a
lot of things gonna be discussed in a
few moments all right we get to it we
got Lord rless 5 power Super Chat too
many one-sided rumors I'm not wanting
Phil to come out every time and squash
them I'm going on what was last said to
go where Game Pass exit you're standing
on it okay salute
salute yesterday terms and not today oh
damn s
damn I'm just saying we G get to it we
GNA get to it then we have Ethan the v v
with the 14 Zars I'm sorry I'm not
exactly sure what that is right now
looking up though I ain't hold in the
line they messy messy all right yeah
messy today I I'm gonna try my best to
jump back in no I feel you bro I feel
you I'll get the next one cuz I know you
got to go all right so cool
no doubt Luci August for 29 months Xbox
is the girl that ask you to pay for her
nursing school and as soon as she starts
her residency she leave you for a
Japanese dude Xbox yo Lucius out of
pocket out of pocket that was wild crazy
that was wild crazy that was wild funny
that was bad funny I ain't even going to
front though that was so look we got to
get into uh some more business before we
get uh started with everybody what
everybody want to hear so let's get this
for the occasion that we are here that
log that scribes of the month time you
already know what it is Lords and.net we
are blessed y'all we're blessed to have
some really really good talent fun fun
people just to to work with and that a
true game is um actually some of our
meetings are some of the best and
funniest meetings we go like two hours
some of these uh writers meetings but
it's really really cool and um again we
got some some great talents so we got to
celebrate one particular scribe of the
month who went above and Beyond in the
month of January he's been on an
absolute t with his opinion pieces
Persona 3 reload as well as everything
Sonic everborn you in trouble I found
somebody that might be more passionate
than you on everborn yet Sonic title is
in Jeopardy I'm just letting you know
right now so we proudly present the Lord
dizzy log neck scribe of the month to
Lord Sonic himself Robin kellet in the
realm Robin kellet speech speech
thank you guys so much for letting me
join in on chaos it's listen man listen
ien been listening to you guys for the
for well over a year now and it's not
gonna lie you guys got me through a lot
of tough stuff in my life and I can't
thank you enough for letting me hop on
and join I also can't thank enough the
Lords of gaming editor staff and Young
subscribes for dealing with my Sonic and
just I see the shirt I see the shirt
crispy too and I'm prepared for coffee
okay all right all
right um
and and a special shout out to editor
mood like he yeah mm he not he Not only
was nice enough to take my application
look at it which it didn't glean enough
was a sonic review but he every time I
get an article and I send it his way he
always gives me great feedback and but
special thanks to him for being being
such a bro I can't thank of enough and
the other editors and writers
and just like special thanks to my to my
to my sister okay who always has always
been like a big vock in my life
absolutely special thanks to to my my
late mother and grandmother
who were basically helped me become the
person I am and I'm not saying the
special thanks to like the specific
Place itself for you know privacy sake
but special thanks to my job for even
though they drive me
crazy it's uh special thanks to them and
uh no doubt the circus and everything no
doubt man congratulations you've been
absolutely killing it we love the
passion brother and again since you
jumped on it's been you know it's been
all all all on all the time man and I
love what you bring to the team you've
been killing it and uh look forward to
probably seeing you again at some point
make sure you hit up um solve you know
what I mean because we got to reward the
the scribes for what they do the
legendary Lord Sonic himself Robert
Kelly you got actual par King in the
chat okay yeah that's what I'm talking
about yeah Astro me and ashtro it's
gonna be great in for the the New York
for the West than media thing in New
York gonna get kicked out of the feeter
because we're gonna talk about Sonic and
Colin's gonna be like you got you too
cringe get the hell out he gonna pull up
I already know salute you already know
the legendary Robin Kelly appreciate you
brother no doubt and of course we got a
secondary award you know what I'm saying
it's a award that we considered for for
the editorial team kind of the lifeblood
of the site the backbone the editing the
teaching just behind the scenes and um
this editor has quickly risen to fame
the pillar of consistency and uh what I
definitely like he always crushes It or
Not only with his Warframe content Now
power world content you know what I'm
saying and just the voice of the site
with uh proper critic constructive
criticism were needed so we probably
present the Lord dizzy editor of the
month to all man AKA Lord Warframe AKA
Lord flame AKA Joe Repco what's going on
sir
congratulations well one I want to thank
everybody on the writing team after all
there's no reason for us to be around if
they're not here that is very keep
everything going Robert was absolutely
killing it this month we also had new
people like Billy the Brewer come in
come in start off strong he had take bit
of a short break and we have people like
Chris who submitted like multiple
articles in one night like he doesn't
stop I don't know where gets his time at
but yeah everybody there is just
incredible including Jean like even
though he's been on a short break too
like he is in the background doing a lot
of good stuff right now and I just want
to say thank you to everybody on the
team and of course everybody on the
editorial team who you know picks up
where I can't and you know people like
mood Gondor Nick especially considering
he's been going through something too
so yeah everybody going through
something now I appreciate you brother
and uh yeah you've been killing it
absolutely killing it and again just the
consistency and I love your interactions
when we have our meetings is really
really constructive so salute most of
them most of them is your
yeah no doubt congratulations make sure
you hit sub up I was surprised I expeced
some Destiny slander to come through and
you actually been nice today wow I I did
yesterday I need to taste
myself now we're celebrating persona
persona was celebrating that okay
Persona reload okay okay I see what it
is yeah we got something better on mind
so no doubt all right Brothers enjoy
your day again congratulations subscri
the month edit the month salute you
already know salute and good luck on the
topics holy crap the chat's gonna eat
you
guys you know I got my eye on you I have
a wrench I will Bonk anyone that comes
at any we G to see
goby I can't I can't wait for King man
to go crazy on the on the we'll see
we'll see what happens
on the mustard hot we going to see what
happen no doubt salute y'all no no one
can hold the
line both of y'all enjoy your day we
catch up with y'all you already know and
of course we got the poll real quick on
last week's poll results are in and the
people have spoken to the question with
all the recent layoffs within
Microsoft's gaming division which do you
find the most surprising the winner of
the four-way I with 51% of the vote
blizzard leadership departs group coming
in at second at 18% of the vote was the
other Xbox and zenax layoffs third place
at 15% of the vote was the physical
media and odyssey teams and then last
place at 14% of the vote was I don't
care don't think your favorite company
is it next so adct they said the biggest
surprise was Blizzard's leadership like
the aaras and I believe the other uh
what you call it president um the top
guy at uh blizzard that was also that
also left what are your thoughts
sir I think you
muted the blizzard thing I think people
knew I at the end of the day like when
you know we were talking about it last
week like I I called
it so it's just like and if and if I
called it other people called it it's
just you know the industry is about to
drastically change and we we going to be
talking about here soon so it's going to
be interesting to see what what goes on
man yeah no doubt no doubt so now it
time probably to get into these topics
so I this is yours you want me to set it
up because I got the um yeah I got a lot
of the stuff that changed up let's uh
pull this up actually one of the things
oh I got it now all right this is the
big one Xbox third party is the strategy
shifting so I guess you know obviously
we've we've heard Rumblings you know in
the past couple of rumors about
particular games that was kind of going
on for a couple of weeks but then we got
an idol SLO I hate to do this to you
friend of the realm I SL I hate to do it
because you have deleted this tweet but
uh the good friends on Twitter have
screenshotted your deleted tweet and I
do have it so again don't know if it's
still accurate but I have to read it
because this is what kind of set
everything off so according to agent
Deli which is um at agent Deli which is
a zamax product manager
Sarah Bon Xbox director will speak in
Spring to explain the change in Xbox's
strategy regarding Hi-Fi Rush SE of
Thieves and other games going
multiplatform then the quote was wait
couple of quotes are wait for Springtime
Sarah B will say something you guys will
be fine I'm assuming Xbox Community I'm
assume a summary of deli's other remarks
on this podcast he said this a lot of
this is metrics
driven internet discourse isn't
considered but concerns are valid okay
and regarding considered discourse if
looked at from a different angle there
is missing information that you I guess
us may not see Illusions to a very
concise explanation by Xbox about the
situation got to figure out what the
situation is that they going to give a
concise explanation upon um a secondary
speaker mentions that other people who
were concerned previously are now saying
we shouldn't be as concerned as we are
so again internal thoughts in the
building uh the big three Xbox Nintendo
you know PlayStation platform holders
have the liberty of Paving the road and
laying the brick at the same time very
interesting statement and one of the
final things was a lot of conversations
around this kind of stuff it's
ongoing everything discussed has been
covered and and or has a clause around
it so this one has set the internet on
fire so people fire huh what happened I
said fire huh uh oh should I should I
just go to King first I mean you know
this is a lot of people are are cons
yeah let's start with King let's start
with King cuz clearly clearly King wants
to talk so I mean look King you know a
lot of people are concerned they they
they feel that this substantiates the
rumors and then um obviously that it
looks like there might be a State of the
State of the Union Address from uh you
know Sarah Bond or whatever so what say
you King about this
situation Xbox dude
yo act like they're in a horror
movie I I see Michael
Myers I see Michael Myers yo
what what's up slowo what's up what's
going on King every week they're being
chased by a new
monster every week they're
fearful of a new subject he got a knife
he got a
gun I don't know what to do
General everybody breaking
rings I like how your lip moving
continue I'm so fearful King this third
party really scares
me you're a dog
oh okay get a spine you
jellyfish you mustard Hearts so are they
are they scared they have they have no
reason to be scared is that what we
saying K what's going on until you see
me don't be afraid oh okay that's what
we doing so so until it's official with
there's nothing it's busted heart it's
fearful talk cry I'll cry for no
reason that's that's I think it's under
the bed mommy mommy mommy don't turn off
the light don't turn off the light cuz
the monster under the bed is going to
get me that's exactly what you sound
like you fear the dog cuz you fear the
unknown let it happen you mustard heart
and stand
firm to be clear for no reason all right
just stand firm and whatever's going to
go down is going to go down that that's
what we say what do we say CU a lot of
people want the generalu to come out
they want the generalu to to go storm
the building to storm the Capal and say
too busy the general is too busy
fighting your
monsters
you cowards what you run from will
eventually find
youm stand firm stand firm hey did you
go from Michael Myers to bane just
now sounded like Bane for a moment so so
just to be clear they they stand firm
nothing nothing's official right now and
then whatever happened happens that
that's the dumbest thing I've heard was
yo sor B going to come out in the
spring yo then she going to drop the
knowledge on you so you can understand
exactly what's really going down in
these gaming streets yo yo all I can
tell you is this okay let's go is a
civil war going on in the building oh
you got one group that's pushing a line
and blurring a line and trying to get
bread and you got the other group that
is there fighting for what we want
oh I'mma tell you
this nothing is said in stone oh fluid
you're going to know who
won by who
leaves okay
so pray and hope that your team that
you're rooting for the Aaron greenbergs
the Sarah Bond the Matt booties the fil
dominous Maximus a really expensive pray
that they win because if Saia Tim
Stewart and those dudes win
M you're not going to recognize the
brand that you love oh you may want to
add Amy Hood in that too oh the hood the
hood too okay well you already know um
the her mentality to the situation is is
is pushing into all diverse places right
and yeah I see I see guys being fearful
okay of that prospect that Prospect was
always a prospect when ABK came in M I
said
once Xbox makes more than
Windows then people with vested
interest look down and say how can I get
more money out of this this so so it so
I know one of our topics is Xbox ging
Revenue so because now uh gaming is has
surpassed Windows Windows was always the
money maker for them historic
so you're saying because now that has
passed when gaming and Xbox has passed
Windows as the money maker in the
building that now maybe stakeholders or
people with non-gaming sensibilities
will try to extract more and thus an
internal potential internal battle in
the building that was inevitable and the
fact of the matter if if if you're truly
down with the Xbox brand the Xbox brand
not the Microsoft brand Xbox game pass
brand and you see the ABK deal goes
through you would want majority of those
games to be
multiplied so when the next Acquisitions
come up Microsoft can point to their
track record and keeping certain games
multiplied in order to push it forward
in order to achieve the ultimate agenda
I don't
think Microsoft is invested in killing
Sony as much as we want them to die you
want that PA
yeah see as much as Us Xbox dudes want
them to pass and become an app I don't
believe
microsofts all Xbox workers there
themselves want them to die yeah maybe
Matt booty do Matt booty want to spend a
out of business yeah he he's on Team
Green that's the dude I like that's who
you ref that's who you I like him but I
think other people there because call
Duty makes money there because of other
things makes money there I don't believe
that they have a vested interest in
destroying PlayStation as much as us uh
console Warriors do and and I believe
that enlar the problem because you would
systemically keep Kong alive so in all
this is this balls down to when Godzilla
had Kong on that boat and he was almost
out and they said turn everything off
Godzilla just wanted him to submit right
didn't want to kill him right he just
wanted him under his foot and if they
continue to do what they doing they want
to keep Sony under their foot and keep
Kong alive maybe we're the only ones
that want Kong dead and Godzilla don't
interesting so so as far as like the
Schism in in the building right please
take the mask off now no it's hilarious
it's hilarious cuz he scaring the
mustard Hearts right now I know what
he's doing keeping the fear going so
it's interesting because my man made
this he made prop MK that's fire that
joint is crazy so okay so so so the
thing is there's an internal Schism in
the building that you feel that there
are a group that want to keep Kong alive
right right being PlayStation the other
platform so that they can extract
Revenue off of these guys right okay all
right let's open and then other one want
him
dead and and I honestly believe Phil s
Aaron green B and and definitely Matt
booty want them dead they ain't with it
they ain't with it they want them dead
interesting interesting nice it it is
interesting if if this uh you know
internal battle is going on you know um
that it and if one side is winning the
battle if the battle is Raging on what
is going to happen I got to get slow cuz
slow is a guess in the
realm yeah man this is this been a big
one it's been brewing it's been brewing
right like we've been hearing the
Rumblings right then high-f five Rush's
t-shirt gate going on right you know we
seeing red and blue and people are
speculating on that we've heard um shout
out to my good uh friend of the realm um
in seate ghost he had uh step tatiller
on who was talking about um SE of
Thieves he heard you know going to
PlayStation other things so we started
these Rumblings right and I believe the
other gentleman was uh Nate the I forget
the gentleman's name about about a high
fire rush so what are your thoughts on
this that the first part of the
Rumblings and then second did you see
about the OS slof tweet where there
allegedly supposedly going to be a State
of the Union Address of Xbox's third
party strategy from
sarahan all right so the first part I I
would say this like I I see people
saying oh well like why is anyone
listening to this one person saying this
and I'm like have y'all been paying
attention for the past month because
this isn't just one person that has been
saying this and people that you guys
trust about oh they got sources at
Microsoft oh they know things they let
us know what's good haven't been
disproving any of it so it's like is it
is it really just one person saying this
is it really just some random guy on
Twitter who look at his Twitter timeline
he doesn't talk about Xbox he must not
be an Xbox employee I mean like you use
your brain for a moment if you have one
think about it for a second it's not
just him it's a bunch of people who you
also know have sources who have also
been saying that this these are things
that are being talked about as king said
these are things that are being
discussed and also there will be
something along these lines but we don't
have all the details yet so I I I've you
know like us all I've heard some things
you know and and in regards to the the
idol sloth tweet I saw the Tweet the
first tweet
and I and I kind of was like oh boy
because just when when it's when it's
someone that actually is like I don't
know whether that was should have been
said in as much detail as it was said
but uh I'm just hoping that what the
first tweet say I didn't catch it well
the the first tweet had uh the person's
title and their handle and everything AG
inv sorry agent Deli damax product
manager yeah so so it's just like it had
all that there and then I don't know if
that was supposed to be said in that
manner at that time because clearly they
want someone who is Media trained
someone who is one of the top Executives
people who know who know the face to
come out and speak it the way they
wanted want to speak it whether you
accept it or not is up to you whether
you agree with it or not is is
definitely up to you and and I think you
know I I understand the whole you know
hold the line you know get your bayonets
up you know get in the
line I think I think we have to we have
to start thinking about us you know what
I'm saying what you want from a platform
and so even if and I I understand
waiting to offici for official word to
make your decision on what you choose to
do or whether you choose to go here go
there go to PC whatever but when you
hear certain things and then you're
starting to hear other people say
certain things okay like you you have to
start kind of prepare yourself for what
may what may and what and what you want
to do with it like I think and and my
opinion on the whole the whole subject I
feel like you shouldn't go multiplat
with these games oh so you feel they
should have I am I am on the line of
kill your enemy oh with the bo I'm yeah
look I'm not even look I you know I'm
primarily you PC I'm shocked by this as
a castle in a castle sitting on my 480
super just kind of looking and and and
you know surveying the landscape
of right right I'm I'm looking at the
the battle go back and forth and I'm
just finding curious right but but I
look at it and I'm like you now you're
start you you acquired all these Studios
the majority of them have not yet
develop the game from beginning to end
under the Xbox Banner under the
Microsoft Banner you're now starting to
get those games to come out you're
starting to get your pipeline together
and and now now you decide to go put
some games now let's give them high five
rush now let's give them now you want to
give that give that away no you tell
those people you want these games you
know what to do you buy yourself an Xbox
or you go to PC I'm not putting your
game on your little blue box
that all right that little Trash Swit
Let It Go I feel you so what if though
what if because according to King which
I think there's a lot of Truth to what
what Lord Michael bars the killer of the
bringing fear of the mustard Hearts we
doing Lord King Myers was saying was
that like there's there's an eternal
Schism so what let's just say you got to
stop saying
Schism there's a riff hey look I I I
agree I agree with King on that okay I
just like I I I am hoping that the the
bonds the booties you know and the and
the dispensers went out because what I
see from and and in no shake to those
people they know how to make money but
they don't know the gaming industry they
know how to make money but they don't
know gaming this is what we saw with
Google when Google jumped in there tried
to flex I know yeah I know how to make
money and then where they where were
they two three years later they were out
trying to make money doing something
else like the gaming industry is
different and when you have brand
identity when you start to put your
games on other platforms you're telling
the overall Gaming Community I don't
need that box no more and cons
sales right regardless told you they
never needed the box when they showed
you Samsungs you can play anywhere and
and to your point we went to a uh what
you call the forza event the marketing
liter said no console required so is
this something that iself is this a
self-inflicted situation that that that
that sounds like you you you you you you
didn't just trip on the rake you went to
Home Depot bought the rake brought it
home lined it up then you stepped on it
it's just like you're still making a
product here and it's like it's yeah
sure you don't have to own an Xbox in
order to play Xbox Gam but if you're a
Xbox only gamer or you're a console only
gamer telling me I can play on cloud at
1080p with with with all kinds of
latency I don't care about that but
that's an option for you they will
always have hardware and an extent for
the hardware concerned consumer but the
option the goal is not to have to make
all these consoles spending all this
money and chips and all this other stuff
where they just worry about serviceing
games they build up the game franchises
in order to facilitate games across many
different platforms and that's the goal
that's the end all be all is eliminate
as many barriers as possible in order to
push the product and the product itself
is their store their storefront and once
that product once that storefront is
inside whatever application you have
then they able to extrapolate cash from
you but other than that that get
worrying about a hard way getting to
your house that's too many steps they
want to eliminate those steps
interesting I I understand the their
view of things from their standpoint and
what they want and how they want to
provide games but I'm speaking more
towards the actual game what the actual
Gamers want right do the gamers want
that right now is that is that something
that they want in 2024 2025 was that
something that's more valuable for like
2030 right like when when G never know
what they want though
is it is it let me push back one not
push back let me ask you question slow
because I hear what you say right but is
it a situation like let's be honest like
Gamers kind of went through through this
on a on a different level with your
beloved PC at the time when Microsoft
was talking about putting their games on
PC day and day and the rumors came out
there was pitchforks what are you doing
you know this is hurting us it's going
to devalue the console and then now
you're seeing the revenue and now it's
kind of an accepted thing is it a
situation I guess my question to you
slow is this is it a situation where
Microsoft sees something from a data or
metric standpoint of where the industry
may be going cuz we got to give them
this historically historically whether
it be from the OG Xbox with Hardware in
the I mean hard drive in the console
ethernet in the console like Y what are
you doing no one has Ethan everyone has
d right 360 what are you doing um XBox
Live and is party CH why I got to buy
HDTV right remember it was like 720p t0
each it even with Xbox One people like
yo all right TV TV you know don't put my
games married with TV right and what do
we see now Halo series or Last of Us
series witches right let's be real and
we also at the time to connect you know
oh it's a spy Cameron who wants that now
we do Alexa tell me this chat gbt like
we so in their
defense they generally know where the
industry is going but sometimes they're
a little too aggressive some cases and
and to your point right is will this
backfire cuz I'm assuming what you're
getting at and correct me if I'm wrong
is brand damage like they could damage
their brand in the gaming space but I'm
curious about if you think about their
Forward Thinking with this situation
right right and and when it comes to the
PC and you know as a as a PC Gamer you
know I I I appreciate those games PC
make sure it's but but but but we come
PC is a different Market you know it's a
different Market there is there a
different ecosystem and how it works the
the demographics the kind of genres that
flourish PC are different it that
there's a whole different it's a
different animal to put your games on PC
versus putting your games on a rival
console within the console Market when
you look at like the the metrics like
every every year like around January I
look up like the the the revenue splits
for like the previous year in the gaming
community and we always see like mobile
is like 50 to 55% of all the revenue
generated but the way they split that
out there's mobile there's console
there's PC and then there's like VR and
cloud and everything else like little
small little slivers on the
pie HEC is a different
market and it's treated as a different
Market because it is a different Market
PlayStation ain't a different Market
that's your direct competitor and you're
giving them money so you're giving them
30% Revenue so they can go ahead and
take that and then continue to keep
games off your off the Xbox
platform I mean that's I mean you you I
understand it from the the mindset of
Minecraft and Call of Duty CU you have
to do that right Legacy titles have to
put a high five rush over there you
don't have to put a SE of Thieves over
there you don't have to do any of those
things okay so that's that's just my
mindset on I feel we go we G to spend
the black bag on you this a hot one oh
let's get addict man this literally was
his topically hijack because everybody
wanted to know what what king was gonna
say but um adct man we've been talking
right the Rumblings in the street we've
been hearing many trusted insiders
saying this and then obviously the uh
the whole now deleted tweet but um you
know the whole project manager from
zamax as far as a potential Sarah Bond
State of the Union about Xbox's third
party strategy what say you Lord addict
young wolf what do you say about all
this I think it's a mistake I think uh
if the moment I don't think it'll have a
highy
rush but I think the moment something
like a starfi or a Halo Master Chief
Collection hit the brand especially
Halo it's a rrap you've done two
especially when Halo drops on X on
Playstation you you self-destructed the
brand there's no coming back at that
point because at that
point even if you make statements
full-blown statements saying we're not
doing this we've decided to pull the Uno
reverse card people would say I don't
believe
you because you've shown through
consistency through years and years that
you are the kings of backtracking makes
message him so it's just like yeah I
feel that they're making a mistake um
you know people and and I feel that the
Xbox fans that attacked me for making
videos about it um you're part of the
issue because you you
refuse no apparently I'm the mustard
heart they're they're they're the front
line so you know here here's the thing
when it comes down to it's like look
even if you don't believe it can happen
I believe it can happen we want the same
thing so let me make my video and shut
up D you can't sit here all year long
saying PlayStation people don't don't
speak up enough for their brand and then
get mad when I speak out against my
brand shut up get them get them I so
tired shut up I love it I am so tired of
every time I make a post or or a YouTube
video I get so many people in my chat
that's like let's wait for an official
announcement you mean when it's too late
o so you try to stop it now you want the
you want the internal group that's
that's fighting imagine
with the uh Star Wars Battlefront 2 when
the when the loot boxes and stuff happen
every just let's wait for it to be
officially on the game it wouldn't have
gotten fixed imagine the Xbox Live gold
membership increased when they let's
just wait for it to be out there it
wouldn't have been fixed talk to him
talk to him you have to speak out
because I
believe that speaking with the wallet
helps but the problem is is by the time
you speak with your wallet it takes
years to
recuperate because by that by then the
game's already out you know people want
me to wait for high-i Rush to just be
announced for PlayStation and switch and
the fact that we saw updates right
updating shirts and stuff that that that
announces probably within a month or
two so it's just like okay wait wait for
it because because then when eventually
and I'm not saying it's going to happen
but you know you you you you give me 1
plus one I'm assume the I'm assuming it
equals two what's two break break it
down where we get two is complete third
party oh everywhere for the so it's just
like you know and I get it from from a
semantic
standpoint even if they if they if their
games were
good and they and all it was timed
exclusive I can see how the Xbox would
still Thrive but here's my thing okay we
don't need none of that okay you know to
me the only there's multiple reasons but
the biggest reason I can see where you
would want to just expand is if you
don't got confident what you're
doing and then not I I know what people
say well you know the metrics this the
metrics that well the numbers guys are
wrong all the damn time all the time
damn they never right damn they they
they they thought that they were going
to overtake Twitch in three years by
spending hundreds of millions of dollars
on stre right right know what
mix the you know what that exist be
wrong the financial guys can't be wrong
they thought they were going to overtake
the window the Windows phone and
overtake the whole IND you got got
Window Phones in the chat you chose
violence I still got one I mean it don't
it don't do nothing it's just it's a
paper weight but I got one what's up at
the end of the day window phon oh
Windows phone oh damn I didn't know it's
like a zoom now
here another one oh damn I forgot they
still another one oh damn
okay all right all right you're not
helping the cuse
bro like right now help you see you
trying to figure out why they they in
your chat I can tell you right now why
they in your chat that was that was
examples of people that just speak
numbers and don't know the industry
they're referring to they just go out
there and say yo look at these third
party stuff you we gonna make all but
then you can say got the Birdman clap
then you can say Microsoft don't know
the IND because they didn't spend a
whole bunch of money and didn't get
anything right yet well see here's the
thing the people the right people on the
side of the
wars they they they pushed for these
purchases because they thought they were
they were building a weapon of mass
destruction but it turns out the weapon
W wasn't built very
correctly they I honestly believe
they're so good that they're
head right you know the connect the
motion controls and stuff like that all
that gesture and stuff and all the stuff
that they're doing you see that Tech
right now and that um the eyeglasses
thing the the VR thing what I'm trying
to say is does okay but but my my
question to you is does uh do they have
a a a hand in the VR
industry oh what does does Microsoft
have a hand in the v industry yeah
basically by proxy yes what Oculus big
scream or I play it all the time so so
so they got a hand right just clarify
Microsoft owns Oculus no they put they
The Game Pass game pass on what you call
it but my point is is it doesn't matter
what you do it doesn't matter how far in
the industry are doesn't matter if you
if you playing 4D chess 10 15 years ago
we've seen it with the Xbox one if you
if you do stuff for the market that
you're trying to advance is ready for it
you might as well just just fold that
all those planes in your hand burn it in
your hand get third degree burn and
throw it away so B early gotad I'm sorry
I don't I don't I don't I don't
subscribe to that that philosophy okay
because with your philosophy you'll
you'll wait until you see the wave
sometime you got to catch the wave
understand you got to go get that wave
you got to go make that wave because
without the Innovations of Microsoft
there's no innovation inside um video
games Sony would not have done anything
they would have stayed the same you
would have had a disc drive with nice
space and nice audio Xbox came gave you
a hard drive Xbox came gave you Ethan
Xbox came gave you online there things
to push the industry forward sometimes
it you're not the beneficiary of these
trailblazing efforts but at the end of
the day what the path that you make is
for everybody else and I feel you on
that and they they they've definitely
had plenty of examp Xbox I'm sorry
please and but they they got some flops
too where where where where your guys
connect your guys connects right now
you're gonna you're gonna have flops
when you try and innovate you is is this
is inevitable right there's a difference
between innovating and trying something
new and just TR like here's the thing
Game Pass was innovating it was trying
something new it was still it was still
in the Realms of the industry and how it
functions as a whole it's just now
instead of making you know allart games
we're going to put it in a subcription
service it made a but but to come there
I'm like we're going to be a console
manufacturer and we ain't locking
nothing we you get something you get
something like like we make fun of
PlayStation for be rated a for everyone
e for everyone Xbox is about to make the
weop season let me
let I give I can give you the process
worse than the streets
take anything you want I can give you
the thought process in that all right
let's go because exclusive don't sell
consoles and let me explain why okay
break it down especially when you have
let's take the PlayStation brand because
you like them so much don't do that to
don't do that to my B third party titles
sell more on the PlayStation brand um
three to one compared to their exclusive
games that's a fact so if you're a third
party developer you have the ability to
to out sell their homebased AAA bangers
so-called that's supposed to uh identify
with the console so what identity do you
truly have if your identity is to have
failing first party titles and you're a
third- Party Machine this is this is
where the problem lies you're looking at
it from you're looking at it from a war
standpoint in thou shall not have my
just to clarify you think they should
have bestest that here's my thing I
understand what you're talking about
that's not what they've been saying
there's a difference between what you're
saying and what they're doing because at
the end of the day they we have Phil up
there saying we investing to make the
Xbox a more of a valuable place to play
We inves
in if you want if you want exclusives it
goes wherever Game Pass is Phil
literally just said a couple weeks ago
that they still believed in exclusives a
couple months ago right the ja thing he
said that what homeboy took them uh like
he said it the wrong way like his
homeboy I like that it's just like to me
I like that I personally this is what I
think happen see I want to know what's
this mixed message in because they said
select titles did he select so CFO
didn't say the the CFO didn't say you
know we're g the hell with what this
dude is talking about I'm talking about
Phil I don't listen I'm not worried
about a shirt talking to other
shirts all right but didn't Phil also
say these games were go where Game Pass
is exact Game Pass no game pass on
Nintendo play check it out is has high
five rush over there yet Chicken Little
oh no don't go slow chicken come
on now we busted Hearts can be all y'all
looking up am I still going to be
Chicken Little when when half R show up
over there am ick then then when it show
up over there then we have a
conversation okay do you think it's not
happening we going we going to have a
conversation about the thing okay okay
hold up hold up hold up King do you
think it's not happening you think highi
Rush is still not coming to Playstation
I believe in the world that Phil just
walks in the room and smacks somebody in
the face and say I said no I I believe I
believe in that world I believe he said
a fairy tale cuz it's another world like
another
Universe we Kingdom Hearts in this stuff
right now is that what you
saying you dudes y'all them dudes that
every time a dude walk past you and go
like that you you not the Flinch not the
Flinch dude you hey you that dude hey yo
man if you don't stand tall and just let
stuff happen y'all ain't got no control
anyway you think you think okay let's
say the game is already planned and
already ready to go and it give you the
announcement y'all think on Twitter
y'all saying I don't want my high five
who the hell high five rush it ain't
your high five rush but y sitting here
my high it's not your high five Rush
apparently it's everybody's High
it ain't nobody's high five rush but
Xbox high five Rush right now you this
sky falling mentality everything's over
there already you done gave up you just
said here take my lunch and here take my
car keys too and drive home I'm sorry
I'm
sorry the I I got I got I gotta push
back the reason that I have this kind of
mentality is because I prefer to say
something when I see the meteor coming
towards the Earth not when it's killed
me and hit the ground already
yo how many how many how many times do I
got to hear the buru is coming back to
the Galaxy or how many times do I got to
hear oh yeah they said that a rocket is
going to hit in 2024 how many times do I
got to hear oh you know when the when
when the year 2000 come the world is
going to blow up y
YK hold up I know where you going do you
do you believe that Phil's going to stop
highi Rush fromn on play station that
he's going to walk in there and be like
in my world so your world
fanty okay so so the thing is so the
thing is let's go you go off of every
rumor and that's why y'all get pushed
out of position oh damn all right cuz
y'all y'all the ones out here with these
what preemptive tweets if if this
happens I'm going for I I for four weeks
I'm going to send you $1,000 if this
happens why say that why is that
necessary don't speak it into exist
right don't don't don't do that don't
give your energy so we got to keep our
head in the ground we can't listen to
that we can't listen to nothing listen I
love content this sound sound so some
sound like some spiritual mum jumbo you
got well the problem is I'm 98% right
all the time and you wrong ain't that
right
division listen ain't that right Captain
Division division you going throw
division on him like this you know what
you know slowo slowo hold up hold up
real and you and you hold up hold up no
king king want to step on his I know
exactly how to drive
the high restur on play we do a better
you been the KNE with me high I'm going
get you in a second but I just got I got
to I got to say this I got say not just
Kanye yeah you've been picking the wrong
horse forever all right so just got you
out the way because
yeah
division get this
work he said division of failure slow
and he said you are not to your opinions
are not to be trusted because of
division all right you going to get this
work all right all right all right all
right now let's get
back just let's get back to this this
short shot veteran over going we're
getting right back to you we're going
back to the mustard heart we talking to
you okay so you don't want to do the B
why don't you I'm talking to you I'm
talking to you now okay you going to to
you it's not happening it's official
it's official put in the now watch this
now watch this now watch what I do to
you and this is going to hurt you more
than it's going to hurt me go no no no
let's go let me hear this let me hear
this Phil what's up stopped them glasses
off King oh we got glasses time the last
time I told Phil to do something until
my glasses so it happened it happened
and
I direct sh to fill down ma if you
listening to we know you listen King
said you got to stop it cuz B is on the
line it's serious now not only
[Music]
kinging
and listen listen listen listen listen
listen over there listen s your theves
over there high five Rush going to
Nintendo but they a getting high five
rush and I'm get his knees and this is
how we going to do this no blue shirt
for y'all you heard here Phil if you
listening this is how you know what you
got to do I'm willing to even make it a
little bit better no is right right now
you can't even walk cuz I already got
both from two
B send me my new needs I don't care
about your need if you win this I give
you not only your I'll give you my knees
back oh you get okay you get double the
knees double the frun okay the KNE the S
You Sage
stuff everybody out here everybody out
here extending their self further than
they can
bet put it on the line y'all but I'll
bend it and I'll take it PA it up that
but yes I I look you standing on
business he going down he going down
with the ship however go he going told
Phil you got to respect that you got to
respect that y'all he he ain't run he
ain't run from y'all CU it's looking the
tianic was looking like we hit the
iceberg and he said die you thought you
had some wounded
animal sucker they all suckers they all
bued Hearts that's why he the king
that's why the K he don't go down like
that that's what I'm talking about I
love to see it the definition of a
captain going down with the ship bro
that boy that listen I'll tell you right
now all my life don't know that man a't
never run from a fight that man ain't
never that man staying on business in
real life and everything so I got to
respect it man I don't know what I'mma
do I I
have I'm about to get artificial needes
get EXT when Sarah come out and say what
she going to say and your face when they
see your face is your camera going to go
off and you going run why you going to
run cuz you know you know I'mma see you
in March so God
that's the that's the tough so the queen
queen you got to do the right thing
Queen yeah yeah Queen Barn plus you know
we can't really say 98% King what
happened to that Kojima thing at the
state of play come on why you had to
bring that up no no no I like it because
why why we talking about the P yo check
it out so I'm doing this right I I do
like 90% of the time what I'm doing I'm
doing this so I'm getting text and I get
the text and I didn't really
understand what the hell he was saying
at the same time he's like yo he got
another
game I'm like I'm looking I'm like what
and I'm listening to you and J J said
something and you was like yeah
Espionage I'm like
Espionage I looking I said oh
sh we like oh that was fast that was
fast that was fast listen was merary
dope it dop it dope Y and it was a good
setup it was a good setup went from 98
to 90 went to 9 no no no no no that's
too far of a drop
buddy but I'm saying K that was way
buddy buddy I don't know what type of
school you into but we don't you got to
lose 8% off of that don't hell no
guy you're bugging out so what are you
95% foret that I'm 97 oh come now you w
you a never going this B percenti no
since when Kim was worth that much
points he was worth that much points but
o came on the screen and you was capping
like was showing up though I knew he was
showing up there I a know what the game
was but you get out of here with that I
he going SL
this got hey that's a lot of that's a
lot of you went down from from 92 to 90
we we on the average hey get him he's
not the um Whatchamacallit what's that
the dude that the aor the amount of the
amount of B the knes I won with you I
think you're like 70 I'm I don't like I
don't like how you got the stat book but
we going to move on to what I I don't
care about yourending me mean you
mustard
hot yo they stupid somebody said ad get
chased off his own block oh come on over
anyway so look let me jumping this is
this is crazy so like this this right
here man where do we go with this so
look this this is my thought process you
know me
personally I really just want Clarity
whatever it is yall GNA do just do what
y GNA do and say the messaging right
that that's where I'm at because my only
concern
slmo is this
if you're going to tell
me we need to do this right we need to
do this because the internal T targets
are not where they need to be the
metrics say we're not we're behind you
know our plan is we should have been at
X number of Game Pass subscribers or you
say to me ABK we thought the deal was
done we was counting on that money a
year two years ago or whatever it was
right how long the FTC case went on if
you tell me that and this is about
survival right cu no one wants them
necessarily to be Sega right you know
what I mean so it's like if you tell me
that I can understand and you say Okay
select titles older or ones that didn't
hit and I've always been on record live
service should be everywhere live if you
truly want live service to succeed live
service needs to be everywhere now the
high five rush I get it that definitely
is going to Sting the base that is a
highly critically acclaimed game it
hasn't been out that long let me ask you
one quick question when it comes to like
the live service that's technically Halo
infinite that is
technically are
you I'm get let me let me I'm going get
to my thoughts last let me just get to
what their think I got you though I got
you okay so my thing is okay if they
tell me that then I I don't like it but
I understand the business it's corporate
CL say okay I get that right now my only
push back is like how what is adct
saying it's not about restricting and
saying I don't want PlayStation to have
it and I don't want Nintendo I know what
makes business right my thing is kind of
what s I mean slmo is alluding to which
is you this base has been with you
during these dark times right Xbox One
or whatever whatever right it's not just
about loyalty it's about messaging they
need to know what your vision is they
need to know what's going on here if
these games go to other platform it does
create confusion and here's the other
thing we got to be real about the Xbox
brand from a worldwide perspective when
you think video games you think
PlayStation you think Nintendo to the
Casual fan as we had Peter Moore on here
he's always talked about the mentality
of the Challenger brand right pushing
forward fighting getting exclusives
doing all these things buying studio so
they in the series X generation and at
the end of half of the Xbox One they've
presented themselves to to the Xbox base
like they are the Challenger bread they
are here to compete and they have been
on record of saying yo these games are
what game pass exist hey um this is a
situation where when we looked at AI on
Nintendo switch that may have been a
mistake that's not sustainable this are
their own words so they can't get mad at
the base for being upset at the
confusion a a at at at what are you
really doing right I do agree with King
though that I feel that there is some
internal conflict in the building I do I
think I believe that too yeah I do feel
agree with that I do feel there is an
intern because this is an immed this is
a very immediate pivot that seems if
true because again to King point it is
rumored it kind of feels like like low
key the moment the ABK deal happened
like the Civil War started right so
something this listen corporate Cog
again when these internal battles happen
there's teams right you've got to
present your rubrics you got to present
your o okrs you got to present all these
arguments to show this is why we knew
now if the team again I don't know if
it's you know Phil Sarah Matt booty
Aaron Greenberg let's just say that's
team state of course right and then
let's just say I'm making up Tim Stewart
Saia whomever is team we got to put this
everywhere if team we got to put this
everywhere has the data and says hey
we're behind hey we didn't hit these
Game Pass targets hey ABK just got us
barely in the green over these last
metrics that team is going to win in the
building and you got to capitulate and
if if you don't want to capitulate then
people will leave right that's just yes
please I got cor corporate Cog I have a
question yeah yeah let's go let's go why
not wait until after the bulk of your
like two three years from now you you
you've had like so much the bulk of your
Studios dropping content on the annual
bases you're hitting your your first
party game every quarter why not wait
till after that and then you if you
don't see that you have grown in the
manner that you wanted to grow then you
go to the great question great question
I got you okay corporate this this is
what corporate car going say you are
right from a gamer perspective and to
see it through unfortunately remember I
told you is it survival or is it greed
is it can we extract
more and what we see as king is saying n
gamers in the room Finance guys data
guys in the room can we extract more
right if it's if it's greed but or in
the in the finance guys you know defense
if it's survival say look we ain't where
we need to be we can't sustain this a
lot of people don't want to wait until
things start getting into the red when
they start to see the dip some some may
say hey we got to do this now and if
those guys cuz we know Phil is on the
board but if the rest of the board
outvoted him it don't matter what's
going on he's now at the board because
gaming is at is what is it third number
you know number three or whatever it is
so I get I'm with you look slow for the
record now I'm answer addict's question
for the record I'm with y'all I feel
they the vision was about to start
you've got the studios you've got the
plethora of games let's see it through
because my main thing and this is where
I agree with you slow is that the brand
damage I am concerned about you've
already not considered a top brand when
I speak to guys like Colin when I speak
to guys who are entrenched in the
PlayStation and Nintendo ecosystems
right they're not coming over when you
give high five rush over it like like
like I understand the mentality which is
like yo if we give them high five rush
we give them c3s we have high five Rush
too you might be excited the reality is
those guys are entrenched in those
ecosystems already how and to addict's
point how much revenue are you really I
could be wrong but how much revenue are
you really going to get from is it
really going to do Blockbuster I don't
know these answer maybe the finance guys
know and they prove to be right the last
thing I say I see s jumped in it's just
look it's not about being emotional it's
not about yo PlayStation can't have it
what you call can't have it my concern
is at least if you stay the course for
let's say a year or two is that we know
as Gamers when they are critically
acclaimed games if you have good games
people Gamers break they go damn that
Indiana Jones damn that blade damn
there's always one that will break and
then you know when you get eventually
you just have a I'm going to Walmart
right and then I'll get this as a
secondary system if you don't do that
now you run the risk of high-f five rush
over there oh I got it here comes high
five Rush 2 on Xbox and game passes to
say that which fine but they go this is
what you now create oh you know what
that's going to come to us eventually we
just wait you feel what I'm saying we
just wait without any confirmation they
don't need a confirmation and now they
open up they open up Pandora's Box
because Pandora's Box says every XBox
exclusive from this point on if you ad
if you do this experimental strategy now
comes in the question oh well I don't
know if hell blade too that might come
to us too oh I don't know if whatever
whatever you open up this whole convers
ation that it's where you consider the
rake where it's this self-inflicted
thing so it I again to King's Point got
to hear the messaging got to see what's
going on nothing is official I get that
but we can't act like some of these
sources that we are hearing from have
not been correct in the past that's all
I'm saying I see s in the building S I
got to get you where you at where you at
hey hey can I say something real quick
go absolutely um to to the to the point
about data and and the data Guide and
the stats guys and when they when they
speak and that that's true in the
corporate environment when when you
provide the metrics like uh philosophy
goes out the window like saying well
this is how things are without any kind
of like backup doesn't really help you
but I remember and you know we we we are
fans of BioWare right absolutely um when
when they got acquired by EA the the
internal struggle that BioWare had was
that the EA guys was always like well
multiplayer is where it's at now you
guys just do single player games here
are the metrics that I saying we can
generate more Revenue with multiplayer
so they forced them to start putting
multiplayer in all their games and oh by
the way you know if we Stop Licensing
out unreal and then we just have you use
our in-game engine oh that hey it's just
for Battlefield whoop sorry you don't
know how to use it whoopsie but don't
matter
about financial guys have been wrong
before many how many how many this
financial guys like we going we going to
get this this battle royale g g game
popping we going to get this games of
the service popping the division going
to be lit an going to be lit like yeah
no no you guys appre continue slow I
know where you're going you absolutely
this is the this is the risk yeah and
the end result is end result is the
talent the core Talent of the B was like
we not down for this rout yeah and then
we start getting M androma Bond Anthem
Bond and now the very next game they
come out with next year who knows where
the studio will be if that game doesn't
hit and this
the the erosion didn't happen like
immediately that took a long per of time
and and when you start to see when you
erode your brand when people no longer
think of bware as one of the best
studios in in the world and now they're
just like yeah they used to be I don't
know about them now like that that took
a period of time and that's that's a
brand that got eroded I don't want to
see that for Xbox I don't want people to
be like I don't need that even though
yeah they even say hey you don't need it
because you can play anywhere you want
but but there are people who feel
internally right I know I could play
everywhere but I want to play here
absolutely and and and when you when if
if the when you already got struggling
console sales and if if that continues
to erod and then people you know who
don't have one are like I don't need one
and they and stad of getting a new
console gamer coming in who may you get
it as a second console techically a gay
P subscriber loss you know that that
doesn't buy the as well exactly like
that that's just like in the long run it
is just not a good look for me no I get
it I get it and like I said only push
back and nothing that everything you
said is completely accurate is
that let me present a scenario for y'all
and so anybody can answer if this is
truly about survival right if this is
really what it is and it's a situation
where it's like look we can't move
forward with this model in its current
state so it's either a I'm going give
you two choices you know Game Pass day
and date got to go
away right they we can't do it Finance
says what it is ABK we got to put it
everywhere zel Max we got to put it
everywhere and you know we can't sustain
it so maybe you get the titles it launch
but it it's six months or a year after
then it's a game pass right I'm put a
poll in the chat I got you something
that you have already promised your base
with the Game Pass service but you can't
sustain it right that's one or two which
is the rumors that is postponed out in
order to survive okay we can't get rid
of Game Pass day and dat we keep it we
retain it right but select older title
you know a sea of Thieves or maybe
something that underperformed or I don't
know what highi rush did I'm assuming
the stealth drop may not have benefited
without proper marketing right I don't
know you know what I'm saying cuz FR
frush is strange to be to be and it's
not a multiplayer game right so it is
interesting but if that is the case and
there's a gun to your head in the
building what do you
do that's the question that I'm not
saying this is 100% the reality I'm just
saying what if yeah they are presented
with that situation what do you guys
choose like adct what do you choose do
you choose Game Pass day and date go
away okay go away okay so you saying go
maintain your thing maintain okay no I'm
saying um don't don't post them on D
Dayton Game Pass like cuz to me I feel
like uh the game having an identity and
the game having brand is way more
important than you know a value of a
console because if you have games people
are going to come regardless so but to
me my fear about the whole matter and
you know then we'll get to that is I
just don't want like a giant list of
dominoes that's going versus the
exclusives then the console cells don't
pick up then before you know it Xbox to
have a series conversation maybe we
should just ditch the console and just
go full th
that is my concern will it happen I
don't know but uh s what do you think
one wait before s answer slowo answer to
your question K I need answer to that
question game pass day and dat situation
and then I got S I just want to keep uh
how long how how long okay if you go the
no day and date for Game Pass six months
let's say six months let's say six
months yeah let's just say I'm fine with
that I'm fine with that if you crazy
they already they already kind of do
that now when games launch you can get
it a little bit early for like $40 like
remember with Starfield you can get it a
little bit a little bit before launch if
you want to spend a little bit extra
money and people have done that like
they spend a little bit extra bread to
get it what's the poll the poll is 5248
right now oh it's close as hell 159 what
would you rather have exclusive games or
Game Pass day and date yeah 52 it's
tight 165 people voting go hit the vote
hit the poll King this is what it is I'm
just making up a fake scenario day day
got to go away we got to keep the lights
on D date got to go away
o why didn't expect this from you um
because but see my my my goals is to
kill
KH my my goals is is gota die my my
goals is he's right though what's the
odds of you competing with PlayStation
without exclusive games like it's
not yeah know but I want I want them
dead though
like and I don't believe Microsoft want
them
de I I believe every Microsoft just to
weaken a Beres these dudes know that
they got a corpse right there not the
and just prop them up so they can keep
eating off his of his constituents we yo
um I know it's in an Insidious
thought but Microsoft is going to be
your life support they did it to Apple
they keep people around and they prop
them up in order to eat off them they're
the living
vampires So Kong is dead already okay we
just going to fill him up with our games
but what okay so you can drink the
poison pill but what about the the
promise you told your base I mean not
you yeah I want I want I want them dead
I want I want to live off the promise so
you're okay with riging the the pr
nightmare care about that game pass so
you don't care about that I want Kong
dead they're actually riging either way
because they said the zenx games only L
lose you're right you're right good call
good call it's a lot you you got caught
in your lie e both of them got CAU they
got caught their lie either way and I
and I'll say this doing the uh the don't
do day and day on Game Pass route can
give these games a second life you have
the people who were all in on the game
day one they will buy the game day one
the people who were somewhat on the
fence you put it in six months later the
the the sales tail has then you know
leveled out now the game isn't really
selling like it was at launch then you
get the other people who are in Game
Pass subscription who will try the game
and may actually like it now you got
that boost again and so it's kind of
like it's kind of like what we see with
third party developers how they treat
game pass with their big big games corre
they don't put them in their day and
date correct they wait until the the
sales have dropped they put it in Game
Pass that will work just fine and you
keep everything exclusive after s says I
I want to go back around one more time
and do you think that how bad would the
pr be oh I know we G talk about this PR
in a minute but s even impatient I need
your vote real quick and then we got to
talk about where you at with this whole
thing yeah D and day has to go
oh nobody wants the third party G it was
always selfish self it was always it was
always a bullish
when you think about it it was always a
bullish move to begin with that was the
I mean when we heard that we lost our
minds like brand new games day and date
for this you know whatever price a month
$10 $15 a month whatever the case may be
you roll in Xbox Live and all that stuff
like it was always a super bullish move
that they in the moment really they
needed to make right coming out of that
Xbox one generation they needed to make
that big splash you know back compat
wasn't enough
needed that
so but but you know you take these bets
and you see where it pans out and over
the years you know I think the telling
thing for me is just that they stop
reporting the growth of Game Pass right
especially in in the console space where
it's it's going to grow the most the
thing about the PC space and the cloud
space that you know we just the PC space
is very very steam Centric you saw the
backlash to the epic games store right
even more backlash to the Microsoft
store because they feel it's even
inferior to the Epic gam store so to get
the the PC Community already to kind of
go over and accept the Xbox store and
the Xbox ecosystem on their platform a
lot of these guys would happily go pay
$70 for your game on Steam rather than
go rather than go that's a good point
that's a good point you know as a
consumer I'm like that's that's crazy
but that's that's the thinking so you're
not going to you're not going to convert
those people and then you know on the
console to tell the console guy
hey you know you've kind of you're not
the priority anymore we want to get onto
these other platforms we want to get
onto mobile and and cloud and stuff like
that those other places aren't where
they were probably hoping they were
going to be right Cloud especially their
Cloud infrastructure their Cloud
infrastructure is vast but it isn't the
fast right you look at something like a
gForce now or something like that so
they they have the proliferation they're
everywhere but for what they needed to
be maybe it's not quite ready right and
maybe it's not going to be ready in the
timetable that they had for whatever the
next set of consoles are so it just sort
of feels like them looking at where they
want a game pass to be and where it is
it's like okay we've seen we've seen
that the willingness to jump in on Game
Pass and that be the way Way Forward for
some people they're just hard-headed
they don't want that they want to feel
like they own their games whether it be
digitally or or or whatever or or uh
physical copies and it's just been hard
when you think about that it's like hey
you know
what when you think about what Microsoft
right Xbox as a console within that
ecosystem within the Microsoft ecosystem
was always kind of an outlier because it
never really fit with what the rest of
the company does which is just plain
softare and software in as many places
as it can so when you think about the
original original goal of Xbox it was to
put the PC into the living room right
and to take over the living room right
that idea evolved but but the premise is
still the same the way you proliferate
that change from a piece of Hardware to
software everywhere so as they move
forward the idea of it being mostly
software based was always there and the
Xbox ecosystem Works in contrast to that
because that's just not how the console
space works so now looking at it I I
honestly believe what I said earlier I
really do think that when they think
about where the vast majority of their
fandom is and going to stay unless you
want to kill the brand completely I
think you do need to continue to build
some sort of platform some kind of
console some kind of box I think you
have to because the truth of the matter
is is that the vast majority of Xbox
players are on an Xbox that is just a
fact so to to do that and eliminate that
and move away from that I think would be
supremely damaging to the brand
because it it is so integral the console
space is so integral to Xbox
success I don't think they can look at
you know what growth they've had in the
PC space what they what you know what
games people play on mobile and stuff
like that right
and say hey this is viable for us to
leave the the console space behind
completely it doesn't make a whole lot
of sense I mean again when you talked
about hey let's see the vision through
we we now have these mobile games that
are at some point going to come into
Game Pass right so that's going to
attract a different type of player and
see if that player buys into game pass
on their mobile platform to play those
types of games on the PC side they've
done a lot of work to make PC be at
parody with the Xbox right they've done
a lot of that work but like I said
before the PC player is as hardcore as
they come they have their platform that
they want to be on they don't deviate
from that you know there's plenty of
guys that I know that was like well
Allan Wake is on the is on the Epic gam
still I guess I'm not playing Allan Wake
too and it's like what people are
married yeah people are married today
they really they really married to that
so the as somebody who was you see it
just by them buying games on Steam
instead of going to Game Pass like see
that I'd rather pay 70 bucks for this
than than get it in this service even
get the service for a month to play the
game for 15 bucks or 10 bucks they won't
do that and and eventually all the other
launchers on PC bend the need of steam
they they they'll put their games over
there they'll try not to have their
games on Steam but eventually they do
put them back on there because it's it's
the way PC Community is man it's the way
the PC Community is I was like oh you
know what I'll give you the 30% rip
whatever right um you know if I get if I
get a you know whatever 50,000 sales of
the game on my
launcher that's great I get all that
money but the the money to be made is
with steam and that's just what it is so
like looking at the the fear around this
I comp as as a an Xbox gamer who was
forced to move to the PC ecosystem
because of the fact that I'm not well I
can't I'm not in front of the Xbox
anymore
oh I'm not I can't them frames they made
you not be in front we we going to move
on FR ask King I had capable machines
forever much like much like the rest of
Y it's like I want to sit in front of my
TV I like the ecos system for me the
ever since PlayStation and Xbox came
into the game PlayStation has always
been exclusives over there I played
their games over there that's never been
my my full-on machine my primary machine
a PlayStation has never been my primary
machine it was it was Sega machines
right and that it was Xbox as my primary
machine I play the first party stuff on
it Xbox in addition to third party stuff
that would be my my my ecosystem so for
me I was like I can't be in front of the
console anymore I'm going to move to PC
where I can have access to some of these
games through game pass over there right
and I can have access because I already
had a steam account all that stuff like
I can access it this way and I you know
I I could be more
engaged but so as somebody who had to
make that move I'm like you know what
it's not that painful like it really
isn't that painful but I understand
understand this idea that you told me
this was going to be important to you
and all these things trickling out
indicate that it's not and for whatever
reason you're not willing to be straight
with me up front um and I wasn't here to
listen to the conversation but I'm assum
King's Point was hey it's all conjecture
still we don't know right part
ofing yeah no and until we get it from
the horse's mouth that is all it is it
is conjecture
um my thing is just that they're doing
themselves a disservice right by being
kg and talking around it that's what I'm
saying just get in front of it just get
in front of it and say whatever it is
you doing that's all people are really
saying they still fighting
Fair they still might be having these
meetings Phil Phil Phil ain't lose yet
he's he's punching somebody in the mouth
daily and and I'm pretty sure that you
know he's waiting for that dude's uh uh
PTO to
finish so he can catch him over at the
the the cooler you'll be funny you'll be
funny if like they they argue so much
feel was
like let's settle this with the sticks
beat me and Tekken whoever wins n he
said meet you in that lunchroom with the
lights out I can't
catch that done told you about raising
your hand in class and they said they
got one more question you keep raising
your hand you
so the fight is on the war is still on I
I believe I believe they they are
actively fighting I don't believe mat
booty got to give up attitude and I
believe he want Kong to die and he's
trying to Yo there mustard hearts in
that
building flag flag with a f for the
muster and y'all over there y'all want
to wave the flag y I know you dudes and
Phil is like get the so is the buer
hearts causing this it's their fault K
come oh busts in the building
y y thought feeling it was Kum Baya now
he's team kill him off and and and the
Kum Bay is them other dudes that like
that bread but cuz they like why kill
them off when we can gouge their fan
base like they do we can that fan base
is stupid we can manipulate them like
they do like no let Bernie die throw
Bernie away let's bury Bernie and get
him up out of here oh man we going get
your fan Bas regardless but we we
playing nice but that's the no that's
the problem you're not going to get them
I just talked about how how territorial
these people are you ain't going to get
them listen when they when they're dead
and they got no place else to go they
got no place else to go and they tired
of playing PlayStation 4 and five and we
on to the next and the next and the next
y'all come over we going we going to
starve you out Popeye's biscuits you
going to play The Last of Us remake for
her but so long going they going to
remake game for the only thing that get
the only thing that gets that crowd that
gets that crowd off of PlayStations to
try out your console is high quality
games you might not one the Call of Duty
you might not get them with Final
Fantasy 7 rebirth but you might get them
with Call of Duty you might not get them
don't buy I don't know infinite but you
you but the thing is is Everyone likes
to boycott something to a stay game
listen all we got to do is remove porn
off they joint Call of Duty don't make
that the p hub system listen and make it
make it only exclusive make Point her
exclusive to Xbox and they they come
over tomorrow don't say that's all what
them dudes is
doing you got to S series X uh X
PlayStation
skin y'all messy y'all messy look look
yeah guess I'll finish up um so for me
I'm G be perfectly honest uh oh uh oh to
me I think I I completely understand the
fan base that's on the console I'm like
man I feel betrayed by this if this
happen uh you know I wanted to see this
through and then if it failed then cool
you're not even waiting around to see if
it fails if this is true right I get it
I I get that my thing is this end of the
day if you really want to sit down and
talk about the numbers and how Xbox
games because now we're talking about
how many studios how many games coming
out the important thing that the games
be good and that the industry at large
recognizes that absolutely and for
whatever reason the industry at large
people that aren't Xbox fans there's an
unwillingness to even look at these talk
about all them IG dudes come
on you gotta be nice on a Sunday come on
but there is an unwillingness that I
think kind of dissipates when there's no
C to war over right right but can I just
interject one quick second but wouldn't
it be wouldn't you be able to more make
a dent if you at least stay the course
and you have these quality games to at
least entice them to at least entertain
the ecosystem oh my thing is this and
like I said I really do think they can
be the first to break that mold and
continue to give the console guys a
console right and and and literally put
everything on every platform if they
want to because if maintain Game Pass
right H and then you just talked about
taking you know first party games day
and date
right wait yeah I gotta interrupt you
real quick uh so so uh Paul tassi put a
tweet I said what exactly is Microsoft
strategy at this point and Jeff
commented and said number one alienate
fans making them worry about the future
of the of the platform and their
purchase purchased games number two
create a meme that Xbox has no exclusive
game pushing wider audiences away number
three be confused why everyone thinks
this is a bad idea and number four pivot
when it's too late continue so there you
go it's like it's by not saying it
anything about it right um it's you're
kind of stepping on a rake that you
don't have to that's but at the end of
the day if it's not true at if it's not
true then it was all for nothing
everybody helping and puffing K going
talk he going to talk to the mothers if
none of this don't happen in March
it just sucks that these dudes got to
always validate their relationship with
these suckers every day yeah we still
married
honey honey we're still married yes I
love you still always yes honey yes
honey I still love you just how much how
much you got oh man the most insecure
fan base I've ever seen in my life that
mustard hard talk yeah but but you got
to admit that's the abusive parent doing
that to you
bar not letting you know where you stand
go and masturate yourself and get out of
here go go and masturbate yourself and
get out of here for for those dudes that
don't know what that means emancipate
that sounds too much like something yeah
that sounded like something else we
going nasty you
nasty that's why your lights is on for
you in the
closet I would say this I would say this
right like you know the fan base that
the fan base wouldn't be uh needing
validation so much if uh if if the
uh if that other half wasn't out there
in the streets and people coming back I
saw I saw you know what you picked when
you got her you
know before she before we saw that ay we
saw that ay over there and they stuck
around don't sit there and stick around
after sh- talk about why she a cheater
you a
sucker we we knew what we was getting
into you know exactly what you had when
you had her all right she flirting with
PC FLIR flirting with Nintendo yo listen
you ain't meting in church all right oh
man that ain't a church going woman sit
there you ain't going to sit there and
try to turn that into a house you ain't
going to do that we already knew what we
was dealing with okay fa up fa up sit
there for the Trap she for the
Trap scare people again because people
like to look up you know things to make
themselves scared um so apparently like
you know there's there's there's rumors
out there that you know that the deal
with AMD for the next Hardware was just
sign right right right right so and that
goes back to the to the rumor that they
could be doing some kind of hybrid
architecture with an arm chip instead of
you know an AMD so right so then the arm
thing begs the question how much of a
hybrid machine is this is is is the
cloud stuff in a place where it would be
viable to make that that a building
block of the next platform right right
so it it just goes again it goes those
things like that even though again it's
conjecture you don't know it's rumor
speculation it it makes people in the
know think like hey where are they going
with this what is their focus next time
are they not going to give me a super
power in defense of King I think Tom
Warren jumped out in front of that
extreme I never SE him be this extreme
and was kind of clapping back at the SW
and gent you know I forgot his name Mo
something
um yeah he he clapped back very hard
kind of like don't and Tom is generally
connected in that respect so I don't
know who's right I'm just saying because
I saw what you saw too and I was like oh
they not going to be able to get the AMD
situation popping before PS5 Pro and ps6
or whatever and then Tom Warren seemed
to he quote tweeted it and he seemed to
you know shout out friend time like he
he seemed to shut that down like don't
okay yeah kind of fall for the banana
and the tail pip type situation at the
end of the day my thinking is I don't I
don't have a problem with them actually
going pro thir party I feel for y'all
want stay in the console don't do that
don't do don't PC master I feel for
y'all don't don't don't do that song yo
I mean it's it's such a different
reality for me now and again I would
have I would have gladly see you out the
hood now now you living in a new
neighborhood I don't like how you acting
I don't like it's you different now I'm
in I'm in the BS now you know bro we get
and we get one NZXT deal and now this
dude he don't come back to the block no
more slow-mo he talking about frames and
all this other stuff hey I get it I get
it though look s woke up in the morning
with his bath robe on he turned on his
Cofe was like I feel sorry for y'all
shame they're going through that you see
how he threw the y' on us that's crazy
that's crazy so not like this not like
but again I don't I feel it is not it
would not be cool for San to come out in
April and be like yeah um everything's
going everywhere and question is how do
how do they how do they say that from a
from a PR perspective how do you do you
what do you say like do you say like
this helps us give us the experiences
right you spin it you spin it as this is
the best for the Xbox brand and again I
say I I though go ahead son you got to
you got to snitch you got so you too
right all the time let me hear this what
they gonna say I just I believe that
Messiah if listen when you think about I
I don't know how much they spend on R&D
on these consoles and what that you know
in terms of over like what they consider
to be too much for a space where they
feel they plateaued in um and my hope is
that they truly understand and realize
that the strength of the Xbox brand lies
in the console base they haven't done
enough in the other spaces that they
want to get into to Warrant them
abandoning a console completely just
they're not there unless unless they
come out tomorrow and be like Game Pass
is at 70 million subs or whatever the
case may be um and you got to look at
how many of those subs are are are
Xboxes right so um yeah I I just really
don't I think they can be the first to
do that and I think that is the way for
them to dip their toe into where they
really want to be if it was an ideal
situation um and also continue to
appease the fans that got them where
they are um and I I think that is a a
reality that can really happen because
imagine it completely doesn't make a
whole lot of sense to me right unless
again a couple of years into this plan
the games are so hot they're coming out
with 85 Plus bangers every four months
everybody's so upset so to to understand
the emotionality of the Xbox fan base is
like when we had you know put him in the
pl but we had kid on last time right and
he was like it's like bro you right at
the mountain top you you got all the
you're there like people were like this
is from this point on we looked at the
road map right even people like yo 2024
look crazy for Xbox 2025 like all the
projects we know all the Gams we know
and I guess the frustration is like why
now that you at the M be there because
they have B they have Batman
mentality Batman mentality is Batman
mentality Batman could have always
stopped his villains he never did
he never chose to he never chose to kill
him off yeah he never chose to kill him
off he always kept him around so he
could have another Caper so he can have
another adventure so he can have
something else to do they keeping him
around because they need something else
to do because literally right now you
could just snap him out of existence
that's what kiss Mo said he said this
was supposed to be the th snap
moment but the mentality you got to look
at it it's a reason why they can Phil
even said I don't look at them as
competition actually I would like to
help them remember when he said that so
in helping yeah yo you keeping these
dudes alive like really listening to
what he's saying we want them dead or
you know hey y'all want us dead right so
and I want to say this because y'all get
mad when you you hear me say that I hurt
your feelings you want us dead you want
our games so when I tell you that I'm
supposed to turn the other cheek no hell
no you for you for the violence I want
you
you your I know how you give on people
that wish bad things you are too
gangster I I get it we know
you the thing is the thing is and part
of that leak was this idea that you know
that they're aware of what the community
saying and they're not really taking
that into consideration yo that was wild
and then you know what team that is yeah
exactly so the thing is what you said
Cog is what the fan right the the the
person the fan of Xbox is is thinking
the person with the the person the
person with the
suit suit right the person with the suit
is saying great we we've reached that
Pinnacle the games are amazing the games
could stand on their own that's they're
thinking at that point they don't need
they don't need a box pause the games
could stand on their own so why not put
the games anywhere that's what the
person with the suit is thinking right
and it's just a matter of who wins out
right absolutely B who wi absolutely and
then you have examples that the
corporates you know corporate cogs will
say will be like yo the the Minecrafts
look what happened look at the a look at
the the Call of Duties and stuff like
that when stuff is every I get it I know
what's going on we just got to see how
play out I know we've gone long on this
I just want to make sure everybody had
got their bars off for we move on adct
I'm gonna definitely need your help on
the super chats if you can do we got a
bunch what's the what's the last one you
guys had oh man oh you we haven't read
any we haven't read any from since left
i k got off oh yall bro topic was crazy
no we literally talked to like we've
been on the topic the whole time one
topic this is this is the first topic we
just ended the first that people wanted
the streets wanted to know you been
going it's been crazy bro it's been
crazy if so if you want to get that
that'd be
appreciated he can't see them oh he
can't see them on the phone I can't on
the phone I can can blocking me on the
phone I can on the phone I can't I can't
on the laptop oh good girl we got you
now put that man to work put that man to
work I'll be right back yeah yeah I'll
bounce after this I'll read yeah lock
them in we got a Lucius Augustus M for
29 months L bronze Xbox is the girl that
you asked to pay for her nursing school
and as soon as she starts a residency
she leaves you for a Japanese
stud said that wow no I didn't read that
one that one okay okay then we got Sage
with the $2 I meant Jamaican dollars
jokes I mean
you yeah Sage said he pay us $1,000 for
five weeks if we're right yeah in
Jamaican
dollars M Smart
M then we got J Boy On The Run $2 CH
Xbox is pushing the Industry facts facts
not
Sony we're not we're not debating that
but you know then we have Ethan de years
again with the 35 Zars we went from wait
until E3 to wait until the summer Xbox
is the guy to go clubbing with the
homies and when the fight breaks out
they how you hide in the club all right
there we got Hollywood rules $5 Super
Chat buy this mustard Hearts listening
to Port begging narrative creating
embarrassing always falling for the
banana and the
tip this is the truth bro dude they you
got them talking like you King this
is
line we got it's literally the Frontline
boring boring right now we got Hollywood
rules $2 shocking after a suspect show
rumors
ar oh man not like this not like
this then we have uh blue the $2 Super
Chat Colin is wild funny Kong will unal
I I'm funny how Dave the DI had Godzilla
in it I started cracking up when I saw
that oh my God that that was so dope
that was hilarious why ain't nobody clip
that you monkey
Mouse then we got uh the woke Credit
Union with the $2
$20
what oh wait a minute Kang it's me free
R Kelly wait R Kelly got a new aliot
he back he back he's out he's out he's
out fre Kelly's
outside income tax showed up he he
witness he witness protection what's his
new
name incom tax showed up so now he's
able to Super Chat again a don't do it
like
that don't do him like
that let me see my old account got
banned for trolling I ended up getting
my finance degree going to work on
getting my CFA hey shout out to you
brother told go work go work at Sony so
you can help them with their
finances I told y'all before COA is
wased up anyone buying DS2 is throwing
their money away oh facts on that one yo
I was not feeling that little puppet
thing
hilarious Yo tell me why he stole that
from God of War now he got a little head
on his pocket
too weird those stuff but this one moves
in five frames per second you
know
yeah like spider
Spiderman this this is what happens when
you you go for
Kima he can't be rained in can't be too
loose that's what happens when you go
full SSD oh man I like the part where he
say oh you put to the back what's up
with that
yeah we got one punch Jedi $5 chat
Microsoft giving PlayStation money it's
like them giving Apple money back in the
day but y'all still the
oppos that's like King vaugh going out
there giving you lunch to make you get
stronger C you in the
playground the bully the bully driving
you to school and beat you up in
class
messie
continue reminds me of that I can't
remember what movie it was maybe someone
in the chat could say it where Ice Cube
was a teacher and he said after class
I'm going to beat you up like yeah I
know what you talking about when yeah
ice was the substitute teacher and other
teacher ratted him
out and then the whole time the teacher
kept looking at the uh the clock can we
can we avoid this like try to get out
the situation you get these hands
son then we have JD Gamer Let me see JD
gamer $10 ch has always gotten his
consumer facing Brands wrong Xbox is not
a utility device a service we play games
not because we need to but because we
want to Microsoft must realize that Xbox
is different they I mean obviously they
have because they've been with you know
Xbox has been part of Microsoft forever
right but I mean Xbox as a console in
the console space before this game
passed before the services thing was
very different to what Microsoft proper
does so
at some point you had to figure they
were G to try to incorporate that right
and we got Lord that's five P CH I don't
need to see the books given oneye high
five rush and six years of SE of Thieves
to Sony Gamers isn't going to move the
needle as far as cash to Xbox that's
what adct said true that is
true let me see then we got JD gamer
again $10 super chat if Microsoft wants
Xbox meaning its gaming division to
succeed not just in the short term but
for three long term then you must
provide the Xbox brand with value or you
end or you're or you end up with another
Zoom that is correct it's correct we got
Lucius Augustus $5 super check if you're
a third party publisher who brings your
game to Xbox when the Box continues to
sell less and less as the Xbox dude I
continue to lose
how no I get it but I mean the only In
fairness the only thing is the third
party I mean as far as the Xbox game
studio if they they're seeing other
Studios able to put their games
multiplat they going to be like well why
can't we do that you see what I'm saying
and that creates another internal
problem in the building you know what
I'm saying so they they got to if they
if the RS are
true at that point I'm like who bought
who playing Power again I
see enslaving them5 Super
Chat M real quick real quick like the
thing is though I don't see like like
Sony like just be oh you know dotin you
could still make their St multipl we
should be a doy PlayStation be like okay
are you are you Bungie no no okay you
you're naughty dog they make games for
PlayStation we don't really know because
they just put out an edct talking about
they want their games everywhere so we
don't know exactly what they're talking
about well we don't have with their fan
base is a bunch of jelly backs I ain't
going to front those little mustard
Hearts over there staying strong in they
poo poo but our guys over here
geez yeah yo you had chance of rain
these dudes got scuba gar on the
forecast chance of they the ocean CH of
rain are you are you saying they're the
kind of person to go they get like three
inches of snow they go to the store
buying all the water toilet paper snow
FL not even that they tell them it's a
chance of snow and they be buying toilet
paper and stuff like that you preemptive
dudes oh I just want to just make sure I
just want to be in control shut up you
ain't in control you control if you
purchase a box you don't like what the
Box is doing get rid of the evil box all
right box then his Microsoft might go
the other way King then you go the other
way man what's wrong with
you not like this oh damn damn softies
oh
man then we have NC $5 Super Chat
Microsoft treats games like they treat
office but they forgot that they had the
Monopoly before putting office
everywhere Xbox ain't in that position
yeah but gaming is more than office now
though hey you say whatever you want
with Call of Duty doing what it do like
you all these dudes talk about all that
they not in this position to do that yes
he
is yes and you then the problem is you
don't know that she could do it you
really ah she she G cheat like that cuz
her leg don't work like that on Tuesday
yes it
do y'all keep on thinking that he's not
as versatile as he is they got they
literally yo Microsoft games is beating
Windows they wherever they want to be
that's they all had of window that's a
fact y yall bugged out
crazy but they forgot they had the
Monopoly before putting alas everywhere
Xbox ain't in that
position we got the legendary Yi $2 talk
that talk my dog adct Mad Dog addict
they was mad dog adct they was feeling
ad go AC then we have Kujo 2099 which
$10 Super Chat Sega was innovating with
their consoles first on CD first on 3D
versus on internet where are they now
there's a limit of how far you can
innovate the games have to be ready
ready to uh the
idea yeah I believe that I think he mean
he me I think he meant Gamers have to be
ready to the idea yeah but see that did
you summarize Sega up into the
peripherals and not the internal
conflict between Japan and the USA if
they was all on one Accord the still
they'll still be here they would still
have Hardware but they weren't on one
Accord so it's a misnomer to believe
history and and to to not know know the
actual history we live the history so
Sega didn't go out because they made 3D
light guns and glasses bro they they
they would have at least lasted longer
because I the thing is people people F
to realize is that when PlayStation came
into the game PlayStation is back then
what Xbox is now is that PlayStation was
the consumer electronic product jumping
into video game that had a hell of a lot
more money than Sega so Sega might have
lasted a little bit longer just on
strength of their games and their
consoles the in fighting caused it to
die sooner but again PlayStation's goal
was to kill Sega yeah and that I don't
think Microsoft goal is to kill Sony
they literally you know is interesting
go ahead I just G say you real quick
bring up how Sega had an internal
conflict and we're talking about today
how Microsoft got conflict so yeah well
that you're talking about for one no
it's not similar you talking about in
philosophies and we're talking about
Hardware Hardware conflicts is very is
is very detrimental of course you're
going to have philosophy uh conf right
they and they had that but to to also
have differences in Hardway that lasted
up to the last second and getting hard
way out the door where you had limited
yourself that was the detriment within
itself so we you know you have internal
uh philosophies going off at Nintendo
Sony and Xbox it's only competitive and
whoever whoever has the best strategy
wins we just saw Sony go through the
worst year of their existence with 2023
we only putting out one game and they
had to make their own award show to make
that one game the winner all right
um wild you wild I got to throw sauce on
it
relax but they did that happen because
of the change in Philosophy from um
games of service to single player story
driven games and I believe that that
thing to um to move on here Microsoft is
having a philosophy fight it's not the
first time we heard that Matt booty was
fighting to keep games of uh day and
date inside Game Pass so that means that
philosophy fight has been going on since
M booty got there right and now you're
looking at Nintendo Nintendo has a
change of philosophy and obviously these
young kids won because now Nintendo
games have taken a turn on Innovation
and being a whole lot better than the
average you know cut and Pac stuff all
I'm saying is sometimes uh infighting is
good it's not great at the level where
it's detrimental to the product where
you having two different products being
put out and it wins at the last moment
we have shortages and stuff that's it
yeah yeah with Sega was the Sega of
Japan Sega of Japan controlled
everything yeah like there was there
wasn't any collaboration it was you do
what we tell you to do yeah you what you
say slow no I was saying like I I
understand about like yeah that's the
hardware thing is different but when we
seeing at the top level that is a back
and forth on something so big which is
exclusive exclusive games first party
games going to your rival platform I
think that's that that that's bad that's
bad in the sense that especially when
everyone's not on the on the on one
Accord with it yes that's problematic
when people are trying to do their job
on a daily basis and and potentially you
got like 50% of the people doing their
job on something they don't believe in
right and that's what caus exactly
that's what causes departures when
people if if their Vision loses out in
the
boardroom yeah that's what I said you'll
see who won by who Lo who leav who
leaves yeah we got JD gamer $5 Super
Chat Microsoft the numbers guys are
wrong reading the data caus Xbox One
Connect problem diluting Xbox identity
will be a brand nightmare Microsoft
don't do it I gotta agree with JD here
you gota move forward without diluting
the brand that's valid points all right
then we
have Hollywood rules $5 Super Chat Xbox
dude so used to losing they're scared to
win walking around flinching like
battered yep K agrees with that
statement K definitely agrees with that
statement then we got Tyson Lewis member
for 206 months Lord bronze well uh well
you now know now can use the browser on
Apple devices for Game Pass maybe
there's a deal that game pass is
available in smaller versions from the
others yeah we I mean that again that
that is a transformative thing that just
happened and apple may not be happy
about it but it's happening big deal
wall G that's a big deal the wall
Gardens are starting to come
down okay hold on a second this thing is
a lot of super chats and it jumped me
give me a second you good you good
chilling chill in the chat then I could
walk the dog I'll be right
back uh then we got JD gamer again $5
super chat now now with all that above
stuff said pathetic Port begging ponies
got no games we now they ort begging
overdrive salivating in a corner for
high five nope Jesus
scenarios then we got NC with the $2
Super Chat Why by Sega if you can be
Sega oh man that's funny there you
go then we have boy member for 30 months
Lord
bronze the king is talking
boom bo bo bo too much violence brother
Bo worried
over then we have Lord nater lordin
nator $5 after the hundred billion spent
on Xbox I don't think Phil has hit this
power
anymore you see we're gonna find out
we'll find out yeah for
sure but okay what if the scenario what
if he what if he's not at the other end
of the argument oh
oh you live long enough to become the
villain yes you do yes you do man that
would be that would be interesting that
would be devastating to certain people
that are walking C certain individuals
certain individual walking the dog right
now yo that's crazy he he'll be he'll be
walking the dog in the wheelchair is
that with no knees
man man got my man needless damn then we
got RC polygons $10 Super Chat Xbox
shift from exclusives prioritizing
Hardware against Sony focus on becoming
a mega publisher letting games go
everywhere acquire more Publishers to
strengthen platform dominance buy like
2K I mean this is the thing right I
think this is the people weren't seeing
the PA as a long game in that they can
become the most dominant publisher G if
if the industry ends up in that wall
Garden coming down we know who best
equipped for that based on their
infrastructure yeah but but you know
even if even if let's let's say that's
some like Multiverse where where Xbox
where Microsoft stops making the Xbox
hardware and they stop doing that in
order to acquire more big Publishers I
still think Regulators would be like no
you're doing too much yeah like I don't
think I think at this point after ABK
anything that's like over like a five
billion
dollar
they they yeah that's that's G to be
really difficult to happen it'll be yeah
they'll probably do it you know Studio
by Studio stuff like
that the only thing we got to look at
though is we have to look
at that they could be looking at a
potential ubiquitous future with stuff
like that Apple case going down where
the Xbox what is it the cloud gaming app
can go on GeForce now can go on the
Apple the native app not the browser so
if native yeah again if they're
forecasting that they see
I don't know five to seven years from
now that wal Gardens come down whether
based on some legal stuff they this
would accelerate them trying to be
aggressive in in these third party
spaces again not saying it's right but
that could be a mentality for future
forecasting okay hold on I kept getting
keep getting jumped guys are really
excited about this I've never seen in
some super CH from one time they going
in we got JD G again $2 Super Chat
pathetic Port B P don't got no game Just
J just had to say that had to get that
off we got BT Maverick 707 $5 Super Chat
why is everyone calling Stellar blade
Stellar yam when it's for like Stellar
HS wow same thing yeah yeah same thing
same thing let's see then we got JD G
again to Yo Pony Port beggers you ain't
getting no
game he feel away he feel away driving
home the
point then we got d
wow still
super D you walk the
dog yeah and she was giving me a
headache I'm like y Coco come on she
want to attack
the I'm like yo stop attacking the
neighbor yeah they Super Chat crazy for
this topic yo hit that like y'all get
these likes up see 400 likes 1200 in
y'all listening chilling being
comfortable the like the C continue
okay um I absolutely get the impression
that once the ABK deal went down
Microsoft came in and is putting their
foot down on the direction Xbox should
take that could be that well could be
true for sure we got kit moo5 Super Chat
throw Tim Stewart to the bushes he needs
to go with Terry M oh man Tim Stewart
catches Strays not the bushes in the
bushes Terry Mar not the bushes damn
then we got Unstoppable los5 Super Chat
Microsoft has to sacrifice a few games
they're doing it because they inine they
are they're buying something and it's
not Sega it's bigger jumped again Jesus
okay so they gotta pay the rent we got
to get to make sure the bill gota make
sure the bills are paid hold on a second
I gotta see I gotta see what it is that
they're buying hold
on
super that is why they are not talking
we'll see we shall see okay JD gamer
once again $5 Super Chat Phil booty Bond
Remember the Alamo protect the Brand
X Alamo don't forget the oh
man great battle oh man as a brand has a
value that the numbers guys don't
understand and can't easily quantify
that's what slow-mo
said GSD AKA getting stuff done five
chat Money Talks everything else walks
after they spent nearly 100 billion they
are the company's third largest part
time to pay the
stockholders
Roi return on
investment and we got Sage once again
$10 Super Chat Never follow a crowd
number of people saying something means
zero no one knows any everything ABK and
Bethesda caught all off guard I respect
adct voice concerns in hopes that they
don't become a reality all right that
was reasonable Sage I respect
that you still got that money though we
still got you 4k on that money my
Jamaican dollars or not we got that
bread got you what you pay
me they got they tweeted it on IOP they
like we got the receipts on them Co we
got them I said oh damn they coming this
AG then we have the Don cjg five pound
Super Chat uh Philly Spence and the boys
don't need to address the third party
allegations publicly a small
allegations minority online is just
blowing it out of
proportion we'll see we'll see Philly we
have JD gamer again $5 let's not have
another Xbox One Moment data did that
gaming is about a connection and desire
to play games data is inconsistent when
predicting that King is that Coco yeah
yeah yeah hold
on good then we got Raiden blade 5 pound
Super Chat PS Community is all mouthless
service they don't buy their own games
so why will they buy Xbox games they
Port fan just to say we don't need Xbox
Jes yeah he's
wild JD gamer once again in the chat
just in case we didn't hear last time
but Pon got no games # NOS for emphasis
thank you for patronage
patri then we have the woke Credit Union
once again super that's that's that's gu
R Kelly oh wow oh that's his new name
okay got you5 super chat Kang is living
in a Fool's Fantasy game pass was never
viable in the long run now we seeing the
negative effects get back to exclusives
06 to 02 Dam he stepped out too Dam I
want to hear King response to that oh
man then we got the W Credit Union again
$2 Super Chat Xbox flops Halo gears
Starfield redfall
ex be
ETA then we got sju Sage once's again $5
in chat hey cut that out we don't have
to choose between exclusives and Game
Pass day one we will have both even UB
and EA do day one on Subs now still
gonna have to pay that money though yeah
they do they want on Subs now but they
are everywhere chances are they're not
only in the Ubisoft store I was trying
to fight for you brother but they got
you this
time if we see the queen come out on
stage talk about that D oh boy I feel
bad for your bank
account then we got Mike Theo $5 super
chat if XBox One a strengthen the brand
make an EVO for Shooters type uh type
event Call of Duty Halo Doom Quake
OverWatch gears tournaments all at one
venue that would be's that be dope you
need a Esports team that hopefully they
didn't lay off but
exactly we going move on then we have
Bel member for 29 months Lord bronze
peace Lords this is all con we make King
you
muted I'm sitting there like still
superch yeah bro it's crazy I I just
walked the dog twice I've never seen
this before like they are in here all
I'm saying is hit the like button at it
let's see if they lik's hit that like
Buton yeah we we only got 22 yeah this
is more this is more than when they
bought ABK yeah like this is like ABK
like type
energy they expecting me with a new
holding
[Music]
line peace Lord this is all conjecture
we making this up keeping both exclusive
games and day and day Game Pass is an
option I want I want all of them okay
all right then we got mad mad Q mad Q
for 10 member for 46 months Lord bronze
PC Gamers will not pay $70 for games
like console pay like console players
will pay that's another thing the PC
they I mean they they'll buy games on
the platform that they choose more than
likely steam um but they they kind of
used to that $50 maybe 60
like it depends on the game honestly
like they they bought Starfield and
start with and they bought the Early
Edition Millions bought the uh the early
edition of Starfield that was way more
than $70 yeah um Call of Duty is played
more on PC than it is on PlayStation and
Xbox combined and you know ABK charges
that that at $70 now of course you can
get go to stuff like Green Man Gaming
and CD keys and get it for a little off
but PC Gamers will pay for the games
they want that they want that is true
that is true even over PC is rising more
than console PC Master race is taking
over I agree with that I agree with that
then we got Sage once again $5 Super
Chat Xbox don't report numbers for game
pass publicly to not have it used
against Xbox bkg over 30 million over
200 million ma reality reality it's over
500 million act active users oh wow wow
I don't know bro I don't know about
that that sounds like some K&N stuff
that definitely sound very K&N affiliate
I never understand I don't know about
this whole idea I don't talk so I don't
embarrass y'all like I we don't want to
flex on y'all too hard so we gota let
y'all know what we doing yeah yeah okay
then we got Resco $10 super chat if XBox
blames revenue for this move it's their
self-inflicted wounds that got them
there no new game released with the
console Halo infinite no games 22 and
redfall Xbox slows their own momentum
that's a fact uneven years I will agree
with that for sure uneven none of those
things are
like kill you you know what I mean I
mean I guess I guess in in all of them
together maybe bad launch dope 2021 pop
of the year then no 2022 no first party
from what it Starfield R for the 2023
banging Starfield high five Rush uh fors
and all it's yeah they're been up and
down for the generation then we got back
from the dead remember for 11 months
Lord bronze keep your pornh Hub on PS5 I
just want good games without bugs amen
amen salute back got Sage once again
Super Chat I don't agree Xbox hasn't
spoken Microsoft spoke to them on
January 18 2024 XBox doesn't need to
tuck these crybabies in bye
felici he standing on it we got BT
Maverick 775 so CH you guys did read
that Sony's internal leaks were saying
that they were terrified of Game Pass
they can't compete with Game Pass just
saying we talked about it yeah we talked
about that then we got heck that Mao man
$5 Super Chat all hail the powerful
Lords I love the fact that Darth Phil
has his hands on sy's Lifeline one wrong
move byebye syy hash get down on no ps6
wow I don't think it's a plays6
anyway next one it seems like Hector the
Macha man is aligned with a certain
thinking hold on a second I got jumped
again you got out here wow yeah this is
this is man we I've never seen this okay
let me see okay okay Champagne Supernova
$5 in chat s h the money y'all y'all
there's console heathens here I'm with
Xbox the wheels for long big Phil and
Sarah the silence is violence okay it
just might be violence against
you it might be domestic
violence hey
yo then we have Craig H again with the
CR have for Craig holig gifting one ILP
membership we got Craig holig again
again remember for 17 months Lord bronze
Xbox should give me games day one then
milk that game for all the money on all
the other platforms months later great
games for
everybody see we got the rubber knob $5
Super Chat Microsoft was always going
third party Bill said there's exclusives
where Game Pass
exists okay we'll see we'll see hwood
rules $2 Super Chat so are the new
console PL scrap for
2026 still think so yeah but yeah we'll
see we're gonna have a whole
conversation then we got Lord Metroid
member of the 28 months Lord silver I
just want to play Metroid Prim four
before I depart this Mortal form
Jesus subel Matias uh King uh Prince of
purge the Lost Crown is excellent yes
yes it is it's a very good game very
good game the list 22 member for months
Lord bronze what if the reason some
titles go third party is because they're
going to acquire more Studios Publishers
Regulators ABK changed the
math yep that's what I said and that's
what I've been telling you your one more
Acquisitions right shut up and take
it how do you feel about that Lord
acquisition who me about um what games
going what's the question I forgot I'm
sorry what was the question he said he
said the reason they're they're doing
what they're doing is because they're
trying to acquire more stuff are you
okay with sacrificing exclusives to
acquire more uh uh Publishers I mean I
don't know if there's data enough to
suggest that they're doing it just
because of regulators but I mean there's
nothing really going to hold them back
from after you get ABK you all bet is
off nothing can stop you now like you
already you know what I mean like you've
already got the biggest thing going so
unless it was like take two so I don't
know I don't I don't know necessarily
know if I believe that just yet okay
then we have uh JD gamer again $5 Super
Chat Kong must die D
ye color it was all a dream I used to re
Word Up Magazine I know in the
chat Phil protect the Xbox brand now
let's go and spend Sony out of business
yo they
Wilding then we got Gamers play HUD
xzero member for 38 months Lord bronze
what's good Lords Xbox is making a huge
mistake by trying to appease all Gamers
you may win money but you lose your
pride and identity be
Xbox we
again then we got Sage once again $2
Super Chat keep all receipts I'm black
Tony Stark Tyrone Tyrone Stark Tyrone
star all
rightone
Lannister those
Debs that's a good one good that was
good Lannisters always pay their debts P
their Deb that's right
[Music]
buddy y don't when he heard buddy he's
like I don't care if they go third party
now just give me
that hand over to bread I'm a win I'm a
win if we
lose JSU say did you make super
chat then we got Michael Mooney 5 super
chat what if Xbox games are only
available in other subscriptions not
stores then they would it would I mean I
think the part of it is that people
don't buy into the subscription stuff so
then what would be then you kill the
appeal of Game Pass period as well yeah
so unless unless that platform holder is
willing to give you a bag and a half for
whatever game that they want to put into
that service it doesn't make a whole lot
of sense you know all he's talking about
is that Sony Service he ain't talking
about nothing else but the Sony Service
the the CEO don't even care about their
services what the CEO say I got a
service but we don't believe in services
so we got one we got one for the guys
who want
it please then we got Spartan 661 member
of five months with bronze this is my
favorite event on Sundays the IP podcast
is one of the most entertaining things
ever seen the chat is ridiculous and I
love it thanks much love yeah this is
hilarious
topic and we got Sage again5 Super Chat
when SAA recently reported 200 million
uh active users he was referring only to
mobile go read the earnings transcript
Xbox monthly active uses over 500
million and may you talk all right y
talk about we not in position yo they
look like they're in Flight position
right now they on that Runway
we have there we have champag Supernova
$2 Super Chat Tekken is a six out of 10
that needs more G I choose violent
that's not what the street said
though you on your own
buddy the street say it's a zero out of
10 though you Ain the streets
though you don't you don't count you
don't
count we not doing that we not doing it
will be no teken slander
here not doing that one
buddy
uhuh
BFF
reuff we got J rber $10 Super Chat none
of this stuff uh seems fishy to y'all
for the first time in Xbox existence
they potentially could have their foot
on Tony's neck but all of a sudden
they're going to go their party no way
dude let me
I doubt it's this but do you think there
was some kind of
like like some kind of um dealings that
was made that we don't know about for
ABK oh like ABK was a it was like it was
like it was canc like they were going to
shut it down and and Xbox was like wives
if we do more third party deals I think
that's going on right now that wasn't
reported publicly
I think that's going on right now I
think that's the whole gist of the whole
thing like I told you I thought ABK was
streets this stuff it just seem so out
of place so fast like it wasn't really
thought of too much it's just like the
moment the ABK did was closed and now we
starting to like hear rumors that
they're going third
party it just felt it felt really quick
listen a lot of you a lot of these uh
higher positions they only stay in these
positions for probably five six years
it's like if look at your favorite NFL
player right favorite NFL player usually
stays with that team five six years they
have contracts and in these contracts
some of these are performance-based
contracts so and these performance-based
contracts if they can produce at a
certain level they get a certain amount
of money same thing with these CEOs and
these uh guys in places they're in
places they have performance package
Peres so now that Microsoft looks over
and sees Xbox making his bread that's
making more of the windows they look
over and say yo all right yo we bet the
form on this right here cuz I can get my
performance package up because I'd be
out in six years anyway and the
philosophy had changed so it's really a
doggy dog world that's going on up there
and everybody is pushing for the
financials now if you get all the
financial teams that's hungry that's
trying to average you know on a
basketball court with dud trying average
like this dude ain't passing Rock
performance review numbers up he messing
up the team the brand is going down man
we used to be known as a spread the ball
around team now we just a ISO ISO shoot
team this is not good for us that's what
the the identity that you're having
right now you're trying to figure out
why they talking about this right it's
rumors until we lose until philling the
other team that want to kill Kong when
they lose then you already going to know
sa and the other team won and they gonna
spread him around okay so pray that Sati
a young Odin for fall asleep and he go
fall asleep he goes into the old and
sleep where he 5 years and nobody nobody
worries about him and we get Tim behind
out of here cuz Tim you causing a lot of
problems every time every time I say a
dude name like P hind look at my resume
you GNA speak him out of existence I
said P hind go Tim do it got to go oh
man damn so King we were talking about
you you walking the
we talked about what what if behind the
scenes if Phil is on the other team oh
yeah he's not on the other team he's not
on team he's not on other team the
reason that's why he's quiet is adct
laughing off screen laughing off scre
that's that's that's no that was
slow-mo he's that's why he's quiet he's
not on other team he's fuming he he's
socking people in the mouth I'm you g
see you GNA see order restraint
paperwork come out on my man he can't go
to that side of the building okay so
okay so let's say you're right you're
right and he he loses the fight though
is he is he holding the line and walking
away or he's going to think he Le I
think I told
you the the ones that lose watch who
leaves I told y before when Reggie left
Reggie is like whatever was going on
Reggie's like I yeah I'm not doing that
y'all can eat those um Sean leaden he
was fighting so much they had to remove
him like
you they walked him out the building he
was putting he was putting boots to ass
so I'm right now I'mma tell you anytime
you got to get removed from the
[Laughter]
building you was putting boots to butt
you was that guy that they didn't went
over there don't tell Tyrone cuz he get
violent you that guy so I already know
listen the y'all y'all are hearing this
is people whispering looking at the
fight reporting the fight yo I'm tell
you right
now they talk about putting a high five
rush and um see thev over you know they
talking about doing that but but oh wait
a second Phil just socked him in the
mouth I'll be right
there oh that sounds good that's just
happening so when every time y'all hear
these all these rumors yes Sarah bond is
coming out they try to force RoR to do
it and I don't know what she going to do
she going to come out in the springtime
cuz you know what she said I'm not ready
to say that now get that out here get
that microphone out of my
face so y'all think Phil now Phil is
gonna say today and you know he got his
man M booty if I can go on anything I
know for a fact M booty up there raising
hell I know that for a fact I know I
know that he he's swinging the moms over
there for us bro I can't imagine cuz we
know Phil watches the podcast yo sorry I
got I gotta
go we got two yeah we got two two more
infinite umra and JD gamer infinite umra
adct you got that infinite um J please
BR I can't imagine Phil Spencer yeah
listening to the podcast hearing oh I
punched someone's face what did that
happen K says you did that pH imaginary
F that's C pH that's that's that's young
squabbler young young squabble
squabble what we got you got infinite
umra with the5 Super Chat iron Lords
what if Microsoft was bringing games to
Sony and Nintendo platforms because they
agree to allow game pass on them would
that be acceptable I Phil said see
that's what people would have no problem
with Phil said Game Pass exist yeah
that's that's crazy
acceptable that would be that would be
the ultimate everyone bent the need a
Microsoft that would be the ultimate
Brandon like you know how when go out
there and they brand their cattle
yo you will wear this Mark B over and
you this Mark you got to put it on the
cheeks
son cuz your
cheeks that's crazy are you just sit
there that's that's too that's too much
dominance we going to move on put it in
the
fire not the fire
BR dve from JD gamer Kong must die he
spell
die but math be math and Xbox unit sales
may be up 50% even though Hardware
Revenue was good transition to finally
get to the next topic awesome so
now King topic Microsoft's gaming
revenues overtake Windows thanks to
Activision Blizzard gaming is now the
third largest business at Microsoft but
device revenue is still struggling
despite the PC market pickup shout out
to Tom Warren and The Verge so it looks
like Xbox content Services Revenue again
Game Pass which includes Game Pass is up
a massive 61% because of the Activision
Blizzard revenues He also mentioned the
um that as far as that the hardware he
said is only up 3% after the after the
quarter um after the holiday quarter he
said Microsoft ran a series X promotion
during the holiday in the US but it
doesn't appear to have result in Big
Boost in sales and revenue AB Hood BL
blamed a weaker than expected console
Market but overall Microsoft's Gaming
revenue is up
49% and uh yeah it said it's an
important quarter from gaming at
Microsoft as it's now the company's
thirdd largest business gaming
contributed
7.1 uh billion in revenue for the
quarter more than 5.26 billion from
Windows but behind the uh 13. 4 uh
billion from office and cloud services
and the Giants 23 uh billion from server
products and cloud services so King this
is your topic on Z Revenue what would
you like to say
sir I thought xbx wasn't
profitable I thought we couldn't make
the Bucks we number three we're number
three in our whole division
son we out here we big dogs on campus
son you understand so so when they come
with the money baggies what what's
what's what they call those um sponsors
in um college football what what they
call those Don the boosters I forgot
what they
call when so when the boosters come
through you know they putting money on
they putting money on my back they
putting money on the gamer division back
Xbox the brand my man we run the land
heyy window see you in the redie miror
baby oh that's what is cuz G pass
Windows yeah you know that CL only thing
that's better than us right now is cloud
and AI you heard
me how they they running the joint yo
that scared the hell out of me that
scared the hell out of
me because when you start making money
y'all heard the line biggy said More
Money More
Problems when you making little pigeon
money in the in the corner you good like
they always look at you like yo I wish
you get your weight up yo go ahead man
get your weight up and they not looking
at you you could go continue doing what
you was doing making the moves that you
was making then when you start making
noise on the street dudes start getting
hungry that's when the vultures is
out this is where you got to carry
yourself different that's when you got
to make your circle Tighter and once I
saw that they was making that bread I
said
damn they not going to be the same no
more it's like when Champions like when
your favorite Champion you hope your
favorite Champion when he wins the belt
he um continues to train hard he
continues to go to the gym he continues
to get up out of those silk sheets in
the night you know um silk sheets make
soft
men stuff going to change they're making
enough bread they being acknowledged by
different people do they stay the same I
don't think so oh you do think changes
coming there I I listen first of all I
knew ABK is for the streets I knew that
for from the beginning with the verbiage
with with with they say you know select
titles to go XY to go to different
places and Legacy titles will still be
there so that means that you're not
shutting off the door you're not
shutting the valve off when you walk in
if you want to kill something you g to
shut off the water I don't give a damn
what I pay for this it's mine I take the
penalties Regulators right yeah but but
see this is where you already made the
capitulation you already did the science
behind it and you figured out what was
going to rock over there and what wasn't
right if y'all if y'all really want
Microsoft um to Value Game Pass and to
Value the direction that they going
because I think they're going all
digital in a second to be honest with
you well H all there with hell Blades by
by the
hellblade buy the Helder blade in order
to make sure that you still get these
first party
if hell blade doesn't sell and this is
the experiment that I've been thinking
if it doesn't sell it doesn't make that
money that was a gamble I think from the
Phil side and um Matt booty and them
side to fight that's a fight gamble he's
betting on us the board is
watching and the board going to say okay
eternally that didn't work so now we
need to launch it on
everything you understand so they they
looking now now this directly making
more Revenue put wrong eyes on the
product okay and now you this is the
reason why you you hearing bad messaging
or people scrambling in the background
because when you pop out and you say oh
200 million from mobile total like a
close to like a 300 400 million eyes on
this
product then you look back and say okay
how can we how can we make more eyes how
how can how how how how okay so how does
that transfer to my bank account those
how did this game equate to me my back
how how do I squeeze the dudes that's
over here the day
ones yall not the little startup band no
more guys we not them no more we're not
the dudes that's playing the small
Arenas anymore where we had a personal
conversation with the band remember when
you used to be Ries following the band
now they playing bigger Arenas and they
may not see you they may not see your
hand anymore in the crowd and you may
say oh man they became too corporate and
too bougie but this is what you wanted
you wanted for them to be Superstars you
wanted for them to reach them Heights
right you did want Kong to die I mean
it's just yeah see my my wants ain't
what they want though I realize that
right now when I was looking at it I
said damn they don't really want coner
to die like
me because if I'm looking at it you have
the moment to stab him jig them whatever
you send out the kite you warned them
you warn the dude that you trying to
kill so when you warn somebody that
you're trying to kill then you don't
really want him dead at all and then I
started going back listening to what you
was saying you was telling me the whole
time I don't view him as competition
yeah said that that's been on record I I
viewed I would like to help them you
making little sign treaties with him you
talking to them on the golf course
that's why he jammed you up cuz they
view you as a sucker you
soft how many how many times do they got
to smack you up and beat you up and and
you sit there and be like he's my friend
he's not your friend and if you don't
want what I want for him then in the end
he going to do you in damn the
corporates is busted Hearts too damn so
you got to really you got to really take
the time out to understand all money
ain't good
money kill them
off kill them off because they going to
sit around they going to get stronger
they ain't going to have another year
like last year on another piss poor year
like this year you give them one more
year and they slide up on you with that
Wolverine and that other stuff those
financials is going to look a little bit
different so you kill him off while you
got the
chance because your financials ain't
going to be this robust if they get a
chance to hold it down and I'm looking
at it and you got the wrong people in
place put this video in front of them
let them know that money is a poison
pill we kill them we take them pillage
and take the village don't let them
survive what about the women and
children if if they let them continue to
play on playstation fours and FES let
that die out let them become a memory
because if you don't they're going to
slide up on you they're gonna finish you
off and you going to be third party and
you're going to stand next to the other
guy looking at looking at like look at
us how did we get we tried to be friends
with them
too boss all right all right listen the
K the kid got smoken you know I guess
whatever the team is that's fighting the
good fight you know King is riding with
y'all whether it be the Phils the the
Saras the Mad booties the Aaron green
bird you heard it from the King he's
riding with y'all he just don't like the
jelly back mustard heart other dudes he
don't like other whoever those other
dudes in females may be dude to do that
baby king is not with that he those are
balls those premium King balls right
there I respect that Lord SLO your
thoughts on the revenue Gaming revenue
Microsoft uh gaming is now um third
overtaken uh on
Windows yeah um I the numbers look good
the numbers look good and I anticipate
that that will continue throughout the
rest of the year um as they continue to
keep reporting each quarter over the
next year there those those yearly those
year-over-year results are going to be
compared against what they were uh
resulting last year and with ABK in
there you're going to continue to keep
seeing this kind of like anywhere
between 40 to 60% Revenue growth um and
they'll and they'll keep you know
shouting that out to the rooftops now to
kind of echo what what king is talking
about the concern here and and being as
someone who has who's worked in the
corporate world for a number of years
I've dealt with I've dealt with where uh
CEOs and Boards make really weird moves
simply because they are trying to show
the shareholders that we're still
growing we still got year-over-year
growth even though even even though that
year-over-year growth may not be exactly
what is necessary for your brand maybe
you just need consistency right now you
know but they when you're doing good but
it's just it seems stagnant shareholders
who don't quite understand what you're
doing start chirping and often times you
will see with different companies that
they start making moves not for the the
health of the business but to appease
people who
know what
talking so although this year is is
going to look great for them financially
on the Xbox division all year long every
time they come out with a financial
report it's going to be roses and and
fireworks and great next year though
yeah that's good point when now next
year is comparing to this year and
you've got ABK in the in your pocket for
longer than 20 20 longer than 12 months
then you're going to start to get a lot
more of that pressure we're seeing some
of that pressure now
that will ramp up as people start asking
well how do we grow from here how do how
do we take this and continue to grow
further that's where the kind of talk
that we we really like have been
discussing for like two hours already
starts to really really you know whether
they make a decision on it and they say
no this year that talk could come back
up once we say oh well growth is was was
less than 10% but last year growth was
was like it's like yeah you know why it
grew like that yeah come on now but it's
and like like I said it still it looks
good it looks great and I hope that I
hope that my hope is that the first
party
games really help catapult them even
further yeah uh hellblade 2 AOW Indiana
Jones those games come out like I hope
those games help push Game Pass
subscriptions to where they want them to
be I hope that even outside of that on
Steam you know the sales ising because
all of that will end up being a end
result of there's ammo for the other
side screw your screw what your metrics
say good point this is us not doing that
and putting our games over there and
still resulted in us looking the way
we're looking right now which which is
kind of the course which was kind of the
statement Starfield made right because
Starfield yeah did had so much success
and let's be honest without PlayStation
with steam the what you call it and and
again not saying that that can't happen
but I'm just saying like there there was
a proof of concept of div vision and how
successful was and people were willing
to buy the consolation joint early
before Game Pass and all that too so I
see your point like they need more
examples of that that side that's
fighting that fight in the building
right to to justify staying the course
to the whatever it be the financial guys
or the you know the data guys that kind
of thing that's a good point it's a good
point Lord addict your thoughts on the
revenue Microsoft is gaming is bigger
than than
Windows I don't care I knew he was gonna
say I don't care I don't care about the
uh the numbers you know but I do agree
with uh Saul you know when you start
adding up those because right now
they're just comparing what they made
last year to this year and because of
ABK it looks good but next year you'll
have ABK so there's nothing unless they
go and buy like a T2 or something like
like there there's there's nothing to
compare it to so it's just like look
like you know back to the last
conversation MH it's like you know I I
hope works out for them yeah I do uh I
hope Xbox makes all this money I hope
you know maybe we put too much emphasis
on third part on first party games this
entire time Gamers be emotional uh so
you know maybe that's the case uh or you
know maybe we we having maybe we end up
having a podcast talking about the good
old days of Xbox
back in the day son
remember back in the day back in the day
son podcast I can't you stupid that was
funny sorry the thing is is like you
know I I guess it's hard for me to oh
you make more money than Windows like
it's like that's cute but you're also
dropping the ball more two like it's
like it's hard to celebrate one when I
when I kind of see a direction I don't
agree with going to it cuz it's like how
long you going to keep that
up no that's fair I I'll jump in pretty
much not too much to add I agree with
mostly what everything was said my only
concern was um the the the net impact
from the acquisition it said it was over
two billion in Revenue but the cost of
integration transaction costs and other
costs of Revenue all to totaled 930
million with other operating expenses
more expenses 1.5 billion it worked out
to an operating loss of 440 million so I
hope that don't continue you know what
I'm saying as far as um you know in a
post ABK world like you know how does
this equate once Call of Duty now is
integrated into Game Pass right or with
with the thought process or you know now
they start getting this revenue from
King and mobile and all that stuff so
I'm very curious to see how that
continues to track and of course you
know Amy Hood did not like the hardware
sales you know declining whatever I mean
even though no offense to Amy Hood yeah
uh oh but my thing with Microsoft it's
it's not nothing on her it's like you
literally for the past few years have
done nothing but scream from the top of
your lungs you don't need a XBOX cuz
stuff's on PC you don't need a XBOX they
literally did a Starfield commercial
where they said you just need a
controller and a TV if you want to play
Starfield and then you got AB C on here
say she's disappointed with consoles you
think what did you do to to to to
promote said yeah absolutely nothing
what they did I get you no that's fair
that's fair and that that's a question
they going to have to answer in
reference to you know doing something to
try to boost hardware sales or you know
maybe that those generational rumors are
true as far as the looking at a 2026
2027 potential skew thing but yeah
overall look this is big um you know
it's it's proof that they needed that
acquisition and now it's just a matter
of again seeing the course and like
slowmo said if the game are good and
they get this expected Revenue they
should be fine hopefully I means stay
the course we'll see but again these are
people that are smarter than me that
have data so we'll see how it plays out
but that's all I got uh next time we got
super chats uh adic you want me to rock
those what we got what we got I don't
think we have any super chats do we have
any merchandise buys no no no we good we
good um I think it was we got did we get
JD G with the $5 yeah we got him Kong
must die with the ye okay cool yeah yeah
all right cool so this was s's topic I
believe um Sony and the Xbox handheld so
there's a lot of um rumors going around
um shout out let's get out this one from
um WCF Tech um says that uh Playstation
handheld powered by AMD is an early
development and um looks like uh it's
reported by Mo la de in a new YouTube uh
video they said the Japanese company is
looking to plan to entered the handheld
Market with new hardware and console
will be powered by custom AMD Apu it's
currently in the high level design phase
that meaning it is uh two at least two
years away but hasn't been green lit for
release as of yet and um yeah they just
basically said that um this will be more
of a modern PlayStation games on a
portable device um but unlike the
PlayStation portal most likely uh Native
and it said this move would not limit
lines for King this move would not limit
Sony's pursuit of PlayStation 6 as a
traditional Home console allowing it de
cada to both portable and high powerered
gaming experiences they also um go on to
say that uh yeah that this is you know
early stage production but we will see
if it's green lit so that was the first
thing and then shout out to good friend
of the realm Jess Gordon from window
Central he uh has an article out in
reference to the Xbox an Xbox handheld
saying is isn't just likely for
Microsoft it's absolutely necessary so
he is feeling extremely bullish that
Microsoft will also be entering the um
handheld uh Market he he uses a point of
um PlayStation and Microsoft kind of
being tied of not having full control
you know over their storefronts and
footprint you know with having to deal
with them and um yeah they he pretty
much said that let me just get the
paragraph which is um yeah that they
they want to be able to monetize and do
what they want to do and without you
know the interference of Google and
apple he said that those two also hurt
Microsoft's AI Ambitions their Cloud
Ambitions and also hurt Microsoft's
office and business Ambitions and of
course they can hurt uh gaming ambition
so they look at stuff like the steam
deck look at stuff like the ra Ali where
Microsoft could have you know these
Hardware endpoints and the as stronger
as companion devices and he is bullish
he thinks this is coming so yeah let's
start off with slow um these rumors of a
I'm sorry I said yo yeah yo I'm sorry
okay no my yeah so yeah there rumors of
a of play of handhelds legit you know
native handhelds for both uh PlayStation
and
Xbox well I I would say this I I I don't
believe all rumors and and and depending
on who it's said from I think about
their record and I think about some of
the things they've said in the past like
PlayStation is going to be PlayStation 5
is going to be far more powerful than
the series X that was also said from
from the guy that is saying this and I'm
like got you I don't think about I don't
know about that one so but but I
sometimes I think people throw stuff at
the wall and sometimes it sticks and I
mean we even saw with the leak uh
through the FTC where all that Xbox uh
documentation came out and they had if
you look at one of the the slides it had
all of these different under Xbox these
different pieces of Hardware accessories
and one looked like something that
looked like very switch like you know
something looked like it wasn't a switch
but it looked like something that was a
some kind of Xbox handheld device I
think that I think both Sony and Xbox
tend to make a lot of prototypes and
they throw ideas out there and they see
where things can work and sometimes they
can't like for example that the dongle
That was supposed to be uh connected to
TVs uh that ended up not happening for
for for whatever reason you know and so
I think that if it does happen that's
great for me personally I I I do this
with handhelds all the time I buy them
like I had a steam deck I had a Logitech
g-cloud I buy this stuff I play with it
for like a week or two it collects dust
for a few months and I sell it and I and
I so I got zero handheld the moment you
know outside of the the switch that yeah
I was going to say do you think that
like the success of something like the
switch with the dockable stuff is
something that maybe Xbox would try in
the future or Playstation cuz like
there's no way people don't see how
successful the switch was where you able
to dock it and not see that maybe we can
like bite off of that a little bit right
yeah I think I think that's the wave and
I think going a little further the
docking aspect might yield more power
because now it's docked and maybe you
can actually uh the the power usage the
power draw can be raised and you can
actually push a little bit more
performance out of it than just strictly
in the handheld mode but yeah absolutely
we see what all the PC manufacturers are
doing it now like even trash razor which
you know sorry I don't know if you guys
look
cool sorry that's respons with
y'all you even even Razer at CES was
like yeah we got one too so everyone's
got one everyone's doing that and
they're all very similar even though I
think the the raising one's doing Intel
but like a lot of them are running with
AMD apus a lot of them are doing the
same thing where it's it's it's it can
be docked it could be uh connected to
your TV but also it's it's a handheld
that's a bit more powerful than what the
the current Nintendo switch is whether
it stays more powerful than the switch 2
right that's that you know that's to be
determined but everyone's follow valves
move with the steam deck and I think
that's kind of shown at least to Sony
and Xbox that yeah this is this could be
a viable thing especially when you have
a platform already of Hardware consoles
where hey look you got your you got your
Xbox but you could also like stop
playing Persona 3
reload go out and do something and take
this handheld with you and continue on
exactly where you were in the game
that's like that's something you can
Market really well and it's easier to do
that uh through Xbox and PlayStation
Sony then say Val with steam deck trying
to like they still don't even have Game
Pass Apple there now natively and that's
and with some of the other like R Ally
has issues Hardware Wise from what I
hear they I think they could do it a lot
better than these other companies have
right but again it's all it's all up in
the air and it's all depends on if they
actually have take those prototypes and
say yeah okay this can work but yeah I I
need to hear I need to hear it from
someone else outside of the current
Source we got breaking news y'all
um addict um I think we need to talk
about it
now um put a check the I chat I just
sent it there um I read it to slow now
this is something that came across also
um our line me and adct in reference to
um Starfield so shout out to Xbox era um
looks like they put it out officially
right now um exclusive Microsoft plan
Starfield launch for PlayStation 5 oh
and it says for many weeks now rumors
have persisted regarding the Microsoft's
intention to release a number of first
party games namely high-fi rush and sea
of Thieves on Rival platforms according
to our sources who have King's going to
like this who have asked to remain
anonymous but they were not authorized
to talk about company plans that list of
games also includes Bethesda game Studio
Starfield and basically says that
according to sources we understand that
correctly Microsoft are planning uh
currently excuse me Microsoft are
planning a launch for Starfield on
PlayStation 5 post the release of the
already announced shattered space
expansion for Xbox and PC which is on
target to arrive at some point later
this year we've also been informed that
Microsoft has made additional investment
into PlayStation 5 Dev kits to support
ongoing development efforts adding fuel
to the fire so yeah this seems there's
more there's more um as as already
existing rumor suggested the idea of
bringing first-party titles to competing
console platforms marks a massive change
and strategy for Microsoft and for what
I understand it's not been without
Fierce internal debate on this new
Direction releasing Starfield on
PlayStation 5 contradicts the original
statement around exclusivity made by
president of Xbox Sarah Bond during the
Xbox and bethesda's game studi summer
Showcase of 2021 and I quote it is
awesome to share with you this is 2021
with you for the very tough time our
most one of the most anticipated games
in the world from Todd Howard and the
team at Bethesda game studios a
groundbreaking game and yes it's
exclusive uh continues on according to
our s sources Microsoft's senior
leadership have reportedly debated the
various pros and cons of releasing more
of their exclusive software elsewhere
and internally not everyone is
necessarily happy with the decision but
recouping the potential money left on
the table by not releasing elsewhere has
arguably won out according to sources
Hi-Fi Rush releasing on Rival platforms
is tentatively planned for q1 this year
and we've been advised to expect
Microsoft to make a more public
announcement on this new strategy this
month shout out to Xbox era they uh put
it out there we did hear this um me and
AD yeah we sat I'm smoke you know what's
funny is we kind of like we de de on WE
to talk about it because like we don't
really try to be the people that like
spread rumors and and specul
but like you know a lot of the case goes
down to it like the people that are
telling us this we trust so this
particular they've been right multiple
times multiple times so normally like I
said actually you can you can make an
argument these suckers ain't never been
wrong yeah the source we have in
reference to this sources have been
extremely accurate you know with tons of
stuff recently so this did come across
our line you know we were debating
internally what we we going to um run
with it or not shout out to Xbox era
that that did run with it um yeah we got
to talk about it we got to talk about
let's let's start straight with you
because
um Sage is ready F I gotta break for f
Xbox error story is bogus nobody at
Microsoft would ever leaked that a
transparent attempt to sabotage the
game's big DLC impact on Xbox wow you
going to that Xbox era you see wow just
say it's the G stage just just PayPal is
5gs now oh hold on we got Tom Henderson
in the chat shout out to Legendary so
Tom I need you now now you you you're a
trusted sauces a lot of sauces shout out
to S Koo in the chat from Xbox era he's
laughing at suggest to Sage Tom
Henderson we got everybody in the chat
right it's lit it's super lit Tom
Henderson friend of the realm would love
to know if you can uh also Co cooporate
that cuz uh have you heard things in
defense in defense DM shout out to my
man s Kango in defense of him we have
heard the same so we just would like to
collaborate you know if Tom Henderson
heard the same don't get quiet now Tom
don't get quiet now just just just blink
once yeah for no and twice we know you
want to D you know what I'm saying but
you know give us a blink let us know
just blink once per just blink once per
yes and okay I've Tom hederson I've
heard things many things all right but
has one of those things been Starfield
let's get to it let's get right to it
Tom you can't you can't deny cuz two
people don't put it out now if you heard
or not where we go trying to dance
around don't dance baby don't dance I
know you got an article cooking I know
you got WordPress and everything's ready
to go sick and Koo who's in the building
he wants to come on and talk yeah yeah I
got you the invite bro I got you on that
I need to know from Tom while we while
we waiting and then while we waiting
adct I'll let you to cut because you
know we we had this we were sitting on
this one too a mistake oh mistake um I
think Tom said yeah I heard via Xbox
ER Tom a cosigned Tom ain't cosigned
okay you standing on business all
right go ahead I'm sorry I think Tom
coign because if he if he if it was a no
Tom would literally say it's Tom you can
get in here too yeah Tom come all me get
sick sick let me get sick of Tom here
keep it yeah see look
look unfortunately uh Microsoft thinks
this direction is going to be best for
the brand and um it's either going to be
really will beneficial for them or
they're going to single-handedly ruin
their
brand overnight uh to to be
honest it I don't agree with it you know
Starfield is Miss some qu quotes when it
come to me but it was a fantastic game
and I think a lot of people really
enjoyed it and the fact that you're
looking at something like that is worse
than high five Rush you're looking at
something like
Starfield game arguably one of the the
biggest games you've had in a long time
you mean it's tell me a year and a half
two you going to put that on
Playstation look like I'm I'm going to
be real with you guys I'm going to be
real with you uhoh Xbox this is one of
the very few
times where I'm like PC looking
nice this is one of this they make my
boy look at PC little different
different hey man this year is going to
determine a lot because it's just like I
don't agree I don't and it's just like
you know it's like I said on Twitter can
you can call call me a a mustard heart
it's fine I'll be a must I'll wear the
suit mustard talk I don't agree I don't
agree if they put Starfield on on on
Playstation um I feel like that is the
loser
mentality uh you you have bent the knee
for no reason um I do believe this isn't
Phil Spencer I don't believe this is
Sarah Bon's fault I think this is higher
end people they want their money now uh
to me you made so many statements saying
want long form Investments and this
seems like the most short-term
investment I've ever heard in my life
short money like it's like you going to
sit here and look starford is gonna sell
well on Playstation let's be real here
no it's
not they don't buy
games but at the same time gon buy that
game no they not they'll buy it no they
not like the same way they was capping
for Boulders Gate 3 and nobody brought a
damn thing o game the year all this
other stuff remember exclusive RPG none
of them brought a damn thing we see they
don't buy anything over there this is a
death trap do not
go so at the end of the day you know it
could work out well for them but I'm
gonna be honest with you guys U I think
it unfortunately because here here's my
issue too like Phil Spencer and them
have worked for years to try to bounce
back from the Xbox one generation and
the higher ups
we don't know if Phil's part of it
King's pretty adamant that he's not so
I'm assume I'm I'm I'm a I'm a rock with
king that's what I'mma do I'm a rock
with King he PR pretty adamant that you
know Phil is uh you know losing that
that internal struggle right now I say
he wait
said no I didn't say he losing anything
I say they they Phil is punching people
in the make in the mouth making waiting
for them to come off
pil committing assault and battery
Microsoft build stick with that one and
to me it's like it's like you you're
you're literally right there you've been
building up for years buying exclusives
buying Bethesda buying ABK buying all
these consoles all these uh things
setting up a portfolio for Game Pass and
right there when you're at the end where
you're about to finally get to the ship
that you broke that was broke called the
Xbox one then the other people come out
there and be like oh we caught the other
ship on fire my bad my bad
I'm gonna be real with you it I
personally this is me if they make this
mistake they will be they will be out of
the console generation in the next five
years o so this is brand damage I I
think they will be out of the console in
general Tom hon check DMS check your DMs
brother here's the thing they already
ain't selling consoles like that right
so you mean to tell me that games like
Starfield definitely help sell consoles
like last year right so when you put it
on PlayStation the other people that
were thinking about jumping on Xbox or
maybe thinking would jump on it in the
in the perable future they ain't doing
that now why would they nigg gonna wait
yeah and it's just like it's it's the
most
I there's a term that I like to call
when they're smart people there's some
people at Xbox and uh Microsoft that are
the smartest dumb people I've ever met
in my whole life
like it's just like Whoever thought that
this was a good idea and it might be
maybe I'm wrong I don't know what it's
like to run something in the tri but
what I can tell you is I've been a gamer
for my entire life and I've been I've
been covering this industry for like 10
years everything about this industry in
terms of console manufacturer revolves
around exclusives they're the ones that
get you in the door and then everything
else comes from that now there are there
are outliners such as Call of Duty
marketing rights there are things GTA 5
this is what the people the market
holders fight over but everything is
always oh Tom Warren just dropped oh but
he's quoting Xbox ER okay but but I just
want to be clear um XBox era says
Microsoft yeah planning to release
Starfield on PS5 micros okay so they
just I thought he had something
different now you got there's no time
period is it these dudes is ding right
now tter
didn't Xbox a said after the expansion
Yeah so basically what same what we
heard which is um okay after shattered
space so shatter space comes out was
supposed to be I guess this year
potentially be either this year early so
that after shatter space then they going
come out and say well we're releasing
Shadow space on Xbox and we'll be
releasing Starfield on the PlayStation
platform so so you no no smoke is fire
real quick though I do think that is
100% right on this J say they they are
not looking uh they're looking too much
in short
term and I think they're going to end up
backpedaling all of this after a couple
of these games come out and I don't
think I don't think it's going to be
enough time you know pardon me like you
end up having a
situation where you've already done
enough brand damage like I do I I think
we are right now experiencing
aund times worse than the Xbox one
generation there not to comparison okay
Tim Dog on the street and when people
say stuff like oh this is just for
money the sales are down the Xbox one
was in the worst state Xbox has ever
been in and not one time during that
generation did they make everything
multiplat hold on I got an official
statement from Tom Henderson oh he says
he obvious can't jump on right now but
he says I won't directly co-sign this
news because I've not corroborated my
standards but I've heard similar things
to what Xbox era has reported it should
be stressed that I hear things all the
time but there's definitely substance
here and there's no smoke without fire
if I can collaborate the news you'll
hear it here on www. inssider gaming.com
salute salute Tom Anderson no doubt and
we got my man Joe S M what's going on
Xbox a in the building breaking in
what's up hey bro how you doing what's
going on how we feeling interesting
interesting Sunday afternoon right yeah
it's very interesting lot of lot of news
bre so let's talk about it man let's
talk about it so obviously this came
across your line obviously the laws also
had heard similar things but you put it
out there in reference to Starfield you
know the plans so what what do we hear
what's what's the vbe breing it down I
mean I've been listening to the
discussion right um and it's a pleasure
I think this is my first time on the
show yes this is your debut especially
they came my cherry
yeah what a what a time to be
alive I'll let adct pop your
CH so hit the like button y'all breaking
news say I won't say more than than than
what I've written right uh I've been
working on this since long you
Friday in terms of cooperation um
speaking with other folks within the
industry Beyond uh the source and yeah
uh I I want to kind of just bring this
Back to Basics right
um people say the console war is over
kind of yeah right because you know this
is this is the strategy
right does Microsoft give a [__] if
you're I'm using the Royal oh sorry
there's no swearing on this I apologize
I'm a Brit so I swear like a I apologize
I will appreciate I'll wind that back in
do do Microsoft or generally you know
people that care about the business side
of things care about list Wars and
winning you know for the Twitter bubble
that we exist in right the answer is no
right like fundamentally they don't give
a crap so um you know look at it look at
it from Common Sense point of view
Bethesda were required they were working
on high-fi Rush before they were
required they were working on it as a
mplatform release they were working on
Starfield before they were required it
was being worked on a multiplatform
release does it make sense to a year
down the line throw all that work in the
bin or hey well you know our community's
had that game for a year why don't we
just get some extra money and I
understand and I just want to empathize
this right I understand the folks that
say uh I feel betrayed I feel let down I
understand it I don't necessarily agree
with it it's a plastic box you play
video games on I don't I don't care
where my games come from but I get it I
understand why there is so much
constellation I think overarchingly it
is well what happens in five years when
you know we already talk about third
party support on on Xbox as being
lackluster from certain Publishers s
right now that's starting to improve but
if we live in a world where all or most
exclusives from first Microsoft first
party release a year or two later on on
Ultimate platforms well then why would a
third party start to keep pushing for
Xbox as a platform to release their
games on so I understand all of the
conversation around it but um do I agree
with Microsoft doing this question
what's your thoughts on on the strategy
no I think it's an incorrect strategy on
my part um I totally get leaving money
on the table and I think it works for
some games like live service games think
games that have IP that already exist
you know it's it's a continuation of the
series I think that's an easy pill to
swallow right because the benefit to you
Xbox customers you get it on Game Pass
no worries right but you know so Elder
SC six if they turned around which
inevitably I I feel they probably will
you know like they'll turn around and be
like yeah this is a multiplatform
release like I don't think that that's
bad they've always been multiplatform
release you know who who cares I get it
for for free in my subscription right um
but I think the the the console war
rhetoric that we're seeing um play out
in our Forums on the Xbox here forums
it's horrific on on Twitter we need to
kind of like unplug from that and
realize that one is a three trillion
dollar company that don't care about
this stuff they want to make money um I
think Nick my my co-host he is shout out
to special Nick he is he's often used
the phrase Microsoft don't get it right
and they don't get what gaming is
sometimes I don't think that's always
true okay um but I think when you're in
A3 trillion organization and people are
making calls about justifying costs you
know what we saw the revenue from yeah
we just talked about this is what king
talked about and now bigger than Windows
they're bigger than Windows now so is is
it a situation with King where the I
don't want to say the wrong people but
other people who may not understand how
gaming and kind of what slowmo alluded
to is kind of now that internal group
has one out and it is this is this a a
result of this is this the aftermath of
that is there is now Xbox now shifting
in this potential new Direction because
you know there there's a bag out here we
bigger than Windows yeah I I mean I
think you
know you you were right about you
hearing it and lots of people hearing it
right I think that it was it was
spreading quite quickly so um I mean
we've reached out to Bethesda for
comment right or Bethesda Microsoft for
comment um I wouldn't expect to um but
you know I think it's
becoming pretty clear that someone needs
to say something soon right and and this
is all I will say on the conso world
side of things everyone is talking in
absolutes everyone is talking in the
worst case scenario of hypothetical
right so like this is the death of the
platform right and I would just
encourage I'm not telling you know
people how they think but I would just
encourage it it in 8 years it might be a
completely different sea change in terms
of how we all play games the whole
industry might change look at how Sony
are thinking about look at all the stuff
from the insomnia League running a AAA
organization with those kind of games at
that kind of quality our desire and the
need for fruit that explodes right and
glass that grass that Parts perfectly
and photo realizm our demand as
consumers for games to always look like
that and anything below that I'm not
playing a 2d game I'm not paying $50 for
that Prince of Persia sorry that is we
we've worked ourselves El into this
unsustainable corner across the entire
industry look at all the layoffs yeah so
this see change regardless whether we
like it and it's it's a change of the
old
way change is going to come and and I
guess the real Crux of it is Microsoft
we've seen them try to change things
before and drive sometimes a little
little premature even though it may be
the right direction even though
ultimately it may ultimately yeah often
it's the wrong wrong time right wrong
time and is this another scenario like
that may maybe you know I think people
wanting for this to to to score points
and to you know and I get it you as a as
a consumer base have waited right wait
for xd3 wait for xd3 wa for next D3 for
years to resolve the the hubris of the
Xbox One era and now that the you know
when I get the chance is finally here
that you can do that and they no snap
they're not doing it I get it I
understand I would just encourage people
to just calm down and about it like3
trillion bus doesn't really care about
this stuff oh God Tim dogs here yeah I
got I got to get the dog we got this is
a big day we got to get the dog in here
so look are you sure you can keep going
like I know you usually got stuff in the
afternoon listen let me let me get the
dog in here because um Tim really
resonates on this subject specifically
because this is OG this is this is this
is one when I first met this man you had
a project that tow shirt on at E3 I
never forget and he bleeds he bleeds
Xbox you know what I'm saying like K
you's been in the fire for day one and
you know I saw your tweets on your
timeline most recently especially in
reference to um this potential change
this potential shift um now obviously
SEO Xbox era shout out to them have
broke the news that you know adct and I
and IP Lords Lords Gamers also sat on
but um we just wanted to collaborate a
little bit more but yeah like now that
this is out there poten potentially
right Starfield potentially going to PS5
we hearing the rumors we've heard the um
you know the comments as far as um the
gentleman from zenax make that statement
on the podcast in reference to a
potential State of the Union from Phil
Sarah Bond regarding this new potential
Direction where is Tim do sit with
everything and then I got to I got to
bring up one thing not to be messy but I
saw a tweet from you that maybe a while
back that you were like if Starfield was
one of them joints
yeah you might be out so where where did
you sit or or how you processed hey this
is where it's going where you at
hopefully you guys can hear me on the
phone yeah the situation is I'm out uh
oh Tim wait Tim no we losing the
dog Lo well you know I mean listen I'm
not GNA be disrespectful and hating on
things like some other creators do I'm
wouldn't be nice about it okay uh but uh
listen it comes to a point where you
know um XBox fans have been very loyal
to the platform and very loyal to people
the executives which are all good guys
um but there comes a time where there's
just there's just too much to to bite
off and I think this is this is that
time you know you had you had the PC you
started with that we said okay we did a
lot of other things we said okay we'll
deal with
it s we sat through it with no games in
2017 um and no games in
2022 uh the thing the thing the thing is
the reason why I'm out is because listen
you can't tell me two years prior that
Xbox is going this route we're going to
be
exclusive and now you because of your
mistakes and because you can't foot the
bill we're doing exactly the opposite to
me that's not consumerism to me that's
that's something that um you know is is
just something I can't get behind uh I
me what I say I say what I mean um I
understand what they're
doing and and uh it's it's I understand
what they're doing okay but I can't I
can't I can't be behind okay it's just
from what I said but I get it um it
makes sense the gentleman just speaking
was was completely correct but just a
point where it just goes too far I
remember hearing after Xbox one that
their main thing is to regain the trust
in the consumer
well you just threw that out again the
mess with this has been completely the
worst thing the way they handled this
has been absolutely the worst way you
can go about it they couldn't have
written it up worse than they did and
now here they are and Sarah should be
the person that has to they said the
queen out
there this not her M I get I got you I I
just want to ask you a question because
I'm In fairness I want to play the role
of the other side just before you do I
hate to interrupt you on your own show I
just wanted to say uh Nate the hate uh
has just corroborated oh we got Nate the
hate on it too that report so I saw it
on Twitter so I'm just saying I
feel you standing on business I got you
I got you I got you I got you Xbox era I
got you so my my thing is the wound
obviously is raw it's fresh the news
just came out and this is I'm not going
to minimize this would be a devastating
blow for again the verbiage that was
told not the emotionality that other
people can't play it right but the
verbiage that was told prior that g
places where Game Pass exists you know
these are exclusive you know obviously
the quotes in Prior so my question is
this to you Tim as Gamers right we've
seen shifts and we have to say Xbox has
generally when in terms of where the
industry is going they have been ahead
right we we have to give them that where
we me you come from me and you come from
OG Xbox hard driving the box and EET in
the box and people laughed to say what
are you doing nobody has ethernet we all
on AOL with you know 336 modems or
whatever we had right then people said
who's doing online right who's doing
party chat Xbox Live I don't know we had
that then we get 360 era why are we
buying HD TVs right right Usher in that
era we we've had even the connect people
now say Alexa tell at the time it was a
spy cam right even TV too much TV right
now we got The Last of Us series we got
so in defense of them if they see
something people in the chat kill
Tim Tim not like this hold I know you
goinge get go ahead Tim down tweet I
gotta quote tweet Tim not like this Tim
not not like this not gotta say that
PlayStation 5 Pro becomes very enticing
yo
bro is this a whole time out time out
time out bro Happ I had a lot of I done
had a lot of conversations with you bro
and um I was listening to you I was
chuckling and buckling it was fun it was
fun it was cute and you know being
emotional in the moment is one thing
don't put out that that you delete that
delete he got to delete that now you
delete that you
delete wait he imprisoner at the moment
listen listen I don't care how many
pictures of it is out there I don't care
about that I let let them live with a
picture let them live with a picture you
know I love you hold on hold on hold on
I love you to death I love you to death
this is wrong CH chill OG chill let let
these dudes fight they fight first bro
all right let us let us let us listen
listen listen
listen let us let us let us Shob listen
list talking listen let us let let us
pick up our champion listen let us pick
up let us pick up our champion after he
falls because you know listen you know
me out these OG's going at it let's go
he just said have them come out make
they did they
did okay out he went to
shobi so they say they leak it they leak
Tim Tim come on control leaks Tim we
don't deserve
that Tim go ahead let them fight Let
Them Fight first oh listen they're going
to be number one faster than no no no I
don't care about that part listen listen
what I'm talking about Let Them Fight
eternally first before we jump out of
here yeah I know but I want to see my
man dragged out first so so so ttim ttim
we know you plugged in they can reverse
course they should so so Tim we know you
plugged in you you you feel that they've
already it's already the capitulation
yeah yeah yeah he know he know they been
he know they so so so all right Tim
let's talk then so if we had
to I know you're ask here's the thing
they're very smart in what they're doing
my personal issue is something personal
you can't tell me one thing and then
expect to follow in Reverse principali
principalities this Italian the way they
went about this is not the right way you
go about it tell people like you you
tell people like King listen we're going
to go this route can you try to get
behind us this is the thing we couldn't
do it they well I wasn't going to get
behind it I'm a Reggie this but go
ahead listen the the problem is is is
that it's just they went around about it
wrong they're caught in between a rock
in a hard place now and the problem is
is that yes they're going to be number
one first this is the smart move but you
can't go about it the way you did you
can't hide and you can't be shreding
secrecy and then you give controlled
leaks to come out and put us through
this for four weeks or whatever it's
been since
I when he said he should have just came
out and said we're bringing star listen
listen listen let me this I might still
be in the in let let me say this time
out time out time out let me say this
man oh let's go this deep fake is
crazy is this a deep fake all right this
deep fake is crazy oh yo y listen that's
not my boy Tim this this a this is AI
this is that's not that's not that's not
my boy Tim and y'all got my boy Tim
hostage all right anyway and listen
listen listen if I find if I find out
where you are I got a particular set of
skills all right come on that's the
whole that's T listen listen listen
listen listen ain't nothing gonna stop
me from going to get my guy Tim all
right
so I'm free my guy
so this AI bot that you got working
right now a working I'm say this we got
let finish though we got let fake Tim
hold on fake Tim hold on fake oh man
like this gbt Tim chat gbt Tim um Let me
let me let me let me tell you something
Tim let's
go this is a Playstation fans wet
nightmare this is I mean this is their
wet dream this is our
nightmare this this whole thing sounds
like a PlayStation fan wrote it up oh
and slid it under the
door every let me tell you something
stop falling for the leaflets falling in
the in the battlefield picking them up
reading them talking about you losing
the war it's
propaganda we not gonna eat none of the
propaganda
pancakes fake Tim don't fall for
this listen listen listen and I
I want all of these dudes listen I don't
care I don't care until she comes out on
that stage till they for her out on that
stage and I want to see I want to see
them I want to see somebody push you in
the back and she turn around say Okay
I'mma do it I'mma do it already I want
her to turn around say that and let them
know that this is fced this is fced on
her and she's out there we just gave you
the job so you're gonna have to go out
there you G have to say this damn it
damn it all money ain't good money I
wanted to get up there and rip it up and
say Xbox Manan I ain't about this let
let me ask him a question I got you let
me just ask them a question to your
defense and they set you up and I want
all you Xbox fans to leave so I want her
to do that I want pher resign the same
day I want M booty to throw computers
off the
roof let let me let me let me ask this
Happ bro let me ask this to Tim in your
defense K cuz sik you you made a great
point in your article in reference to an
internal this seems to be consistent
across the board regardless of what is
there seems to be an internal debate
right whether there be two you know
Waring factions as far as the future of
Xbox's Direction so Tim what about the
idea that the faction that may be
currently losing the fight which is you
know wanting them stay the course right
one in Xbox games to be exclusive Game
Pass y ya Y what about the idea that
they may be wanting this to get out so
that we as the the base or the ecosystem
can rally and show you know what I'm
saying whatever I understand the whole
points about here your thoughts will be
considered in King's defense in King I
will I will throw King AB bone today in
King's defense we we had a somewhat
similar situation with the games with
gold remember that remember it was all
already signed and done ready to go and
the community stood up and said oh hell
no we don't want that and then we had
the course correction hey we did wrong
by us whatever and then that eventually
evolved into what I would say Game Pass
core you know a year or whatever later
but games to go so do you think there's
any chance for that or still you still
standing on like no this is the
direction that you're hearing let's go
let let me make this point and I gota
get Cal all right Fair let's
go you guys you brother awesome best
podcast a thank you brother it is not
going to change this is real they're
going to go digital first they're going
to go full party first uh and those are
the right decisions if you really think
about it yeah that's GNA bring money to
the to that's going to pay the rent
that's G to keep the lights on and
that's going to keep them going as far
as their Hardware I would not Greenlight
it I would not Greenlight the next
Hardware which has been Greenlight I
would not do it their Hardware is not
going to sell anymore they do this
that's what you think I think yeah I
think that yeah I think that that's over
with and I think that there's no this is
this is gone beyond the level of that g
Game Pass tweet uh this is gone to a
level there'll be more outrage but
they're just gonna have to eat it
because you know what at the end of the
day I hate to say it even Tim Dog still
be probably on Game Pass because you
know what it doesn't cost as much money
as getting a Sony and getting and
getting it and you know what now they're
getting the the Sony guys to buy their
games right now after the case year
exclus but it's going to be day and date
it's all going there they're going
digital they're probably going digital
maybe this year you might not you not at
the end of the year you might not be
able to walk in the store and buy Xbox
games they're dead Hardware wise uh this
unsuspecting that the hardware was where
it's at and uh yeah no there's CFOs at
play right now and there's no there's no
walking this back Tim last one question
like sure I guess in in terms of like to
help us understand that side and this
like what have you like what is the
mindset is it a situation where it's
like we do this to survive we do this
because you know we have the numbers we
have the data or is it greed we're doing
this to extract they're wrong they're
wrong that they're making the critical
mistake that they made uh the Adam orth
era that the social discourse on social
media doesn't matter it's it's just in a
vacuum you know what that holds true but
when you when you get to this point it
starts to trickle out casuals are
affected they just won't they won't
touch the brand so they're wrong there
as as far as is it uh for them to keep
the lights on and they need to do it
yeah they probably do they just didn't
make the money you saw what happened
with Starfield a great game but it was
just completely sniped out by media by
everyone trying to hate on the game when
it comes to PlayStation it's going to
sell like crazy um and they're going to
make their money it's just they they did
making this transition if you read Tim's
comment once again and Well Fargo it
points it all out the connect the dots
they're there um like I said it might be
a smart move it's just a move that I
can't jusy I don't want to lose you
brother I don't want to lose you you've
been in the tree list you're not gonna
lose me I'm still gonna be on Xbox just
I'm not gonna be the the guy that's
going to E3 and I don't get to see you
oh come on I don't get this I don't get
my my bro hug we don't get drinks no
more we don't go to the we don't we
ain't going to be in the theater no more
we probably go to met games maybe
so wait you ain't sitting foot in the
Microsoft theater we we ain't going to
see the
event maybe I'll go to Jeff's Jeff will
proba oh man you going to summer game
like this question Tim Tim uh right now
obviously you said they green lit the
the next Xbox do you think if the cells
are just horrible like halfway through
next gen they just cut the cord on the
console yeah it doesn't matter at that
point you're going to have a p a PC in a
handheld uh fund or whatever it's going
to be listen their next console is going
to be like a switch you're going to take
they're going to have a cloudbased thing
you rip off your cons we do we doing we
doing two skills we doing how many SK we
do I could comment a little bit on I I
have some Hardware stuff but too I got
that too you me you got the same me you
got the same
sources love you too Tim Tim love you
peace we going to talk brother you I
want to still see you though I'm say I
love you deep breaths Tim take deep
breaths it's GNA be okay I mean I would
just raise I would raise this point
right like we talk about Hardware um and
the problem that I
think or at least I consider Microsoft
facing here is okay let's live in a
world where game passes are exclusive
right so now you develop hardware for
that but then if I was a third party
publisher and I'd be looking at it and
being like well okay one uh G is
Microsoft if if your Hardware is is now
less valuable because eventually you're
going to release your games elsewhere
well I'm I'm just going to release my
games here because it's cheaper for me
right now Microsoft if they wanted to
bring Game Pass to everything well those
third party deals where they launch
exclusively on Game Pass well they're
going to evaporate because why would a
third party publisher do that at all
right because right now they're only
paying for if you just do it on Xbox
right that can't transcend then into
switch and Playstation or whatever
platform so that's a problem but by
getting out of Hardware or they're
removing the very heart of their game
pass subscriber base like it doesn't
like I you could say oh well we could
make Game Pass really complicated and
maybe just have first party games on
alternative platforms but then you've
got to think about all the cost of
developing it and the ports for all of
those platforms the support for all of
those platforms I I you know like look
we don't know and I this is the thing I
would just encourage everybody to just
you know until they have to come out and
say something you know as far as as far
as our sources confirmed that's planned
for this month right February right uh
maybe that gets bumped up I don't know
um at this point at this point be next
week I've ruined a few people's Sundays
but um you know like look we're we're a
small out there and you know i' I've got
to go and work on the Rebrand now you
know gaming era oh what you got you got
the Xbox era no more I know don't know
I joke I joke we going to be third party
era but we doing let's let's see what
the actual statements are you know
they've got to explain to us if this is
all oh King had ultimate laugh none of
this happened though I will say this
this will be the ultimate King stood 10
toes down on everything if this remember
we did this the last
time the wild the wildest thing is the
wildest thing is the last time with the
akk all you suckers sit there and you
report got got got a new email and from
what I heard that they lost and they
going to have to back it up and all you
suckers Jumping Ship running around the
block talking about it's done is a done
deal see y'all forgot exactly how hold
the line came out what that was about
ADV y take it and yall move it around to
fit whatever the hell that y'all want to
fit it to y'all want to say do you want
to hold the line now King I held the
line the ABK deal came through when
telling us it was only 10% that it was
going to get when dud walking away
talking about oh Microsoft lost the you
suckers sat there all of you all of you
walked away and left them for Dead Oh
while I watch the team go up there 10
toes down and strong and then Nintendo
went up there and didn't say a word so
what you do when they say they're going
to give them high fire R ft give it to
them they sat there and they stood
strong when you didn't when you was a
sucker you all talking about oh now we
don't want a high five rush to go over
there when they stood told but you
didn't so you don't get to say you don't
get to say you don't get to say where
what goes and what what do you've been
scared your whole life so right now
Nintendo gonna get high five rush and
Sony gonna get popey's bisiness oh they
get you standing on it you dudes want to
sit there and cry ahead of time you
going to have to put fear in me it ain't
inside of me looking at all you dudes
fearful and cowardly talking about oh
I'm out of here now oh because they
doing that and this stuff is looking
attractive that stuff look just like
they other stuff w
i y'all can sit there and you Ain going
nowhere this is Xbox front line I'm not
changing the name of my
show out so y going to either stand down
or walk away and if y'all already in
your heart talking about and you're
going to do that then y'all already
walked away Phil knock them out and I'm
here with
you oh all that go Ed I don't agree with
this mindset that you know the
internet the internet is a bubble and it
it's not as big as people think um I
have family members that think Xbox T
got old games you know how they saw that
from Tik Tok memes uh people people put
this like limmit limiter on what they
think the internet's capable of the
internet has made multi-trillion dollar
companies been they need in Reverse
policies and you don't think that that
internet that same
internet can't completely demolish
console sales for the Xbox whatever the
next console is at this point Dead Zone
I I don't know like it's just like I
think
people I don't like the fact that
they're like we're not considering any
type of information that the online
personas or you know just people on the
internet in general say because it's
just like I I you know I I get it some
of you even on the panel disagree with
me but from someone that's always on Tik
Tok I never see Xbox and anything never
see Xbox on shorts never see Xbox
anywhere I go and what do I see I either
see anti Xbox stuff or Playstation oh
you know they put PlayStation on on
subways one could argue that's maybe why
they're doing it they've already lost
and they're just like yeah okay let's
just make our
money what do we care about conso let's
make our money and get out of there but
but here's the thing like I don't like
the fact that we try to label everything
as console Wars I know I know I I say it
mostly because just because someone
feels like this isn't good for the brand
and I don't think it's good for the
brand
I new we got more
news Tom Warren scoop Microsoft is
considering bringing Indiana Jones to P
S5 several months after the Xbox PC
release it's part of a new Xbox strategy
inside Microsoft that's emerging as of
one minute ago see and now right there
no one's buying an Xbox for Indiana
Jones and people think that is not going
to translate to the next
gen I guarantee you next gen sell the
sales will be so bad that they'll cut
support halfway in a new multiplatform
approach for certain Xbox game is
emerging we are told with the company
weighing up which titles will remain
exclusive and others that will appear on
switch and PS5 Indiana Jones appears
part of this new wave of multi-platform
games and they talked about the initial
part and then he goes into the high five
rush but nothing newer other than that
he said last year they know that last
year we learned from the FTC case that
indan Jones was originally planned for
multiple consoles Pete Hines bethesda's
former head of global publishing
testified that Disney had a contract for
multiple consoles and that the deal was
amended to be an Xbox console exclusive
after Microsoft's acquired Bethesda
Hines put the change down to point
potential delays and bringing the game
to multiple consoles adding that you're
dealing with the licenser who's going to
have a ton of feedback on what you're
making he says as Indiana Jones on PS5
was certainly be a surprise we're told
there's an intense debate internally at
Microsoft over which Xbox games to bring
the Rival consoles it now looks like
Microsoft has settled on some Xbox
titles making their way to PS5 and
Nintendo switch but like I said said a
month the devil will be in the details
this was just broken right now by timing
Mr Warren interesting timing you try to
eat you try to eat
on hey Co let me let me speak on that
for a moment um so I I had heard about
some things about Indiana Jones a little
while ago and and for and this was also
around around the time the whole blade
thing came out and people was wondering
at this point blade def multier blade is
definitely multier so so you also
remember when there was the Insomniac
league and we saw the the the contract
breakdown between Disney Marvel Studios
and PlayStation and they had the whole
part where it was like where Disney
could back out where if they didn't
reach a certain number of sales for for
I think Wolverine or maybe Spider-Man to
one of those games I think it m been
xman but if they didn't reach a certain
number of sales that that it was that
was negotiated between um Disney and
Sony that Sony could pull the I mean
Disney could pull the plug with the
contract that is a similar structure to
what zenx media had in place for Indiana
Jones and and blade and so but to a
lesser degree and with that said like
Disney don't care if it's exclusive or
not they don't care all they care about
is are you going to deliver on what's
the what was expected in the contract
are you going to give us are you going
be able to sell what you're what you're
supposed to sell to fulfill our part of
that and if they feel like can't do that
on just Xbox and PC and that environment
that they got to go to other platforms
to do so then that's the choice that
they're going to make now I I look at
all of this how you how you I remember
back in the day I remember back in the
day remember with the whole DRM thing
and and Sony pivoted very quickly
because they do better marketing than
all admit that we all know they had DRM
you share your games yes right and and
and that went outside of the little
hardcore community ecosystem even casual
gamers knew what that meant what what do
they do when when after they announce
all this and PlayStation's marketing
goes PlayStation the only console you
need and under that that slogan they're
showing their first party games right
and then they're also showing fortnite
and then they're also showing Call of
Duty and then they're showing Starfield
and hii Rush all of your first party
games right what is your response then
like what what do you Market to people
who aren't already in your ecosystem to
bring them to Xbox when all they have to
do is like well I could buy a
PlayStation you don't have their games
but they getting your games right the
concern of the you can't control that
narrative you can't control that
narrative at that point or they're not
getting all of our games how do you
convinced them them that that's the case
that's truly the case that Halo
there's
n no I get it I get it um I'll jump in
cuz I know we went long I probably have
to dead the last topic cuz this is just
crazy day today already Rin your no bro
yeah this is we got to talk about got a
chance to say about the hand oh I'm
sorry oh I'm sorry my bad my bad no no
cuz we we was just jumping in and out
doing stuff yeah yeah my fa no no let's
let's finish up the handheld let's
finish up let's get um they both gonna
make handhelds uh I thought PlayStation
would be uh the way that they going all
right the investment company that was
they have annual Investments and they
were looking at the viability of the
PlayStation 5 and Sony as far as stock
options and stuff like that goes that
was in December I reported it on one of
my uh Xbox Frontline news uh videos uh
they came to the assessment that the
PlayStation 5 will fall short of the 25
million that they projected for that
fiscal period and it was only going to
make1 million and then they suggested
that the PlayStation 6 don't don't be a
viable option instead they should scale
back on hardware and um produce
something that of a lesser degree like a
switch was a for instance then I got the
rumor about the handheld for the uh
nintend I mean for the PlayStation brand
by AMD right and that stuff is being
worked
on then I got the rumor about uh the
Microsoft thing and then jez came out
kind of substanti appr that right so my
thought process is being that these
dudes work with the same people
AMD and they're seeing where the economy
is going and the sales is going and
they're chasing the Nintendo sales do
they dead consoles within their self and
just make the handhelds the portable
console that you can dock that you can
hook up to your TV and could you still
have this level of uh generational you
know graphics and stuff like that in a
handheld because you guys like The Rock
right you like stuff like
that are both of their strategies to
dead the traditional Hardware go the
soft the the hardware as a um the switch
where is a hybrid and continue to put
their storefronts as many places they
possibly can because both of them have
the same strategy and get in their
storefronts across many different
devices but also having their home
device where they can make the most
amount of money for the people that's
inside their closing ecosystem I've
heard things about this like John has
heard things I have to be careful um
what I will say is that in reference to
you know the the the the the the
companion or the portable device yeah
that I do think in the past I was
wanting to say that they probably
wouldn't do it they didn't want to make
another skew you know kind of thing but
I have to admit listening to I think
it's I'm going to blame you JZ listen
your latest article
in reference to um XBox you know one to
come out I mean should come out with a
mobile and he's very you know bullish
about
it it seems like that that mentality
could have potentially changed and you
look at the success of the steam deck
you look at the success of the rag allly
and the combing device because what the
reality is this what you're saying King
in reference to like I said you look at
the Google and apple storefronts and
these kind of wall Gardens where you
kind of have to deal with them you got
to have to if you're Microsoft and
playst you have to deal with them right
so why not have your own device right
and the way things are these chipsets
and what is it the Z1 extreme that's in
the ra Alle like these chipsets are
powerful it's already A3 in like it's
the technology is only going to get
better the only issue would be the
battery life but it it's the perfect
companion device because then you put
your own OS your software your stuff
into you know this this um this
ecosystem that is proven that people
want it they still want to take it and I
think maybe it's the only thing say it
maybe if there is another generation
maybe this becomes a skew that replaces
the S because I'm going be honest with
you you know once the Ally came out I
stopped kind of using little man because
I have literally more power and that
functionality in a smaller device with a
smaller footprint right that can still
play all these games so now if I had a
the only problem with the Ally is that
it's basically Windows 11 it's no youi
like you know what I'm saying that's
terrible and I know that was one of your
main frustrations with allies like bro
yeah that's why the steam deck was
better with the user face that's why
steam wins out because it's literally
that's their their their gaming
ecosystem boom boom boom that's what
people Gamers want so if you throw that
and then you combine that with a um you
know what you call it footprint uh a
backup cloud footprint because I do feel
these need to be native we need to have
native game pass we need to that's what
makes the Ally dope right and remember
when I saw the Ally I was there at its
debut my Microsoft Hardware teams were
in the building AMD was in the build
they are looking at what's going on here
so maybe now this has if if the rumors
are true that there will be an
accelerated console generation would it
be 2026 2027 then yeah maybe they they
they include this and as part of their
approach but John I'm G leave this to
you because I think we both know the
same things and I'm just trying to check
as very carefully as I can but you you
can do the honors as far as what what
you feel about this thing yeah like I I
don't want to say too much in that uh I
I have heard some things about the new
strategy I've heard some things about
the team that are developing that
strategy um and its
aspirations uh I'm intrigued like as a
as a as a an Xbox Manor uh I would love
a you know a handheld and if they're
going to do the the to skew approach um
it makes sense to give me one big
powerful box or the alternative choice I
would agree with that of a of a handheld
that can dock right and I would I would
buy both um quite happily I got to get
John Trick today he's we know we do
right now man this has been the worst
Sunday in a crazy this Su my kids today
and yeah like I wasn't planning on
publishing this until tomorrow but I had
to I had to push sooner because I think
it it you know it was getting out there
yeah um yeah it is it is I think a the
right course of action in terms of
Hardware my concern comes from
um you know how long does this Hardware
last you know like if the strategy is
Game Pass is the exclusive like you buy
our box you get all of it no worries you
only have to pay as much as you would
have to pay for three or four games a
year but if you lock clients in like
that and eventually like Netflix like
everything else you're going to up the
price you're going to up the price
you're going to up the
price why why would you just choose that
one uh I I I feel personally it's wrong
decision for Microsoft in terms of if
this is the strategy
I'm not going to overreact because I
haven't heard the full strategy yet um I
do think there is some uh truth to the
internal struggle in terms of the reason
this is out there is because there are
some people internally in that
organization that value the old ways of
the console battle right and want to see
that played out um I think I can't
remember who said it on our show
yesterday but you know the point was
made of you've just you've just you've
just invented you know the the gun like
in a in a race where no one's got a
gunpowder yet and you haven't fired it
instead you're gonna give the gun to
everybody else and and then just you
know make money from that maybe you
should see how things pan out first
we'll see we'll see you know and and I
can't remember was it addict or uh or
King who made the point about you know
we've seen scenarios before where
Microsoft rightly or wrongly are the
most connected to their consumer base
like on Twitter on social All That Jazz
comparatively to all the rest you don't
see Jim Ryan jumping on you know sacred
symbols or any of that [__] right sorry
I can't help I'm British I'm sorry I'm
sorry you don't see that right but the
the Peril of doing that is that the all
of us to a degree feel we are OD in
explanation right we feel a personal
connection a little bit more than you
would to the average EX in a suit right
and that's that's a a great benefit at
times and in times like this it's a it's
a big negative because all of that
Outreach that's this where this feeling
of betrayal almost is coming from I I
don't agree with it fully but I totally
understand it so I would just plead for
calm let's let's let Monday morning
arrive the week play out let it play out
I I I apologize to anyone in PR who is
reading this and hating me right now um
for respect the hustle
um respect the hustle respect the bag I
got
you don't hate the play the game look
man say I feel you I feel you I feel
look I I'm intrigued to see what you
know this has been the most interesting
generation we've had so far let's see
how this ride go how plays out very
interesting we got we got to move this
has been a day this has been a day but
um look I'm going to skip the last topic
if that's okay guys because we kind of
did stay to play already we did that
already I will change the titles cuz we
had breaking news on this but um yeah
like I agree I think that um you know we
we definitely want got to see how this
plays out officially you know what is
said but if it does and if this is
whatever this is a major inflection
point and we will see if said strategy
was right strategy we will see you know
if it gives the div desired effect that
a certain Factor may want or we will see
that maybe because of the things like
today that um the other group has
ammunition to you know warn that that
this would be negative feedback I don't
know I don't know how this is going to
play I can't predict the future that's
these guys but that's all I got I want
to give an outros to my man's actually
actually before we do that let me um let
me hit actually let me hit the poll real
quick and uh how many super chats we got
uh ad is it
crazy I don't know I stop all right so
while you do that let me do some outros
because I I've been holding slowmo
holding these guys hostage slow-mo back
slap on an
eventful Sunday where can the fine
people find you what you got going on
Sir oh man look I I appreciate the
invite it was it was a good time um very
shocking as as the as the day went on my
my you know you guys could see my eyes
my eyes were getting
bigger what
I people want me to say some other
things I'm not going to say y y'all will
find out some other stuff I guess as the
week goes past so I'm just going to keep
it there um I again I I love you guys I
love being Hest it's always a good time
you know you know what I miss though
what you miss I miss playing fortnite
with King
David Once Upon a Time King David used
to send me invites and I'll be on
fortnite what what I what I did I
stopped because you stopped showing up
don't don't don't come out there and
share me bro I'm on every day actually
right now I was scheming on how soon as
I'm finished with this my black behind
is right over there right now so yeah
yeah to make a video I want them invites
I got I'm there thank you thank you um
no but no um you can find me on damage
per second podcast with the homie
gameing Forte we we do our little Duo
thing Thursday nights 900 p.m Eastern
Standard time we do it on our own
channel as well as the DPS Channel I
throw the uh oh nice I throw the um that
link the the link in the chat there for
everybody there we go go subscribe to
that right there y'all come on yeah
really appreciate that um had a good
time as usual I hope you guys enjoy the
rest of your weekend and uh you know I
won't over
PC but look King you're welcome over
here on PC as well listen listen I got
that NZXT buts too don't don't don't
don't come for me unless I S for
you listen listen listen I'll I'll I'll
use it when I have to but I'mma call I'm
calling for every Xbox dude if this is
real You Got Game Pass I want you to go
to your game pass subscription and
delete it call them call them up and say
say say you know what y'all like them
numbers that we put out last
week
FTW like Let It Burn not like you going
to disrespect and I'mma show youall when
I'mma you going to see me go to game
pass and delete my game pass if that
happen y'all going to feel it now I'm
not saying I'm not going to reenact it
the next week but oh you going to
reenable the next week you you a
symbolic that one week you going to
catch hell that one week that one week
and then you back but I'll be back on
broes the week later because I'm a
hypocrite but I'm tell you right now
listen this is the fraudery this Xbox
yell all we want they going to S what
they going to say where they going to
say you going to see that you ain't got
no power B so all right we could cry and
yell and no
please let them boys go and and play
something I don't care they've been
begging forever them Port begging ponies
oh seem to have gotten their way all
right they they CED to the right dude
the right dude heard you poor you CED to
the right God you poor begging ponies
now you going to get what you asked for
oh remember oh Starfield don't have a
moon that is quite like
uhi kima's moons his so you gonna be
playing these moons all you dudes that
couldn't get to gas planets and was
talking all that crap I want to see
y'all get to these gas planets now all
you suckers that oh high to be over here
I want to see these numbers up now cuz
you suckers thought oh we fearful we
know you don't buy games and we know
that experiment is going to fail and
they're going to take it back from you
and when they take it back it's going to
be worse because you're going to be like
they was given us and they're going to
come to the screen and said the
experiment failed these suckers don't
buy games and we're not putting no more
stuff over there because it's a waste of
time so yeah we GNA y'all experiment we
gonna find out if you buy games
suckers and there you have it from the
King yeah don't shout out to my man Joe
a g lie you got me that was that was
hilarious shout out to Joe S shout out
to Xbox era breaking this thing
Starfield the whole situation let me
shout you out brother it's unfortunate
it took this to get you of the time Z
real quick I want to make a public
statement yes yes I want to
apologize for what the community put G
through when he started all this
nonsense a couple months ago G guys been
on people were attacking him like crazy
and I want to apologize I didn't do it
but man guys you know why I blame you
guys you the one that started all this
sh when you when you leaked it Xbox it's
like you know what he might be on
to now shout out to to siik man again
fortunately they took this because
normally time zones usually always
assume that you know you guys we never
when we go this long then it links up it
works but normally we're not in the 6
hour bag every time
right what yeah not every time usually
three to four but again shout out to you
where can a find people find you what
you got going on Sir uh I I I appreciate
I know this is weird circumstances
coming on but I appreciate being able to
jump on and and at least clarify it um a
little bit and yeah it's it's a pleasure
to to always be in the in the presence
of the Lords of the realm um you guys
have got a great community and and I I
love the energy of this show it's
completely
nuts oh it's crazy anything can happen
I'm like I I think I have a hard time
controlling Nick and I'm like wow you
know Jesus I'm a
good seriously if uh you know folks
watching you Xbox z.com you'll get way
to everything huge stuff plan for this
this year and the only thing I'll say is
we've got we've got episode 200 coming
up now cast your mind's back what we did
for episode 100 episode 200 we're going
to have a lot of cool stuff to announce
so uh I'm trying to
for you
I'm no doubt no doubt they going to have
Jim Ryan
on spilling all the
tea a third party era third party era oh
everybody got change their podcast name
we lord we good we good that apply to
everything listen listen listen third
party front line keep it
up oh no not thir oh man we got to rebre
let's look at the trade marks y'all I'm
feeling on fing them Yo you stupid I
can't with you Lord yo that was wild
funny add he's on fire right now Lord ad
where can to find people find you what
you got going on sir you can find me on
YouTube at gaming ad you can also find
my streaming YouTube channel addict
Arena I'm on Twitter at Lord
addict third party Arena we ain't
changing it I'm messing with you I'm
being stupid okay sorry no I didn't hear
what you said I said third party Arena
we ain't going to change it no I mean
it's ad Arena you good you good your
brand is good you good you good I didn't
name my stff after Xbox that's a king
problem that ain't a me problem Ain got
nothing to do with you trust trust me it
ain't a problem at all
bro no doubt no doubt that's it tic uh
yeah I'm gonna I was going to stream
after this but now I got to make a video
so yeah I know you is what it is I know
you about to cut all right oh it's it's
going to be like probably 15 20 maybe
even 30 minutes long I don't know maybe
maybe I'll rant and it just never ends I
just be talking here till next week do
me a favor if you can line up the super
chats I'll read the poll if you get the
super chats ready cool I don't even know
where we ended but I'mma try try your
best man I know without solve we we
crazy all right I just don't know I'll
let you guys
brother thank you brother cat you later
love I don't know the last thing he read
is the I can't remember either if I had
yeah it it's been a crazy day bro yeah
let me bow
brother looking at me looking at you
wild crazy yo yo slow thank you for
holding you guys yeah yeah yeah thank
you I'm gonna say gu slow um I'm I'm
gonna say addict it was damn this is a
lot s money P we you have to read this
crazy because they're going to keep us
here all day if we read these yeah like
officially king living in they're going
to bully us okay I know T I know kid
smoo reread that so I'm going just go
after that and just quick ball it like
stay with me and we'll just how about we
just back and all right cuz I got I'll
switch but I got to do the poll I do the
poll okay do the poll all right cool
with steadily increasing rumors of Xbox
fundamentally changing their strategy
regarding the first party games on other
platforms what do you think should be
their best approach moving forward a
don't put your games on other console
platforms devalue game passing your
brand B experiment with a few older
titles and only if this helps sustain
Xbox future C whatever decision you make
communicate ASAP you owe it to your base
or D I don't care cats sleeping with
dogs everybody going to put their gains
everywhere anyway shout out to that all
is going to go up at some point tonight
whenever this podcast end or maybe
tomorrow because it is a crazy day all
right adct let's go knock these super
chats out so let's just I'll read one
you read don't stop commentary okay we
trying to get out of here so let's start
after the kid smoth I know for a fact we
read that unstable Lis with the $ trap
Microsoft has to sacrifice a few games
they're doing it because they're in
buying something and it's not Sega it's
bigger and that's why they are not
talking all right JD gamer f h Super
Chat Phil booty Bond Remember the Alamo
protect the brand Xbox is a brand has a
value that the numbers guys don't
understand and can't easily quantify we
got uh GSD getting stuff done with the
$5 sub Money Talks everything else walks
after they spent nearly 100 billion they
are the company's thirdd largest part
time to uh time to pay the stock holders
s Jitsu Sage $10 Super Chat never follow
a crowd number of people saying
something means zero no one knows
everything ABK and Bethesda caught all
off guard I respect adic voice concerns
and hope they don't in hopes they don't
become a reality why from the dawn
cjg uh Philly the boys don't need to
address the third party allegations
publicly small minority on line is just
blowing out of proportion JD gamer $5
Super Chat let's not have another Xbox
One Moment data did that gaming is about
a connection and desire to play games
data is inconsistent when predicting
that then we got5 Super Chat from Raiden
blade PS Community is all mouthless
service they don't buy their own games
so why will they buy uh Xbox games they
Port begging just to say we don't need
an Xbox JD gamer toot Super Chat
pathetic Port begging ponies got no
games # no
PSX from the W Credit Union uh that's uh
what's his name R Kelly yeah R Kelly he
says K is living in a Fool's Fantasy
game pass was never viable in the long
run now we seen the negative effects get
back to exclusives he right well why
didn't't you call in on Fridays you
mustard
hearted sit there you can sit there hide
behind a tweet put your voice on Deck
bro I'm tired of suck looking over yeah
this is time to go at King you know it
was
never option is shut up they just told
you Game Pass made a boatload of bread
you mustard heart you don't know
business you Patty flipper stop worrying
about what we
talking he catching all time he you s
there talking you Patty flipper do that
toor Kelly yeah I'm messing with him oh
okay please the vot credit you he's back
Xbox flops Halo gears Starfield redf Etc
got a $5 Super Chat from sayu stage hey
cut that out we don't have to choose
between exclusives and Game Pass day one
we will have both even UB Sal and EA do
day one on Subs now yeah they do Mike
Theo $5 super chat if XBox would have
strengthened the band make an EVO for
Shooters type event Call of Duty Halo
Doom Quake OverWatch gears tournaments
all at one venue he yeah I think we did
read that one yeah we be with the member
uh chat he's been a member for 29 months
peace Lord this is all contract we are
making this up uh keeping both exclusive
games of day will day uh Game Pass is an
option I want Al Loom okay uh mad uh
0410 member for 46 months salute P PC
Gamers will not play $170 for games like
console players will pay even overseas
PC is rising more than console PC Master
race is taking over yeah that's dat $50
dudes we got to$ super chat from suu
Sage Xbox don't report numbers for Game
Pass publicly to not have it used
against Xbox over 30 million over 200
million really reality it's over 500 I
remember we said that all right Fresno
um $10 super chat if XBox blames revenue
for this move it's their self-inflicted
wounds that got them there no new games
we did that one okay the back keep your
porub yeah yeah we did that yeah we did
pull Hub with him okayu stage I don't
agree with Xbox has spoke and Microsoft
spoke to them in January we did that one
too y uh BT Maverick with the $5 you
guys did read that uh Sony's internal
leaks are saying that they were
terrified of Game Pass we did that one
too Hector the Macho with a $5 super CH
all held the powerful Lords I love the
fact that dark bill has hands on Sony's
Lifeline one wrong move byebye Sony um
sorry um I forgot where was that you
said okay there we go champag supera I
got it yeah solve hide the money y'all
there's console heathens here I'm with
Xbox to the wheel full off big Phil and
Sarah the silence is
violence we got a member trap from Craig
hooligan been a member for 17 months
Xbox should give me games day one then
milk that game for all the money on the
other platforms months later great games
for everybody we got a $5 super trap
from rubber knob Microsoft was go always
going third party
said that the exclusives were Game Pass
exists Hollywood rules to L Super Chat
so are the new consoles planned scrap
for 20126 as far as we know don't don't
think so Lord Metro he's been a m for 28
months I want to play Metro Prime 4
before I depart this moral form we read
that the list 22 been member for 35
months if the reason some titles go
third party is because they are going to
acquire more Studios Publishers to
appear regulars ABK this we read that JB
G JD gamer with the f Super Chat Kong
must die we read that too read that I
remember that yeah he's did with the $2
Super Chat keep all receipts on black
Tony star I remember that oh no black uh
dude from uh Game of Thrones $5 Super
Chat from uh Michael money what if Xbox
game are only available on other
subscription servers not stores we said
that sayu says with the $5 Super Chat
when Satur recently reported 200 million
he was referring only to mobile go read
the earning transcript Xbox over 500
yeah we read that we read Champagne
Supernova Tekken six out of six 10 I
mean 10 um none of this thing fish y we
did read the infinite Umbra okay I laws
what if Microsoft is bringing games to
Sony Nintendo platforms because they
agreed to allow Game Pass I think that
too damn we com done math a math okay
this I don't remember I think this is
where we are ilad slomovic um he said
Xbox error reporting Starfield to PS5
this where we at and that cannibalizing
PlayStation fan base have rumored to
have won salute we had a Xbox era on
Doctor Strange Love $2 Super Chat did
this explains the lack of Xbox branding
for blade interesting L Paul $2 Super
Chat Phil's retirement date wow question
that might be soon NC $2 Super Chat 2001
Sega Vibes it was fun while it lasted SJ
Jitsu Sage follow Super Chat the Xbox
error story is bogus nobody at Microsoft
would ever leak that a transparent
attempt to sabotage the games big DLC
impact on Xbox but he's laughing so I
don't think and then he chats again s j
South Super Chat to be clear you don't
believe rumors from folks who said
perfect do was a lowbudget episodic game
and we're wrong wow
Stitch if this is true the Xbox brand is
dead $2 Super Chat from NC at least star
at least red St we get to keep that
okay2 super chat
from this is wild convers Sunday wild uh
with these rumors Conor gy um 6 six
pound m has reportedly helped
PlayStation with development putting
funding for Sony that was
reported from Captain log salute I care
about quick resume play anywhere and
other features that come because of a
dedicated console development $ super
Andre Doyle it's not official until
Microsoft says it uh it's it's going to
be official trust me uh $5 Super Chat
for Michael imunity is direct X on the
chopping block we got $2 Super Chat from
Spartan 661 IOP is the event and my line
is shis Nick yeah see I know they could
be trying to make me say some crazy
stuff so I wasn't going to try to
pronounce it super chat from J rbert I'm
going down with the ship Xbox $5 Super
Chat from SJ jitu Sage remember what we
remember what the OG Peter Moore once
warn us all about this is the
PlayStation F campaign at work don't
fall for it two 500 Super Chat uh I
don't know what currency is good luck
with the Xbox expanding in Japan uh
mother uh m first can't believe this BS
I almost like hold let me get the next
one Zach Riley M six months so Starfield
going to get some updated highest scored
reviews now if it's on
Playstation yo let me get a couple n
see2 IGN will give Starfield or
Playstation a 9.5 just watch Yo they
stupid um Tim perr 21 member 14 months
King the general calling for a last
charge after president Phil signed the
surrender hey yo hey yo that's why
um Connor G uh 6 six pound holding the
line is gone PlayStation 5 and switch
have made your waves the white flags oh
here I'm I'm sitting here talking the
whole time I'm muted I'm like watch your
mouth
be andc super chat sell your Xbox now
Dreamcast was birthless in 2002 what
else we got um NC ghost of low road $20
Super Chat I haven't heard an
announcement from Phil Sarah Matt or
Aaron I'll keep it 100 I I don't like it
but I can't lie either Game Pass is the
sell for me I'm 381 OG from Sega Xbox
without Game Pass is No Deal all right
ex adus $2 Super Chat play stupid games
Win stupid prizes Xbox hashit PC time
all sjsu Sage follow out Super Chat
Microsoft set in court they renegotiated
Indiana Jones with Disney to be the
exclusive and removed PlayStation I
believe Phil in federal court over this
all right going against to war he was
telling the truth at the time but think
okay H rules all I all I know these
dudes spilling the tea better be right
your word will never be trusted after
all they changed in the month uh staying
with Bill and they going to come
back fold the line $ superat from Conor
uh gregy uh what will happen to digital
games uh Xbox players b the console's
not going anywh at the moment uh we got
childish bamboo with a he's been a for 4
months why would Xbox make a handheld
when their Hardware barely even sells
especially when their majority first
party games are going multiplay we got a
$5 Super Chat why would son Mak a
handheld when they hardware sales but
they software don't shut up got a $5
Super Chat from Chris R why buy an Xbox
when PlayStation will get all of the
Xbox games along with the PlayStation
exclusive that's my issue especially
after spending $500 don't buy it got
five uh $5 Super Chat from the woke
credit Union breaking news Starfield
coming to PS5 Microsoft buying more PS5
kids to splend up process I'm so sorry K
it's officially done now Xbox
done NC show me when it happens nc5
Super Chat what will PlayStation dudes
talk about without Xbox also $11,000 ps6
in pound you will get a second job Sony
knows there's no more competition Justin
okay Justin Ram $10 Super Chat let
Microsoft acquire Sega and fund their
vision for a new console we need
competition out here without it Sony
will just release Last of Us two remake
edition anniversary edition if they
didn't have it y why does everybody
assume Sega wants to make a
console out G her by choice uh question
uh Cog when I'm clicking the heart thing
to say we read it is it showing up on
your end yes okay I will buy a $5 from
gamer by choice I will buy an Xbox and
game passes as long as I can play the
games I want to play I cannot speak for
others but I like the platform and
controller I agree on that salute B
radio $2 Super Chat go ners salute
salute rap no doubt $5 Super Chat from
gaming Forte so proud of my Kendrick
Spirit slow mo backslab dropping all
that knowledge hey King Boo Boo Xbox
about to release the whole site oh no
hey for what's happening with
Destiny oh W
shot
bushes disly discharged from the
defectors disly discharged damn
Necromancer Zale $20 Super Chat I know
companies have to make money and don't
generally care about the people buying
from them this however feels like Xbox
is spitting in our face if this is true
20 plus years a Bu from Xbox will be
finished an ominous uh boss with the
five Super Chat Advance the line King
salute everyone down bad for begging for
Halo and gears collection Microsoft owns
C I could say hurry up and pay up
sh uh shout what's his name sad cyber
boy $10 Super Chat what she said
something um labara CH I don't know
where that is from looks like $5
Microsoft really happy to give Sony more
money a company that is still currently
working with the FTC to block the ABK
deal interesting you can read the rest
Texas member for 16 months bu in Xbox
Maine since Dreamcast Fizzles I'm not
going anywhere it's an honor to have
lived by your yo he a
he act like you ain't get shot that's an
imaginary wound just sit there keep
watching it's been an honor
sir watching
Sir it's been out of King to
go it like that is already waving the
flag a no announcement no nothing and Y
how does it you look weird when it come
out and they be like yeah we decided not
to do anything I know there's a whole
lot of rumors in the street and Phil
come out on stage and throw the mic down
and said I wish you stop talking
that yo I will say this if that your
rise will be insane again or or or the
better thing Could Happen Saia could
come out and say you know
um we uh we're gonna put our games
everywhere you know do that and Phil
come out and say yeah that's cool I
quit then we out then you delete and
game pass out yeah yeah all all I say is
this one week one week all I say is the
people that quit make it known just be
like yo yeah so what I wasn't down with
that I feel like and go on every talk
show that you want to go on the money
listen listen don't sign n all money
ain't good money just just run that
mouth Cat Williams is situation bro Let
it Loose you already know spart 661 T
Super Chat you are awesome thanks
forever your patri salute David hot
right me for 27 months rooting for the
ners car gang gang you already know
Lloyd Metroid $2 Super Chat Sega can't
even develop a decent Sonic game damn
Lloyd Metroid I think that last Sonic
game look good yeah look last one no
Shadow Jo look fire I think we have made
it we we good we good all right let's
get about anything else everybody say we
good all right look this is a big one
this is a monster Sunday we will see
y'all next week as the D settles yeah
I'mma I'mma send you guys over to weapon
will weapon whe oh yeah yeah yeah go
over there and put some IOP raids in
there man some love in the chat get all
get get along to a degree cuz I know our
fan base and their fan game probably
going to clash a little bit uh but you
know showing some love over there kid
smoo needs your
support he said K everybody enjoy your
Sunday we are out thought you heard
me